REVIEW COMMITTEE SENT TO OUR
NATURAL RESOURCES ENVIRONMENT
PROTECTION AND THEN AND ENERGY
WHICH I CARE WILL BEGIN IN
SIXTY SECONDS.
THE SENATE
BUDGET FISCAL REVIEW
SUBCOMMITTEE WILL COME TO ORDER
GOOD MORNING A RESPONSE TO THE
KOBE NINETEEN EMERGENCY AND TO
PROTECT PUBLIC LEGISLATORS IN
PLEASE PRESS ONE IF NOT A
CENTRAL GATHERING SAID HERE TO
SOCIAL DISTANCING AND FACE
COVERING GUIDELINES IN
COMPLIANCE WITH THOSE ORDERS TO
SEND HIS MADE NECESSARY
ADJUSTMENTS TO NORMAL PRACTICES
IN ORDER TO ENSURE THAT THE
PUBLIC CONTINUES HAVE
ACCESSIBILITY PROCESS WE'RE
HOLDING OUR COMMITTEE HEARING
HERE IN THE CAPITAL TODAY ALL
ALL FOUR MEMBERS OF THE
COMMITTEE WILL BE HERE IN THE
HEARING ROOM THOSE PROVIDING
TESTIMONY BEFORE THE COMMITTEE
TODAY ARE ALSO PARTICIPANTS ARE
PARTICIPATING REMOTELY FOR OUR
REMOTE PARTICIPANTS PLEASE MUTE
YOUR PHONE SYNC. OR COMPUTERS
THIS WILL GREATLY AID IN
ELIMINATING THE COULD STICK
FEEDBAK YES EVERY TIME YOU
WISH TO BE RECOGNIZED THAT YOU
USE THE RAISE YOUR HAND FEATURE%
IN THE PROGRAM EACH TIME YOU BE
RECKONED NICE TO SPEAK UP POP
UP WITH THE WILL APPEAR ASKING
IF YOU WOULD LIKE TO BUY NEW
PLEASE SELECT. BEFORE YOU BEGIN
SPEAKING ALL RIGHTY PERSONNEL
WILL PUT YOU BACK ON YOUTH WHEN
YOU'RE DONE WINTRICH NICE TO
SPEAK PLEASE MAKE SURE THAT YOU
CAN BE SEEN ONSCREEN STATE YOUR
NAME AND THEN YOU'RE READY TO
ADDRESS THE COMMITTEE TO LOVE
PUBLIC AXIS WE HAVE ADMITTED
MEMBERS OF THE PUBLIC TO THE-
TO HEARING ROOMS TO THE EXTENT
THAT SOCIAL DISTANCING
REQUIREMENTS ALLOW AND WILL BE
USING TELECONFERENCE SERVICE
FOR THOSE WHO WISH TO TESTIFY
TODAY FOR ALL INDIVIDUALS
WITHIN TO PROVIDE PUBLIC COMIC
OF CHRIS FISHING TOLL FREE
NUMBER ACCESS CODE IS POSTED AT
TODAY'S COMMITTEE WEBSITE. WILL
BE DISPLAYED ON THE SCREEN AND
I WILL NOW SIT OUT TODAY'S
PARTICIPATE NUMBER IS
844-291-6364 AND X. SIX CODE IS
FOURTEEN SEVENTEEN SIX OH NINE
FOR DETAILED INSTRUCTIONS ON
HOW THE TELECONFERENCES FROM
WORKS PLEASE REFER TO THE
SENATE ANIL COMMITTEE WEBSITE
PLEASE NOTE THAT IN ORDER FOR
US TO HEAR YOU CLEARLY INTO
BORDER ACOUSTIC FEEDBACK YOU
MUST MEET YOUR DEVICE YOU'RE
WATCHING THE HEARING ON PRIOR
TO GIVING TESTIMONY OF THE
PHONE IS IMPORTANT THAT WE HEAR
FROM YOU ONLY THANK YOU FOR
YOUR PATIENCE I WILL. MAINTAIN
DECORUM DURING HEARING HAS THIS
CUSTOMER IN ANY INDIVIDUAL
WHO'S DISRUPTIVE MAY BE REMOVED
FROM THEIR VOTE MEETING SERVICE
OR HAVE THE CONNECTION YOU TO
PUBLIC COMMENT WILL BE HEARD
AFTER. ALL DISCUSSION ITEM
SEPARATE PERCENT AT. WELL OVER
HAS BEEN MADE. TO STREAMLINED
HEARING. TECH HEARINGS IN THIS.
TO THE SAME MANNER. COST THERE
MERRY. THERE MAY BE SOME LACK.
FOR FOUR PARTICIPANTS WERE. TO
NEW U. OF ONLINE TOOLS FOR TECH.
PLEASE BE. OF PATIENTS OF
THESE. SO ALL INTERESTED
PARTIES CAN. BE HEARD. LASTLY
FOR EVERYONE PHYSICALLY PRESENT
TODAY. PLEASE KEEP YOUR MASS ON
COVER YOUR NOSE AND MOUTH AT
ALL TIMES. DOES HE TODAY'S
HEARING. WILL BE SPLIT IN. TO
TWO PARTS PART THREE COVERING
PESTICIDES FOOD AND AGRICULTURE
PART BE COVERING ENERGY ISSUES.
VOTING ON ITEMS WITH ON. BOTH
PARTS WILL TAKE PLACE AFTER THE
PUBLIC HEARING. AT THE END OF
THE A- AT THE END HERE. WE WILL
WAIT FOR CENTER STERN CENTER.
GUARD TO JOIN IS TO ESTABLISH A-
A QUORUM WHICH THAT SAID WE
HAVE. ISSUES ON VOTE ONLY SO WE
WILL MOVE TO ISSUE NUMBER TEN
AT NIGHT FAST- GO BIZ AND I
BANK AFTER. TWO COMPORTED
BELIEVE WE HAVE A- ADVISOR
AVELAR FOR THE CLIMATE FUNDING
FOR- GO BIZ- PLEASE GO AHEAD.
THANK YOU SENATOR THIS IS DAN
ADLER SENIOR ADVISOR FOR
CLIMATE FINANCE WITH THE
GOVERNOR'S OFFICE OF BUSINESS
ECONOMIC DEVELOPMENT. ALSO
WORKING VERY CLOSELY WITH THE
INFRASTRUCTURE BANK ON THE
FUNDING CHANNELS FUNDS FOR YOUR
COMMUNITY HERE TODAY WITH YOU
AND YOURS IN BALTIMORE WE'RE
TRYING TO DO WITH THE CATALYST
FUND- IN GENERAL AND MORE
SPECIFICALLY IN THIS ISSUE
VERY. INCOME SUPPORT ACT. BUT
BRINKLEY AND THE THAT I HAVE I
WANT TO GET. OVERVIEW OF THE
GOAL HERE IN A IS TO CREATE A
SIGNET WHAT WE THINK IS A
SIGNIFICANT NEW TOOL IN THE
STATE'S TOOL SET HER DRESSING
CLIMATE AND ADVANCING EQUITABLE
INFRASTRUCTURE. IT IS IN THE
MODE OF DEVELOPMENT FINANCE
MEANING ASSERTIVE APPROACH TO
ALLOCATING PUBLIC CAPITAL
FINANCING THE PUBLIC INTEREST
BUT IN A WAY THAT USES
FINANCIAL DISCIPLINE AND
LEVERAGES PRIVATE SECTOR
PARTICIPATION TO ACHIEVE MUCH
GREATER SCALE- THIS IS A
BUSINESS MODEL THAT EXISTS AND
NOW TWELVE OTHER STATES AND
WE'RE NOT PROBABLY KNOWN AS
GREEN BANKS. AND IS INCREASING
IN POPULARITY AROUND THE WORLD
INCLUDING A FEDERAL LEVEL- WE
CAN BUILD INTO THAT AS YOU LIKE.
YOUR CAL HAS YOU IN THE COUNTRY
IS THE EXISTING STATE
INFRASTRUCTURE BANK. WHICH HAS
MOBILIZED OVER FORTY BILLION
DOLLARS IN CAPITAL OVER ITS
LIFE INCLUDING NEARLY A BILLION
DOLLARS IN DIRECT LENDING. AND
HAS AN ESTABLISHED AFTER
PROFESSIONALS THAT ARE MAKING
IMPORTANT CAPITAL CONTRIBUTIONS
TO THE STATE'S INFRASTRUCTURE
GOALS. ANY OBJECTIVE HERE IS TO
HANG THAT AT OUR CLIMATE AND
RESILIENCY INFRASTRUCTURE
CHALLENGES- WITH THE PRINCIPAL
OBJECTIVE OF LEVERAGING PRIVATE
MONEY SO I KNOW THERE'S BEEN
SOME CONSIDERATION AND CONCERN
AROUND CROWDING OUT PRIVATE
CAPITAL WITH THIS APPROACH.
IT'S QUITE THE CONTRARY BY
PARTICIPATING STRATEGICALLY
WITH LIMITED AMOUNTS OF
TARGETED PUBLIC MONEY. WE
BELIEVE WE CAN OPEN UP. PRIVATE
CAPITAL AND SIGNIFICANT
MULTIPLES THE VISION TO ACHIEVE
OUR ON OUR HANDS. BECAUSE WE
RECOGNIZE WILL NEVER GET WHERE
WE NEED TO BE JUST ON PUBLIC
MONEY HELLO. SO HEARD I SEVENTY
WHICH WERE PASSED SUMMER. THIS
IS. AIMED AT SETTING A DATE SET
UP THE FRAMEWORK FOR OTHER
CHANNELS FONG WILL OPERATE. IN
AS OPPOSED TO LAST YEAR'S
EFFORT WHICH WAS A TOP DOWN
LARGE SCALE FUNDING APPROACH
THIS IS GOING SECTOR BY SECTOR
RETHINK WE HAVE REAL
OPPORTUNITIES. TO UNLOCK
MARKETS AND ADVANCE THE STATE'S
POLICY GOALS IN PARTNERSHIP
WITH OUR OUR AGENCY COLLEAGUES
WERE SETTING THE POLICY
UNDERSTAND THE NEED FOR
TECHNOLOGY AND WORK CLOSELY
WITH THE COMMUNITIES THIS IS A
FUN PICKING UP. ACTUATE THOSE
POLICY GOALS. IN THIS SECTOR IN
PARTICULAR WHICH CONTRIBUTES
DOCUMENTARY PERCENT STAGE
GREENHOUSE GAS EMISSIONS. WE
SEE SOME REAL NEEDS FOR CAPITAL
AND PRODUCT DEVELOPMENT IN
METHANE MANAGEMENT IN ORGANIC
WASTE OF GOOD PROCESSING IN
PARTICULAR. BUT WE ALSO SEE THE
REAL OPPORTUNITY FOR THE SECTOR
TO CONTRIBUTE TO THE STATE'S
GREENHOUSE. GREENHOUSE GAS AND
CLEAN ENERGY GOALS. WITH CLEAN
RENEWABLE ENERGY WITHHYDROGEN
PRODUCTION ADVANCED BIOFUELS
MARC SOIL MANAGEMENT PRACTICES
ALL THESE ARE TECHNOLOGIES THAT
ARE MATURE. BUT NEED A NUDGE TO
GET THE PRIVATE MORTGAGE
SUBJECT. TO TAKE OFF AND FUND
THE MASCARA. OUR OUR REGION BUT-
RUBIO THAT THERE IS A- INTEREST
PROJECT. ACROSS THE CLAIMANTS
MORE AGRICULTURE SPACE- DID ON
THE GOVERNOR. AND IN. FROM
SERIES CAPITAL PROVIDERS IN THE
PRIVATE SECTOR THAT SEE THIS AS
PART OF THIS IS DANIEL ECONOMY
OF THE FUTURE. AND LOCAL
PARTICIPATION CALIFORNIA
MARKETS WHERE THEY CAN MANAGE
IT- AND THIS AMOUNT OF PUBLIC
MONEY CAN MARRY WITH THEIR
PRIVATE CAPITAL AGAIN
INSIGNIFICANT. THIS IS THE
PASSED IN FOR THEM AND THEY
NEED A PARTNERSHIP FROM GOBIZ
IN IRAQ- LASTLY MY WAY ENTERED.
I BUT THERE WAS SOME QUESTIONS
ABOUT WHY THIS CATEGORY COULD
NOT APPEAR IN THE SEC REPORT
THIS RICHARD ROTH COUNCIL
REPORT- AS WE WERE PUTTING
FORWARD TO CONCEPTS FOR TWENTY
TWENTY ONE. AB SEVENTY EIGHT WE
HAVE A LIST THAT WAS ROUGHLY IN
LINE WITH THE GOVERNOR'S
EXECUTIVE ORDERS AND THE HIGH
LEVEL POSSIBLE THE STATE.
WORKING IN PARTNERSHIP ON THE
FIRE SIDE IN PARTICULAR FOR
FORCED BINANCE UTILIZATION THE
PREPARE THE REPORT PRESS YOU
SEE AND THEN WERE MADE AWARE
THAT CDFA HAD AN INTEREST IN
WORKING WITH OUR BANK FOR
SIMILAR PURPOSES. IT WAS TOO
LATE TO PUT IT IN THE REPORT WE
DID BRIEFLY SEC ON THAT
OPPORTUNITY. AND IT WAS
PROBABLY ENDORSE. I THINK
THAT'S ANY- EXAMPLE OF KEYBOARD.
THAT THIS FUND CAN ENABLE AT
THE STATE LEVEL. WITH FOUR
DEPARTMENT OF ON THE FOR SIDING
WITH CDFA LOOKING AT THIS ONE
VEHICLE AS IMPORTANT TO ADVANCE
THEIR GOALS. YEAH I MAKING THE
CATALYST FUNDER VOICE FOR THAT
PARTNERSHIP. BEGAN DRIVING
LEVERAGE ADVANCING POLICY GOALS
CREDIT CROWDING IN PRIVATE
CAPITAL AND HOPEFULLY ENGAGING
IN A MINISTER OF STRATEGIC
CONVERSATION WITH YOURSELF AND
ARE YOU. SEE COLLEAGUES. FIGURE
OUT THE BEST WAY TO ALLOCATE
THAT MONEY GOING FORWARD. THANK
YOU- AS OUTLINED IN THIS IN THE
STAFF REPORT YOU KNOW WHEN
BEFORE WE GET TO THE ALLEY- AND
I KNOW YOU KNOW YOU'RE THERE.
YOU KNOW LAST YEAR WE PASSED
LEGISLATION THAT SPECIFICALLY
SAID THAT WE WILL FUND IS FROM
NON STATE. FUNDS NON
GOVERNMENTAL FUNDS THAT WAS THE
DEAL. THAT WAS MADE. NOW SIX
MONTHS LATER. THE GOVERNOR'S
COMING BACK WITH NOT ONLY
FUNDING IT WOULD STAY FUNDS. A
BUT FINDING IT CONTINUOUSLY
WITH STATE FUNDS B. AND THEN
EARLY ACTION SO IT'S- I GUESS
THE QUESTION WILL BE ASKED IS.
IS WHAT GOOD DID THE DECISIONS
THAT WE MAKE AT THE END OF THE
YEAR IN THE BUDGET YEAR WHEN.
THE LESSONS A HALF A YEAR LATER
WE'RE COMING BACK WITH THE
ENTIRE THE ENTIRELY OPPOSITE.
AND PUT ASIDE. THE VALUE OF A
GREEN BANK AND ALL THAT CAMPUS
OF JUST A REGULAR. THE
RELATIONSHIP BETWEEN THE
LEGISLATURE. AND THE GOVERNOR
CAN YOU ADDRESS THAT. SURE I
CAN GIVE YOU. OF MY PERSPECTIVE
THAT IN THE COURSE OF. WHAT WAS
A FAIRLY EASY TO GO. PREVIOUS
EIGHT LAST YEAR WHICH MEANT
THAT. WAS AIMED AT SETTING A
FRAMEWORK AND DISSIPATING BUT
FEDERAL STIMULUS IN THE NEAR
TERM. WE NEED TO SET THIS ONE
UP TO RECEIVE. THOSE DOLLARS.
THE DESIGN OF THE LANGUAGE
DESIGN IF YOU LIKE LANDED ON
FEDERAL ONLY. AND IN MY
JUDGMENT WENT TOO FAR IN
PRECLUDING FOR ALL TIME THAT
THE POSSIBILITY OF STATE
ALLOCATION TO SUPPLEMENT. THOSE
FEDERAL DOLLARS. BOB SO IT WAS
DEFINITELY THE NEGOTIATION BUT
I THINK IT WAS. AN OVERSTAFFED
AND THIS IS A CHANCE TO
RECONSIDER THAT AND SAY AND IN
SPECIFIC LIMITED CIRCUMSTANCES.
WOULD IT MAKE SENSE TO PUT
STATE DOLLARS WELL INTO THIS
ONCE ABOUT THAT IS THERE. THE
REQUESTED HE LIKE TO RECONSIDER
THAT A TERMINATION WHICH IN MY
JUDGMENT WAS MADE A LITTLE BIT
HASTILY AT THE ELEVENTH HOUR.
THIS PHARMACY. APPROPRIATION OR
CONTINUOUS FLOWING FUNDS. IT'S
A ONE TIME ALLOCATION. WITHOUT
ASKING AT THIS STAGE FOR
FURTHER ALLOCATIONS FOR THE
SECTOR. THE BEAUTY OF THE ROBOT
FUND IS THEY WANT MONEY IS THE-
TO THE- EN ROUTE BE READ. BUT
THERE'S NO CONTINUOUS. FROM THE
GENERAL FUND. IN THIS CASE- AND
THEN LASTLY FOR THE URGENCY
MEASURE DATA. WANTED TO THE
FORCE PRIVATE SECTOR. IS REALLY
RESPONDING TO THE NEEDS OF YOU
USE THIS FOR SPEECH ACT MORE
AGGRESSIVELY. FREE MARKETS TO
DRAWDOWN OF THE WILDFIRE RISK
IT HAS A CHANCE TO DO SOME
EARLY ACTION TO DECREASE
WILDFIRE RISK IS NOT GONNA
SOLVE THE PROBLEM OF COURSE.
BUT IT IS URGENT AND SO I THINK
THAT'S WHY IT SHOWS UP IN YOUR
EARLY ACTION BUDGET ITEM FOR
HORSE THE PRESS ALWAYS JUMP
JUMP INTO THE WILDFIRE. PORTION
OF DEATH THE GROUP IS- A ONE
LAST. TIME IS. MR WU MY BANK IN.
WANT TO GO ON ALEJO. YES I I'M
HERE. GREAT GO AHEAD PLEASE YOU
HAVE. THEN I WOULD CONCUR WITH
WITH DAN EXPRESS THAT WAY AND-
THE I'M CAL'S FONG WAS SET UP
LAST BUDGET CYCLE. HE WAS IN
LIGHT OF THE PENDING AND- STILL
THERE WERE WORK ONE IN THEIR
WAY THROUGH BOTH THE U. S.
SENATE AND U. S. HOUSE WE WERE
ALL HOPEFUL THAT THOSE ONE OF
THOSE GOALS WE GET PAST THAT
WOULD PROVIDE CAPITAL FOR THE
CLIMBING HILLS FINE. AS WELL
WHERE NONE OF THEM HAD PASSED
IN THE SECOND HALF OF LAST YEAR
BUT THEY ARE ACTUALLY AT THE
TABLE AS WE SPEAK RIGHT NOW.
GOING TO THE HOUSE FOR A VOTE
ACTUALLY ON FRIDAY AND SO THERE
THERE MAY BE FEDERAL FUNDS ON
THE WAY BUT IN THE ABSENCE OF
THAT. YEAH I WORK VERY HARD
WITH DYNAMIC TEAM AND THEY GO
BIZ WORK WITH OTHER AGENCIES
ABOUT OTHER SOURCES OF
PERSPECTIVE FINDING THE
CHEAPEST SIMILAR GOALS AND
THEREBY NECESSITATING THIS SET
OF CHANGES. THAT WE WERE OPENED
UP FOR TODAY. OKAY OUR- GOOD
MORNING THIS IS A BRAND WHETHER
FORD WITH THE LEGISLATIVE
ANALYST'S OFFICE- REGARDING THE
CLIMATE FUND CATALYST IN
GENERAL LAST YEAR- WHEN THE
ADMINISTRATION PROPOSED TO
ESTABLISH THE FUND AT THE TIME
WE NOTED IT COULD BE AN
APPROPRIATE WAY TO INCREASE THE
AMOUNT OF. PUBLIC AND PRIVATE
INVESTMENT FOR CLIMATE
MITIGATION AND ADAPTATION
PROJECTS. WE DID HAVE SOME
CONCERNS HOWEVER AND SUGGESTED
THAT IF YOU WERE INTERESTED IN
THIS CONCEPT THAT THE
LEGISLATURE FIRST FUND A PILOT
PROJECT. AND THIS PROPOSAL AND
THE- THE FORCE PROPOSAL ALONG
WITH THAT ARE CENTRALLY SUCH A
PILOT PROJECT. SO REGARDING
THIS PROPOSAL SPECIFICALLY-
ADVISER ADLER MENTIONED- THAT
THE AGRICULTURE SECTOR IS A
SOURCE OF GREENHOUSE GAS FUNDS
IN THAT THERE ARE- IT'S
ACTUALLY PROJECTS THAT- COULD
BENEFIT FROM LOW COST LOANS. TO
HELP THESE PROJECTS- MOVE
FORWARD. AND YOU KNOW MISTER
ADLER ADDRESSED OUR CONCERNS
ABOUT HOW THIS PROJECT FITS IN
WITH THE STATE'S OVERALL
CLIMATE. AND STRATEGY AS HE
NOTED WAS NOT MENTIONED IN THE
LIST OF. HIGH PRIORITY- ITEMS-
IDENTIFIED BY THE STRATEGIC
PRESS COUNCIL BUT- HE HAS
EXPLAINED- THIS MORNING-
WIDEOUT WHY THAT CAME ABOUT-
REGARDING THE CONCERNS YOU
RAISED- YES THE LEGISLATURE DID
NOT INCLUDE- INCLUDED LANGUAGE
THAT NO STATE FUNDS WERE TO BE
USED FOR THE FUND. THE
ADMINISTRATION IS PROPOSING A
CHANGE TO STATUTE TO ALLOW THE
PHONE TO ACCEPT STATE FUNDS SO
THIS IS- AN OPPORTUNITY- FOR
THE LEGISLATURE TO REEVALUATE
WHETHER THEY WANT TO FUND THIS-
YOU PROGRAM OR NOT IF THE
LEGISLATURE DOES APPROVE
FUNDING FOR THE CLIMATE CATTLE
SPEND WE WOULD RECOMMEND
EXPANDING SLIGHTLY THE
REPORTING REQUIREMENTS. I'M TO
HELP YOU ASSESS THE OUTCOMES OF
THIS NEW PROGRAM. IS IT IS A
CONCERN FROM THE AUDIO ON THE-
MECHANISM FOR THE FUNDING YOU
KNOW IT'S A SEEMS LIKE THEY
THERE'S BEEN EVIDENCE THAT
THERE'S THESE LOANS THAT THEY
CAN GET IN THE AGRICULTURAL
SECTOR OR SKY HIGH INTEREST
RATES AND THIS WOULD ALLOW THE
LENDING OR IS IT THE PARTICULAR
PROJECTS THAT BY BANKS WERE.
FOUND TO BE AS WE WOULD CHOOSE
WITHIN THE AGRICULTURAL SECTOR.
IT'S MORE THE FORMER IT'S THAT-
ITS STATE. LOANS FOR PRIVATE
PROJECTS CAN BE DEPENDING ON ON
THE RISK IN THE- FAMILIARITY OF
THE MARKET WITH SERVICE
PROJECTS CAN BE ALL OVER THE
PLACE FOR- SOME PROJECTS THERE
MIGHT BE LOWER COST FINANCING
AVAILABLE BUT THOSE PROJECTS
MAY NOT NEED THE SORT OF
FUNDING AND OUR CONCERN IS THAT
THIS FUND- DEPENDING ON THAT
THE TYPES OF PROJECTS IN THE
RISKINESS. IT MAY EITHER BE. IF
IT'S IF IT'S- IF REPLACING A
VERY HIGH INTEREST RATE LOANS
THAT PROJECT MIGHT BE RISKY AND%
THEN THIS THE FUND WILL NOT BE
REPAIRED AND IT CAN'T BE SELF
SUSTAINING AS ENVISIONED. AND
IF THE PROJECTS ARE. TOO SAFE
THEN THEY PROBABLY DO HAVE
ACCESS TO PRIVATE CAPITAL THE
SPEND COULD BE SERVING TO CROWD
OUT SO WE'RE THIS FUND IS
POSITIONING ITSELF IS IN THE
MIDDLE- TO CROWD IN PRIVATE
CAPITAL. AND WHAT WHAT WE'RE
SUGGESTING IS THAT IT WOULD BE
GOOD TO START WITH A SMALLER
PROGRAMS SUCH AS THIS- LAST
LECTURES PROGRAM HAVE MUCH
BROADER. SCOPE SO- SO IF YOU
PRACTICE YOU CAN- HOPEFULLY
COLLECT DATA TO SEE THAT THE
PROJECTS BEING FUNDED ARE IN
THAT SWEET SPOT AND THAT WE ARE
CROWDING OUT PRIVATE CAPITAL OR
TAKING ON TOO MUCH RISK
EXCELLENT ADVICE- CHAIR DOLLY.
AND THEN CENTER STERN. THE YOU
MR CHAIRMAN I MY FIRST. IS WHAT
WHAT ARE THE FEDS BRINGING TO
THE TABLE WHAT WHAT I MEAN IN
THE LEGISLATION I I'M NOT SEEN
OUT IS IT JUST DOLLARS FOR THE
POLICY. AT THIS STAGE OF ITS
BEING SHAPED AND DESCRIBED AS
THE CLEAN ENERGY AND
SUSTAINABILITY ACCELERATOR
WHICH REALLY HAS TWO
COMPONENTS. WELL NUMBER ONE
IT'S A SIGNIFICANT DOLLAR
FIGURE SO CORONER DEUCE IN BOTH
CHAMBERS AND THAT'S NOW
PARTISAN SUPPORT. HUNDRED
BILLION DOLLARS TO FUND
CRITICAL CLIMATE INFRASTRUCTURE
FROM THE FEDERAL GOVERNMENT. OF
BY AND I WAS NEWLY ESTABLISHED
INDEPENDENT NONPROFIT GREEN
BACK. BUT THE BULK OF THE WORK
WILL BE TO FLOW CAPITAL TO STAY
GREEN BACKS- IN A RANGE OF
CATEGORIES WHICH BROADLY
REFLECT THE STATE'S GOING TO
PRIORITIES AND STOPPING PLAN
ELSEWHERE- GET INTO A IN A LOW
COST REVOLVING LOAN PURCHASES
SUCH AS THE ONE PRESCRIBING
HERE. THERE'S A COMPONENT OF
POLICY PRESCRIPTION THAT 40% OF
THE CAPITAL TREAT UNDERSERVED
MARKETS AND DRIVE INCLUSION BUT
BEYOND THAT IT'S NOT
STIPULATING POLICY GOALS FOR
THE CLIMATE SECTOR OTHER THAN
WHAT IS ALREADY. IN THE
INDIVIDUAL STATE LAWS. HE SAID
HUNDRED BILL. UNDER BILL TOTAL.
THIS WOULD BE TO WHAT WOULD
CONSIDERED CRITICAL NATIONAL
INFRASTRUCTURE THINK ABOUT
LARGE SCALE TRANSMISSION. TEXAS
VERSUS WHAT CLOSE TO THE
STATE'S RETURN. I'LL THAT HAS
NOT BEEN DETERMINED YET THAT'S
THE TOP LINE NUMBER. SO I
NOTICED THAT COMMENTS THANK YOU
FOR THAT INFORMATION- I'M I'M
PRETTY ON BOARD WITH YOU KNOW
DOING INCENTIVES BUT HI I
SOMEBODY UP FOR SOME OF ARMOR
NUMBER ONE NUMBER TWO. I LIVE
IN THE FOREST AND IT'S BURNING
DOWN EVERY DAY AND THERE'S ALL
KINDS OF- TECHNOLOGIES THAT ARE
AVAILABLE I THINK I MENTIONED
IT WAS THE LAST. TIME WE ARE
HEARING THAT YOU KNOW THERE'S-
THEY'RE TAKING RICE STRAW AND
MAKING PRESS BORED OUT OF IT
AND THE REASON THEY'RE DOING
THAT AND THIS IS PRIVATE.
INVESTMENT NO HELP FROM THE
GOVERNMENT. NOT BECAUSE THEY
HAVE A CONTINUOUS SUPPLY OF
RICE STRAW THE FARMERS NEED
SOMEPLACE TO GO WITH IT AND-
IT'S REDUCING CARBON. IT'S
DOING EXACTLY WHAT WE WANTED TO
DO. IN THIS CASE WE'RE WE'RE
INCENTIVIZING HAVE NO PROBLEM
WITH THAT BUT IT'S THE POLICY.
THAT CAUSES THE PROBLEM. IT IS
A POLICY NOT CAL A CALIFORNIA
PROBLEM IS IF IT'S IF FOR THIS
60% OF THE LAND IT'S MANAGED IN
CALIFORNIA BY THE FEDERAL
GOVERNMENT. THE POLICIES ARE
HORRIBLE IN THE SUPPLY OF
PRODUCT. LET ME GIVE AN EXAMPLE
SO THE FOR SERVICE WHAT DOES
PROJECTS BUT I CALM SPLAT
THERE'S PROJECT HERE THERE'S A
PROJECT A HUNDRED MILES AWAY.
THERE'S ANOTHER ONE FIFTY MILES
AWAY AND THERE'S NO CONTINUOUS
SUPPLY. OF THIS WOODY BIOMASS
THAT IS DESPERATELY NEEDED TO
BEAT THEM DOWN THE FOREST. AND
SO ONE OF THE PROBLEMS THAT WE
NEED IS ONE OF THE THINGS WE
NEED TO DRESS IS. WE NEED TO GO
FIRST IN MY OPINION WE NEED TO
GO WATERSHED BY WATERSHED TO
TAKE A WATERSHED. AND WE SAY
OKAY WE'RE GONNA TREAT THIS
WATERSHED. SO WE DIDN'T THEIR
SERVE DIFFERENT WATERSHEDS IN
CALIFORNIA. WE SAY OKAY W'RE
TALKING ON THIS WATER SHOULD WE
DO A. THE STEWARDSHIP CONTRACT
SO THIS SAYS THE FOR SERVICE
WILL SUPPLY. THE COMMODITY THAT
COMES OUT OF THIS WATERSHED IS
SOON AS YOU GET THAT DONE. WHAT
WE NEED WE NEED SOME REASON
HELP FROM THE FEDERAL
GOVERNMENT HER TO SAY WE'RE
GONNA DO THIS THE PRIVATE
INVESTMENT IS THERE THE
TECHNOLOGY IS THERE TO DO THESE
OTHER THEIR THIRD OF BIO FUEL
PLANT IN LAKEVIEW OREGON
HUNDRED MILES FROM MY HOME THAT
IS MAKING. BIOENERGY OP OF
FORCED RESIDUE- SO I THINK FOR
US IT'S MORE OF A POLICY FIXED
AND IT IS A MONEY FIX WE NEED
TO SAY HEY WE'RE GONNA GO
WATERSHED BY WATERSHED
ENTREATIES WATERSHEDS WE CAN
THROW MONEY AT IT ALL DAY LONG
AND WE'RE NEVER GOING TO GET
PRIVATE INVESTMENT PRIVATE
PEOPLE WILL COME WHEN THEY CAN
GO TO THEIR BANK. AND THEY CAN
TELL THE BANK HEY I HAVE A
TWENTY FIVE YEAR SUPPLY OF
PRODUCT THAT WE CAN TURN INTO
YOU KNOW WHATEVER BIOFUELS YOU
NAME IT BUT THEY'RE NOT GONNA
PUT THAT INVESTMENT IN THERE
UNTIL WE HAVE SOME MATURITY.
THAT THEY'RE GONNA GET THE
FEEDSTOCK. SO THAT'S THAT'S MYCOMMENTS HAVE BEEN PUSHING ON
THIS AND I AT SOME POINT WE
NEED TO HAVE AS LIKE. FIGURE
OUT A WAY TO GET THE FEDERAL
GOVERNMENT HERE IN TO THE TABLE
AND FIGURE OUT HOW WE'RE GOING
TO GO MANAGE THE 60% LANDED IS
BURNING UP. YOU KNOW. WE SEE.
BILL AFTER BILL COMING THROUGH
THIS HOUSE. ABOUT WILDLIFE MEAN
WE'RE STOP WHATEVER THE BEAR
BILL TOP HONEY BEAR I WANT TO
SHARE WITH YOU FOUR MILLION
ACRES BURNED UP LAST YEAR MORE
WILDLIFE GOT DESTROYED LAST
YEAR IN HABITAT. FROM FIRE.
THEN WILL EVER DO BY HUNTING OR
FISHING OR WHATEVER THE HECK
ELSE WE'RE DOING WE NEED TO
TAKE CARE OF OUR OUR- OF OUR
MEADOWS IN OUR IN OUR STREAMS.
AND THAT IS BY PUTTING FIRE
BREAKS IN SO THAT WE CAN MANAGE
OUR FOR SO I JUST WANT TO GET
THAT OUT IN THE OPEN IT'S
FRUSTRATING IS HACKED. TO
ALWAYS FOCUS ON THE MONEY. AND
NEVER FOCUS ON THE POLICY. FOR
STERN. THANKS MISTER CHAIR GOOD
TO BE PHYSICALLY WITH YOU YES
IT IS NICE YEAH YEAH- IT
DOESN'T MISS AT MISTER WU- I
GUESS BUILDING ON- MY FROM THE
NORTH QUEST OR POINT- YOU KNOW
THE SAN PASSED. EARLY I DIDN'T
KNOW ALL THE WAY THIS BUT I THE
BILL YEAR BETWEEN FIFTY TO
ESTABLISH A CLAIM A CATALYST
FUND IN LAW- THAT HAD OF. SORT
OF BROADER MANDATE THEN. THEN I
GUESS WE'RE SEEING HERE TODAY-
IN TERMS OF SORT OF GOING
SECTOR BY SECTOR WITH SOME
PARTICULAR MARKET INTERVENTIONS
INTO. TRYING TO. ESTABLISH MORE
OF A HOLISTIC. VIEW OF WHAT
LEVERAGING CAN BE- AND WHAT.
SORT OF MARKET DEVELOPMENT CAN
BE AND HOW WE WANT TO
PARTICIPATE AS A AS PUBLIC
ENTITIES SO THE LEGISLATION
ACTUALLY. WOULD HAVE BEEN
SPECIFICALLY STRUCTURED AROUND-
PUBLIC CAPITAL NOT PRIVATE
CAPITAL IN THE BUDGET DEAL IS
THE CHAIR POINTED OUT THE
BUDGET DEAL FLIP THAT ON ITS
HEAD AND SAID. NO ACTUALLY IT'S
LIKE A FEDERAL RECEIVING
PROGRAM AND THAT'S WE HAVEN'T
LAW RIGHT NOW I THINK THERE'S
SOME OF THE FRUSTRATION YOU'RE
HEARING IS. THERE A WILLING
WILLINGNESS IN THE LEGISLATURE
TO ENGAGE AND GET HANDS ON
ABOUT NOT JUST THE STRUCTURE
THE AUTHORITY BUT TO MAKE SURE
THE UNDERLYING POLICY
ARCHITECTURES. THAT SORT OF DR
VISSER COHESIVE- SO AS WE'RE
DEBATING. AGRICULTURE AND YOU
KNOW THIS SORT OF. ANY USE
FEEDSTOCK MARKET DEPLOYMENT AND
THE WILD FIRE PECES WELL- I
JUST I'M CURIOUS HOW ARE YOU
GUYS AT THE AT THE CATALYST
TRYING TO ALSO LOOK AT SORT OF
THE BROADER MARKET PLACE AND
LOOK AT WHERE YOU SEE
OPPORTUNITIES IN CALIFORNIA IF
THAT HUNDRED BILLION DOLLARS
DOES SHOW UP AND- THE I MEAN IS
A ONE POINT FIVE TRILLION
DOLLAR INFRASTRUCTURE PACKAGE
AND I THINK YEAH THE HUNDRED
BILLION WAS IN THE BIG BIG.
THANK YOU BETTER SPACE YOU
MENTIONED THE DEPTH OF THE
TOTAL DOLLAR FIGURES LOOKING
EVEN BIGGER THAN THAT BUT ARE
YOU GUYS LOOKING MORE BROADLY
AT- WHAT IS CLIMATE CATALYST
CAN DO AND I GUESS WHAT THE
POLICY GAPS ARE THAT YOU SEE.
IN HIBBING YOUR ABILITY TO DO
MORE I THINK THAT KIND OF
INTERFACE OF THE LEGISLATURE IN
BRINGING BACK SOME OF THOSE KEY
ITEMS OUR RECOMMENDATIONS ARE
OPPORTUNITIES WOULD HELP PUT
SOME MEAT ON THE BONES OPPOSE
JUST SORT OF. THINKING ABOUT
ALL THIS SO HYPOTHETICALLY SO
JUST IT DIDN'T COMMENT ON THAT
MR WE WERE MISTER ADLER JUST
THE BROADER BROADER PURPOSE AND
SORT OF HOW TO HOW TO MAKE IS
THERE ANY TEND TO MAKE THIS
ARCHITECTURE PERMANENT- OR DO
YOU RY TO JUST ENVISIONED THE
STATE ROLE JUST BEING. SMART
AGRICULTURE AND WILDFIRE. FOR
NOW AND YOU'RE NOT GONNA TOUCH
EVERYTHING ELSE. YES THANK YOU
SENATOR STERN SO LAST YEAR THE
ADMINISTRATION'S INITIAL
INTENT. WAS MORE ALONG THE
LINES THAT YOU JUST EXPRESSED.
A MUCH LARGER MUCH BROADER A
STATE FUNDED A VEHICLE THAT
WOULD HAVE. A MANDATE TO LOOK
ACROSS TIME TO CHANGE
ALLEGORIES. AND BE IMPACTFUL
WHEREVER- IT'S ALL I NEED.
GIVEN THE BUDGET SITUATION THAT
AROSE. EARLY LAST SPRING- THOSE
FUNDS I DIDN'T MATERIALIZE. AND
THEREFORE WE ARE NOT LIMITED.
IN OUR SCOPE BY THE FUNDS THAT
ARE MADE AVAILABLE. AND SO WE
WILL USE THESE FUNDS. VERY
PROPERLY LOOK FOR OPT. TO
PROVIDE DEMONSTRATION OF FACTS
AS A CATALYST TO DEMONSTRATE
BOTH THE DEMAND AND NEED AND
THE ABILITY OF OUR PROGRAM TO
MAKE AN IMPACT AND THEN
CONTINUED DURING THAT PROCESS
TO SEEK ADDITIONAL ARGUED THAT
MAY BE MORE GENERAL PURPOSE TO
SERVE A BROADER RANGE OF FIVE
EXHIBITS. I'LL ALSO TURNED OVER
TO MR OUT THERE TO- RESPOND.
DIRECTOR WHO AND THANK YOU FOR
THE QUESTION CENTER STERN IT'S
ABSOLUTELY THE INTENT TO CREATE
PURPOSE MEANING THE ENTIRETY OF
THE CLIMATE INFRASTRUCTURE
CHALLENGE THAT WAS THE
APPROACH. THAT WE UNDERTOOK
LAST YEAR AND FOR ALL THE
OBVIOUS REASONS DID NOT HAVE A
CHANCE TO ENGAGE SO MUCH WITH
THE LEGISLATURE ON THE DESIGN
OF THAT IN THE DETAILS BUT IT
IS THE INTERNET AND WE THINK WE%
CAN GET THERE BY BUILDING UP
FROM BEST. BUY LEVEL TEST IN
SPECIFIC SECTORS BUT WE DO HAVE
A VIEW OF WHERE CAPITAL NEEDS
TO FLOW FOR THE BROADER MARKET
WE CONTINUE TO COLLECT INBOUND
OPPORTUNITIES FOR INVESTMENT
ACROSS WHAT I THINK WE- WOULD
CONSIDER THE ENTIRE CLIMATE
INFRASTRUCTURE AGENDA. BOB AND
IT IS IMPORTANT TO THE ACTUALLY
THE CENTERS PART QUESTION NOT
GENERATION THIS IS PAIRED WITH
FUNCTIONALITY AT GOBIZ BY WHICH
THOSE TWO CRITICAL THINGS THE
FUNDS SO THAT I MAY BUT THE
CATALYST PROGRAM HAS TWO
COMPONENTS THAT GO IS. ONE OF
WHICH IS THE DEEP SECTOR
UNDERSTANDING THAT IS REQUIRED
TO KNOW WHERE THESE CAPITAL
GAPS ARE WHERE ENTREPRENEURSHIP
IS CHALLENGING WHERE WE MIGHT
LEVERAGE OTHER PARTNERSHIPS-
AND FIGURE OUT WHAT THOSE
MARKETING BARRIERS ARE
PARTICULAR. ISSUES VIDAK IN THE
FOR SECTOR AND OTHER PIECES
GOVERNMENTAL COORDINATION ALL
THE STATE AGENCY RELATIONSHIPS
BIGELOW RELATIONSHIP STATE
FEDERAL AND WISELY POINTED OUT
WE NEED TO MAKE SURE WE'RE
OPTIMIZING FOR THAT AND
CRITICALLY ALLOCATING PUBLIC
GRANTS TO SUPPORT BY THE
CAPITAL AND PUBLIC CAPITAL
FORMATION. SO THIS IS THIS IS
ABSOLUTELYINTENDED TO ACHIEVE
THAT KIND OF SCALE WE'RE
LOOKING AT PROCESSES LIKE THIS
COPING PLAN FOR SIGNALS ABOUT
WHERE. THE STATE'S
INFRASTRUCTURE PRIORITIES LIE.
AND IT IS FUN CAN SCALE TO
ACHIEVE THAT BUILDING FROM THIS
TARGETED SET OF INTERVENTIONS
THAT ARE UP FRONT OF US NOW.
BASED ON THE AGENCY
PARTNERSHIPS IN THESE TWO
INITIAL SEX. THANK FOR THAT
INSIGHT I INCLUDING A JUST I
WOULD OUT SOME FOOD FOR THOUGHT
AS A PERHAPS SHOULD BE USED
WHEN WE THINK THE ROOF-
RECOMMENDATION THAT ELIO. NOT
TO THINK OF REPORT BACK ON THE
PILOTS BUT- HI I'D LOVE TO SEE
SOMETHING. LIKE SIR PROACTIVE
LOOKING IS U. S. AS YOU SAY
ASSESS INBOUND INVESTMENT
OPPORTUNITIES OR SS THE FEDERAL
LANDSCAPE. SOME KIND OF SCOPING
OF WHAT'S POSSIBLE WITH AN
ANTICIPATED FEDERAL INJECTION
OF REVENUE AND COME TO THE
LEGISLATURE AND PRESENT US WITH
SOME KIND OF REPORT OR ANALYSIS
THAT THEN. WE COULD THEN BRING
IN OUR FEDERAL PARTNERS AND
ACTUALLY HAVE A LITTLE MORE OF
A COHESIVE PLANNING PROCESS SO
THAT YOU KNOW WE KIND OF GET
OUR HEADS AROUND OKAY WE'RE
GONNA SPEND SAY A HUNDRED
MILLION NOW. BUT THEN. YOU KNOW
TEN BILLIONS COMING BY AUGUST
WILL THAT'S A VERY DIFFERENT
LOOKING CLIMATE CATALYST THEN.
YOU KNOW TO PILOT PROGRAM SO I
THINK PROACTIVE REPORTING
ANALYSIS WOULD BE USEFUL
SOMEONE FOR THE CHAIR TO
CONSIDER THAT'S A OOD POINT
SINCE WE'RE GOING TO HOLD THIS
MATTER THAT'S A GOOD
OPPORTUNITY FOR COPAYS AND THEY
HAVE BEEN TO GET BACK TO
CENTER. MCGUIRE THANK YOU SO
MUCH YOU'RE A CASCADE NO TIME
IS LIMITED AND WE'RE GOING TO
HOLD THIS ISSUE OPEN BUT I
WANTED TO ONCE AGAIN JUST BRING
UP THE ISSU. OF SMALL FAMILY
DAIRY FARMERS BACK IN.
SEVENTEEN EIGHTEEN. THIS
LEGISLATURE THEN GOVERNOR
PROVIDED NINETY NINE MILLION-
DURING. THE ADMINISTRATION THIS
ADMINISTRATION'S FIRST YEAR
WHEN IT COMES TO MATH AT FROM
MANURE MANAGEMENT TWENTY ONE
NINE MILLION DOLLARS LAST YEAR
NOTHING. NOTHING NOW WHAT WE'RE
GONNA SAYS WE GOT THIS GREAT
NEW WAYS BEING PROGRAM A FIFTY
MILLION THAT AS ADDITIONAL.
OUTLETS FOR FUNDING BESIDES HIS
MANURE MANAGEMENT PROGRAM EVEN
THOUGH THIS STATE PROMISED.
SMALL FAMILY DAIRY FARMERS THAT
WE'RE GOING TO HELP THEM
TRANSITION TO BE ABLE TO BE
CLIMATE CHANGE. AND THEY'RE
TRYING TO SELL IT CANDIDLY LIKE
THIS IS THE BEST NEW THING FOR
THEM. HERE'S THE BOTTOM LINE
DOZENS OF JERRY'S. FAMILY OWNED
DAIRIES IN THE STATE. GO OUT OF
BUSINESS EVERY YEAR. AND NOW
ARE YOU. IN ALL DID CONSULT
WITH GARY FARMERS ESPECIALLY ON
THE NORTH COAST- THAT THIS IS
GOING TO BE GOOD FOR THEM THIS
ISN'T GOOD FOR THEM. THIS MAY
BE GOOD FOR LARGER DAIRIES ARE
FEEDLOTS IN THE CENTRAL VALLEY
BUT SADLY IN EIGHTY THREE
HUNDRED HEAD DAIRY A FIVE
HUNDRED HEAD DAIRY WITH
ADDITIONAL. DEBT ESPECIALLY
WHEN THE MARKET IS SO VOLATILE-
IS LUDICROUS AND WHAT I WOULD
HOPE IS THAT WE'RE GOING TO
COME BACK TO THIS. IN THE
NEGOTIATIONS AND PROVIDE FIRM
DOLLARS ESPECIALLY WHEN IT
COMES FOR THESE ORGANIC DAIRIES
ON THE NORTH THAT HAVE
CHALLENGES WITH. A MANURE
MANAGEMENT TO BE ABLE TO DO THE
RIGHT THING- AND PROVIDE THEM
WITH ACTUAL GRANT FUNDING AS
WAS PROMISED WITH A LOWER BILL
WAS PASSED. AND ONLY PASSION
ABOUT IT BUT IT'S INCREDIBLY
FRUSTRATING AND CANDIDLY BIT
TONE DEAF. THANK YOU THANK YOU
GENTLEMEN WE'RE GOING TO HOLD
ISSUE NUMBER TEN AND MOVE ON TO
THE- DEPARTMENT OF AGRICULTURE-
SECRETARY ROSS. AND UNDER
SECRETARY MOFFETT THIS IS ISSUE
NUMBER ELEVEN FAIRGROUNDS
OPERATIONS SUPPORT DEFERRED
MAINTENANCE. SOME OF US MAY
HAVE HEARD FROM OUR COUNTY
FAIRS BETTER APPARENTLY NOT
INCLUDED IN THE FUNDING. GO
AHEAD. THANK YOU CHAIR GOOD
MORNING SENATORS I APPRECIATE
THE OPPORTUNITY TO BE WITH YOU
TODAY YES THE GOVERNOR'S BUDGET
PROPOSES FIFTY MILLION DOLLARS
FOR OPERATIONAL SUPPORT FOR
STATE AFFILIATED FAIRS AS WELL
AS TEN MILLION DOLLARS IN
DEFERRED MAINTENANCE THAT IS
OPEN TO ALL FARES- EVERYONE
KNOWS HOW DESTRUCTIVE THAT
TWENTY TWENTY WAS FOR THE
OPERATION OF MASSIVE DANCE. AND
THE SUDDEN NEED TO SHUT DOWN
ALL ACTIVITIES. AT FAIR GROUNDS
AS GATHERING PLACES HOWEVER
THEY NEEDED TO MAINTAIN
STRUCTURE AND OPERATIONS TO BE
AVAILABLE FOR EMERGENCIES AND
UNFORTUNATELY IN TWENTY TWENTY
THERE WERE CONSIDERABLE
EMERGENCY NEEDS FOR THE USE OF
THESE PUBLIC ASSETS- DURING
CULTIVATE ACTED AS- THE-
SHELTERS. FOODBANK DISTRIBUTION
TESTING SITES AS AND
VACCINATION SITES WILDFIRES AND
EVACUATIONS- AND FOR THEIR AND-
AS AS THE HIGH TEMPERATURE DAYS
AND THE POWER SHUT DOWNS THAT
ALSO REQUIRED THEM TO SERVE AS
COOLING CENTERS. STATE
AFFILIATED PLAYERS OPERATE BY
STATUTEAS A STATE ENTITY AND
ULTIMATELY THEIR FINANCIAL
OBLIGATIONS BECOME OBLIGATIONS
OF THE STATE AND THAT IS THE
JUSTIFICATION FOR THESE FUNDS
GOING TO. ONLY STATE AFFILIATED
PLAYERS FOR OPERATIONS BECAUSE
IT WILL MITIGATE THE LONG TERM
LIABILITY- FOR THE STATE OF
CALIFORNIA AND THEY DO NOT HAVE
THE SAME- FLEXIBILITY AS TO BE
ABLE TO RESPOND QUITE AS
QUICKLY- WHEN UNFORTUNATELY
THEY HAD TO DO WAY OFF LIKE
THEY DID IN TWENTY TWENTY.
THAT'S A SIX TO EIGHT MONTH
PROCESS TO DO THAT AS WELL AS
SOME OF THE PROCUREMENT
OBLIGATIONS THAT WE HAVE. FIFTY
THREE OF THE SEVENTY SEVEN
PLAYERS IN THE STATE OUR STATE
AFFILIATED FAIRS FORTY TWO OF
THOSE INCLUDING CAL EXPO ARE ON
STATE OWNED ASSETS. OF THE
FIFTY MILLION DOLLARS IS FORTY
SEVEN MILLION DOLLARS FOR
OPERATIONS THROUGHOUT TWENTY
TWENTY ONE AS WELL AS THREE
MILLION DOLLARS. AND IT. OF
HEALTH OF THOSE POSH. COULD BE
USED. FOR ADDITIONAL USES THAT
COULD GENERATE OTHER REVENUE
STREAMS FOR THE FAIREST. OF THE
TEN MILLION DOLLARS IS FOR- I'M
GOING GRANT PROGRAM THAT WOULD
BE RUNNING THE LAST FEW YEARS.
TO HELP COVER IMMEDIATE
DEFERRED MAINTENANCE NEEDS WITH
REGARD TO THE MOST URGENT
PUBLIC HEALTH AND SAFETY
REQUIREMENTS. OF THE FARES-
LIKE MANY OF- ARE. LOOKING MOST
OF THEM ARE AT LEAST FIFTY
YEARS ALL. WITH SMALL TO
FACILITY THINGS LIKE STATE. OF
HEALTH AND SAY AND ELECTRICAL
WIRING- PAID. AND THINGS LIKE
THAT- AND WITH THAT I'D.
SOMEBODY'S MOVING- MIKE I
GUESS- WE CAN MOVE ON TO THE L.
L. THAT BECAUSE THE QUESTION
THAT WE HAD THIS LAST YEAR WE
TOOK THIS EMERGENCY ACTION TO
HELP THE STATE OF PHILLY
AFFAIRS COVERED THEIR- WIND
DOWN OF COMMITMENTS THAT THEY
HAD IN THEIR CONTRACT FOR
PAYROLL AND ALL THAT STUFF
STAFF REPORT SAYS IT ONLY HALF
OF IT WAS USE. THAT WE'RE
COMING BACK WITH SLIGHTLY
DIFFERENT- REQUEST BECAUSE
WE'RE ONE OF THE SOME OF THIS
MONEY COULD BE USED TO
DETERMINE WHETHER THEY CAN HELP
WITH THE KOBE PANDEMIC CAN BE
ASIDE FOR VACCINATIONS AND ALL
THAT WELL A LOT OF COUNTY FEARS
OF DOING THAT NO I COUNTY FEARS
THAT AREN'T. INCLUDED IN THIS
FUNDING REQUEST ON THEIR OWN
NICOLE ARE VACCINATING PEOPLE
ARE TESTING PEOPLE ARE
PROVIDING FOOD THIS
DISTRIBUTION AND SINCE LAST
YEAR IT SEEMED TO ME THAT IT
WAS AN EMERGENCY BECAUSE WE'RE
UNDER CONTRACT WE'VE LET THOSE
PEOPLE GO FOR BETTER FOR WORSE
I'M NOT I'M NOT FORGET IT GET
INTO THAT RIGHT NOW YOU HAVE.
AN OPPORTUNITY WORK NOBODY
KNOWS IF THIS IS A COUNTY
AFFILIATE A FAIR OR STATE
PHILLY AFFAIR WHEN THEY GO IN
TO GET THEIR COVERT TESTS AND
YES THEY ALL NEED THE
ASSISTANCE TO DO THAT TYPE OF
WORK SO I KNOW WE HAVE ELIO HAD
SOME COMMENTS. AT THE
LEGISLATIVE ANALYST'S OFFICE-
WE RECOMMEND THAT THE
LEGISLATURE WITHHOLD ACTION ON
OPERATIONAL SUPPORT FOR STATE
AFFILIATE AFFAIRS UNTIL THE MAY
REVISION- WE FIND THAT
PROVIDING OPERATIONAL SUPPORT
IS REASONABLE SINCE FARES HAVE
BEEN UNABLE TO CONDUCT FORMAL
REVENUE GENERATING ACTIVITIES
TO THE PANDEMIC. HOWEVER THE
ADMINISTRATION ESTIMATES ASSUME
THAT THERE'S WILL BE UNABLE TO
CONDUCT NORMAL OPERATIONS IN
THE BUDGET YEAR- WE FIND THAT
THERE'S STILL UNCERTAINTY
REGARDING THIS GIVEN THAT
SOCIAL DISTANCING GUIDELINES
MIGHT BE UPDATED AS MORE PEOPLE
ARE VACCINATED ACROSS THE
STATE. WE BELIEVE THAT DELAYING
ACTION ON THIS ITEM BUT A LOT
OF THE LEGISLATURE TO USE THE
ADDITIONAL TIME TO IMPLEMENT
THE DECISION. ON THE
APPROPRIATE AMOUNT TO PROVIDE-
IMAGE IS ALSO IN. THAT HALF OF
OPERATOR. SUPPORT FUNDING- WILL
BE TARGETED BASED ON FINANCIAL
MEANS OF THE STATE AFFILIATED
FAIRS. THE FOR THIS PORTION OF
THE FUNDING WE ARE RECOMMENDING
THAT THE LEGISLATURE REQUIRE A
THIRTY DAY NOTIFICATION TO THE-
JAIL B. C. PRIOR TO RELEASE OF
THESE BONDS- THAT'S BECAUSE-
THE FARES OUR- DEPARTMENT WILL
LIKELY UPDATE- HOW THIS. MONEY
WILL BE DISTRIBUTED AS MORE
INFORMATION ON THE FINANCIAL
NEEDS OF THE FAIR'S BECOMES
AVAILABLE- THIS NOTIFICATION
SHOULD INCLUDE DETAILS ON THE
AMOUNT PROVIDED TO EACH DATA
DELAYED THERE- THE METHOD USED
BY THE ADMINISTRATION TO
ALLOCATE FUNDING AND ANY
REMAINING BALANCE AND THE
DEPARTMENTS EXPECTED USE OF
THAT BALANCE. AND THEN IN
REGARDS TO THE- DEFERRED
MAINTENANCE WE RECOMMEND THAT
THE LEGISLATURE APPROVED
FUNDING FOR DEFERRED
MAINTENANCE GIVEN THE- NEEDS
ACROSS THE- AFFAIRS ACROSS THE
STATE. AND THE ROLE THAT THE
BEARS PLAYED AND THE. STATE'S
EMERGENCY RESPONSE NETWORK.
HELLO I'M DO YOU THE AND NOW
FOR THE DEFERRED MAY WAS ALL
NINE FARES SO IT'S CONCEIVED
THAT SOME OF THE CITRUS FARES
AT THE COUNTY FAIRS WOULD BE
HIGH. ON THE ON THE NEED FOR
DEFERRED MAINTENANCE VERSUS THE
DEA'S THAT ARE AFRAID EXACTLY
STATE AFFILIATED. DO YOU HAVE A
SENSE OF WITH THIS NEED FOR.
YOU KNOW USING AS A FIX. OF
STAGING AREA FOR FIRE OR USING
FOR COVER RELIEF YOU HAVE SOME
IDEA OF HOW THOSE- COUNTY FAIRS
WE AND THIS. THE WORLD OF FAIR.
I'M WE DON'T CURRENTLY HAVE
THAT INFORMATION BUT MORE THAN
HAPPY TO THE CIRCLE WITH THE
DEPARTMENT AND CIRCLE BACK WITH
THE COMMITTEE ON THE NEEDS OF
COUNTY FAIRS AND CITRUS
AFFAIRS- BUT I BELIEVE THAT
QUESTION THEY MINISTRATION
SHOULD BE ABLE TO ANSWER AS
WELL WE'LL GET TO THAT AFTER
SENATE MCGUIRE IF YOU HAVE
QUESTIONS. THANK YOU SO MUCH OF
A SECURE QUESTIONING COMMENT
AND I KNOW THAT WE ARE UNDER
TIME LIMITS ALL BE QUICK- AND I-ALSO KNOW THAT- THE
RECOMMENDATION FROM THE CHAIRS
TO BE ON HOLD OPEN AND I AGREE
WITH THAT RECOMMENDATION
APPRECIATE THAT. MISTER OR
CASKEY IS WELL. FIRST AND
FOREMOST JUST WANT TO SAY THANK
YOU TO THE SECRETARY SECTOR
ROSTER ALL OVER WORK AND WE
GREATLY APPRECIATE WORKING WITH
YOU. I THINK THAT AT THE BOTTOM
LINE IS THAT WE TAKE A LOOK AT
FAIRS WHETHER IT'S AND I GUESS
SO SHE XIN. A STATE SPONSORED
FAIR. INDOOR COUNTY FAIR
THEY'VE ALL CRATERED IT
CRATERED. FIVE OF THIS CODE-
INDUCED RECESSION IN OBVIOUSLY
BECAUSE OF THE PANDEMIC OF
EFFECTIVE CARE TO CLOSE THEIR
DOORS. IN WHAT WE ALSO KNOWN
ESPECIALLY IN RURAL PARTS OF
CALIFORNIA. AT COUNTY FAIRS
STATE FAIRS. THEY ARE MAIN
DRIVERS FOR OUR AGRICULTURAL
ECONOMIES. IN MORE AND MORE IF
WE ARE RELYING ON STATE FAIRS.
COUNTY FAIRS AG ASSOCIATIONS TO
BE ABLE TO HOUSE AT CRITICAL
NEEDS WHEN IT COMES TO CRISIS
IS ACROSS THE STATE. NGUYEN YES
SETS UP- AN EVACUATION SHELTER.
OR WIN A LOCAL COMMUNTY SET UP
A BASE CAMP WITH CAL FIRE- IT'S
NOT **** IS A STATE OWNED
FACILITY- COUNTY ON DISABILITY.
ALL FACILITIES ARE EXPECTED TO
RIGHTFULLY SO TO BE ABLE TO
OPEN UP THEIR DOORS. IN WHAT WE
NOW IS THAT WE NEED FAIR'S FAIR
GROUNDS MORE THAN EVER. AND
WHAT I'M REALLY CONCERNED ABOUT
IS- THROUGH THE WESTERN FAIRS
ASSOCIATION THERE'S ALWAYS IN
COLLABORATION WITH THE
ADMINISTRATION AND THE
LEGISLATURE. THAT WHAT WORKS
FOR ONE WORKS FOR ALL. IN NOW
WHAT THIS PROPOSALS FOCUSING ON
ARE JUST STATE FAIRS IN AGRA
SUFFICIENT. WE'RE LEAVING THE
APPROXIMATELY TWENTY THREE
COUNTY FAIRS OUT OF IT. AND
WE'RE GOING AWAY FROM THE
FORMULA THAT IS ALWAYS WORKED
IN AS BEEN TRIED AND TRUE.
FINALLY ON THE ISSUE OF AB
FOURTEEN NINETY NINE AND THAT
IS THE GREAT BILL. THAT TAKES A
PERCENTAGE OF WHAT IS SOLD. SO
WE'RE LOOKING AT BECAUSE WERE
YEAR AND ARREARS ABOUT SEVEN
MILLION COMING INTO THAT.
UNDERSTANDING THAT THAT'S GOING
TO BE OPEN FOR ALL FEARS IT'S A
DROP IN THE BUCKET ABOUT. WHAT
FIGURES NEED. AND THERE'S A AT
AUTOMATIC TO SIX SO IT'S JUST
SAY WE'RE GOING CLOSE TO. IT'S
JUST NOT. SO WHAT I WOULD HOPE-
MY CASKET THIS COMES TO US-
THAT THIS IS GOING BE OPEN UP
TO ALL FARES. IN ONE MORE SPIN.
RISK NINETY SIX BILLION
RIGHTFULLY SO TO BE A HELP
SMALL BUSINESSES AND MOST OF.
FOR ARGUING OVER FOR. MILLION
ENSURING IT'S GONNA BE OPEN UP
THE COUNTY FAIRS I THINK THAT
WE CAN DO BETTER WITH HOPE THAT
WE'RE GONNA BE A TO SEE AN
EXPANDED PACKAGE COMING BACK.
WELL IT LOOKS IF THE MATHIS
RIGHT WE HAVE TWENTY MILLION
LEFT OVER FROM LAST YEAR
CORRECT EMERGENCY OPERATION FOR
CONTRACT OBLIGATIONS THEN WE
HAVE TO FIFTY MILLION. THAT WE
GET THIS TEN MILLION SORTS OF.
THE WORKING NUMBER IS EIGHTY
MILLION SECURE SPOT. VICE CHAIR
DOLLARS. WHAT THE METHODOLOGY
AND- THE- WHICH- SHARES ARE
DISTRICT FAIR ARE THIRD OR. THE
SENATE IT'S BASED ON THE
GOVERNOR STRUCTURE. I SO IF
IT'S A EIGHT EIGHT IT'S A STATE
AND TO AND A POP AS A STATE
AGENCY AND SO IT WAS ON THAT-
AND THIS IS NOT IMPRESSED- AND
PREVIOUS ALLOCATIONS LARGE
BEARS- DID NOT RECEIVE THOSE
ALLOCATIONS IT WAS BASED ON
FINANCIAL NEED- AND SO THIS IS
THIS IS BASED ON THE GOVERNMENT
STRUCTURE AS A WAY TO
PRIORITIZE. A SPENDING. AND
ULTIMATELY BECAUSE THE STATE
ITSELF IS OBLIGATED AT THE
BEARS CANNOT MEET THEIR
FINANCIAL OBLIGATIONS WE HAVE A
LIABILITY THERE IS THE STATE.
SO ALL LISTED I WANT TO TACK ON
THE CENTER REQUIRES COMMENTS
THEY WHEN YOU SHOW UP TO THE
WHEN THAT WHEN THERE'S A FIRE
WHEN THERE'S A PANDEMIC WHEN
YOU SHOW UP YOU DON'T THE KICK
OUR CONSTITUENTS DON'T KNOW
WHICH ONES WHICH IN THE FUNDING
SHOULD BE. MORE DISTRIBUTED
EQUALLY TO ALL THOSE. OKAY
FINANCE HAVE ANYTHING TO ADD.
I'VE EVER DEPARTED FINANCE I
JUST- JUST MAKE A COUPLE POINTS
TWO HUNDRED POINTS ALLIE-
PROVIDED- YOU KNOW
ACKNOWLEDGING THERE ARE STILL
UNCERTAINTIES ON OF WHAT WILL
HAPPEN WITH WITH SPARES IN IN
THE BUDGET YEAR I THINK OUR-
THE FIFTY MILLION PROPOSED IS
BASED OFF OF THE OF THE BEST
ESTIMATE OF AVAILABLE DATA THAT
WE DO HAVE- AND- COMMENT ON ON
THE- THIRTY. DAY CAN.
REQUIREMENT I THINK WE'LL JUST
KNOW THAT THAT DOESN'T REDUCE
SOME OF THE STATE FLEXIBILITY
TO ADDRESS SOME OF THE MEDIA
FAIR NEED I THINK ONE THING
THAT WE EXPERIENCE THIS YEAR-
WITH PROVIDING- FUNDING TO
AFFAIRS IS. YOU KNOW THERE'S
JUST A LOT OF. YOU KNOW
UNEXPECTED THING TO HAPPEN TO
WHERE WE NEED TO BE NIMBLE AND
BE ABLE TO PROVIDE AFFAIRS OF
FUNDING IN A QUICK MANNER GIVEN
THAT THEY ARE. WORKING ON TIGHT
BUDGETS AND SO- YOU KNOW
NOTIFICATION BEFORE. IT OF
FUNDING TO OTHER AFFAIRS I
THINK PROVIDES- KIND OF IT
LIMITS TO THE STATE WHERE WE'RE
NOT ABLE TO ACT AS QUICKLY AS
NEEDED TO SUPPORT THE FARES.
OKAY THANK WE ARE GOING TO HOLD
THIS YOU KNOW IT'S I MEAN
THERE'S ALL A LOT OF CLEVER
THINGS THAT CAN HAPPEN IF
THERE'S- MILLION IN THE BANK.
IF YOU HAD A FIVE MILLION YOU
COULD PROBABLY GIVE A MILLION
DOLLARS. EVERY COUNTY FAIR AND
SEARCHES FOR AND JUST SAY
THAT'S IT THAT'S WHAT YOU GET
THIS YEAR BUT- WILL COME UP
WITH SOMETHING CLEVER THANK
YOU. THE CHAIR NOTICES THAT
WE'RE ALL HERE SO MISS ROY
LET'S ESTABLISH A QUORUM WE
PLEASE CALL THE ROLL. WHY
CASKEY HERE MY CASKEY HERE.
CALLING YOUR CALLING HERE.
REQUIRE YOUR REQUIRED. STERN
YOUR- STERN HERE. EXCELLENT
QUORUM MOVE ON THE ISSUE TWO IN
THESE REGULAR. REPORTING FOR
AGRICULTURE. SECRETARY RON GO
AHEAD. THANK YOU CHAIR- BEFORE
CALVET NINETEEN FARMERS AND
RANCHERS ARE FACING INCREASING
NEW CHALLENGES INCLUDING THE
IMPACTS OF CLIMATE CHANGE WATER
UNCERTAINTY- AND A NUMBER OF
NEW REGULATIONS THAT PASSED IN
THE LAST DECADE THAT ARE BEING
IMPLEMENTED. IN THE LAST COUPLE
OF YEARS AND ALL OF THOSE COME
WITH SEPARATE REPORTING
REQUIREMENTS- TWO YEARS AGO- WE
HAD A SUMMER INTERN FROM THE
HOSPITAL OF BUSINESS WHO MAPPED
OUT- THE NUMBER OF REGULATIONS
THAT FARMERS OF ALL SIZES MUST
COMPLY WITH AND MAPPED OUT AT
LEAST A HUNDRED AND FIFTY
DIFFERENT REGULATIONS. ACROSS
MULTIPLE STATE AGENCIES I KNOW
THAT WHEN I GO OUT WITH THE
GOVERNOR GOES OUT WHEN
SECRETARY BLUMENTHAL GOES OUT
WE ALWAYS HEAR ABOUT THE
REGULATORY BURDEN AND IT'S
REALLY ABOUT THE COMPLIANCE AND
COMPLEXITY ALL OF THE REPORTS
THAT HAVE TO BE DONE AT
DIFFERENT TIMES. MANY OF THEM
HAVE SOME OF THE SAME
REQUIREMENTS FOR REPORTING. AND
AS WE LOOK AT RECOVERING FROM
THE HUGE DISRUPTION TO MARKETS
FOR FARMERS WE KNOW THAT THE
LOSS OF FOOD SERVICE WHICH IS
ABOUT 50% OF THE FOOD DOLLARS
THAT ARE SPENT OUTSIDE OF THE
HOME IN RESTAURANTS CAFETERIAS-
SPORTING EVENTS WHATEVER IT IS.
DISPROPORTIONATE AMOUNT OF OUR
SMALL FARMERS WERE IMPACTED BY
THAT THOSE PART OF ECONOMIC
RECOVERY WE WOULD LIKE TO DO
THIS PROJECT WITH OUR
COLLEAGUES AT EPA THE JOINTLY
MANAGE BY PROCESS IMPROVEMENT
TO MAP OUT AND DOCUMENT THE
REGULATIONS THE REPORTING
REQUIREMENTS AND ALIGN WHERE
THOSE ARE BUT THERE MAY BE SOME
DUPLICATIONS WERE WE COULD
STREAMLINE OUR OPERATIONS. AND
IN DOING THAT STREAMLINE THE
REPORTING REQUIREMENTS TO
FARMERS AND RANCHERS ESPECIALLY
OUR SMALL SIZE FARMERS AND
RANCHERS- AND IMPROVE OUR
CUSTOMER SERVICE AND MAKE LIFE
A LITTLE BIT EASIER FOR THE
AGRICULTURAL COMMUNITIES OF THE
STATE- I THINK THAT FIGHT
DOCUMENTING AND MAPPING. OUR
SHARED REGULAR CHOI PATHWAY.
AND I. THE ROOT BACKING- OF
THAT SHRIMP THE ALLOW. WHEN
THAT HAVE IS PROVIDE. AND WHERE
THERE ARE TWO- WEEK COME WITH A
GOOD PACKAGE EVERY FOR OUR FROM
AND IN THE STATE OF. OPEN TO.
ON THAT AND THEY'RE GONNA
NUMBER OF CAMANCHE GROUP THAT.
I'M DONE EVAN AND ASSESSED ON
THAT'S THE STATE. SECTOR WAS
THE MOST RECENT ONE THE
ESTIMATED AT LEAST 7% OF THEIR
OPERATING COSTS WERE JUST
AROUND THE COMPLIANCE RECORDING
COSTA STRAWBERRY PRODUCERS. AS
ONE EXAMPLE OF WHAT A
SIGNIFICANT COST OF OPERATION-
THESE REPORTING REQUIREMENTS
ARE. THANK YOU SECRETARY ROSS I
KNOW THAT THE ALEJO- THIS IS
GOOD INFORMATION ABOUT THE
COMPLIANCE WITH THE WITH THE
STRAWBERRY FOLKS- YOU KNOW THEY
WERE CONCERNED ABOUT. THE BIG
PICTURE IF YOU COULD GIVE US A
FLAVOR BECAUSE I'VE MISTER
JIMENEZ TO MISTER BROWN ARE
WAITING FOR THE END IN THIS
DUPLICATIVE. ASSESSMENT WHERE
YOU THINK YOU GO TO TARGET
WHERE YOU THINK IT'S MOST WILL
AGREE JUST. YET SO- IN OUR
PRELIMINARY DISCUSSIONS WERE
JUST STARTING TO US AND WE KNOW
THAT WE NEED SOME OUTSIDE
EXPERTISE AND PROCESS
IMPROVEMENTS ASSIST BOTH OF OUR
AGENCIES- WE'VE HAD- VERY
POSITIVE CONVERSATIONS WITH THE
CHAIR OF THE STATE WATER
RESOURCES CONTROL BOARD- WITH
THEIR IRRIGATED ADVANCED
PROGRAM AND NOW THE CD SALTS.
AND OTHERS TAKE A LOOK AT THAT
WE'RE GOING TO NEED TO
PRIORITIZE AND THAT IS ONE
AGENCIES VERY EAGER TO SIT DOWN
WITH US AND DO THIS MAP APPS-
TO SEE IF. A WAY TO TAKE A MORE
IN. REPORTING APPROACH TO
MULTIPLE PRO THAT ARE IMPACTING
THE SAME ACRES OF LAND AND
THAT'S JUST ONE EXAMPLE THAT I
CAN PROVIDE TODAY. OKAY ALEJO.
ARM YOU HAVE AN OPINION ON THIS.
MISTER YES. THAT THEIR
COMMENDED WHAT THE BUDGET
ANALYST'S OFFICE SORRY FOR- THE
FOR THE RED. WERE A- AT WE DID.
THE LEGISLATURE REJECT THIS
PROPOSED- TO. AN SS OF THE-
PARKWAY. THAT ARE PLACE ON AG
INDUSTRY. FOLLOWING FOUND THAT
AN SS. OF THAT NATURE DOES HAVE
MERIT ADMINISTRATION DID NOT
PROVIDE US WITH A COMPELLING
LIST OF DUPLICATIVE REPORTING
REQUIREMENTS THAT INTENDS TO
ASSESS. I'M HAVING THIS
INFORMATION PROVIDES CONFIDENCE
TO THE LEGISLATURE THAT PROBLEM
DOES EXIST AND THAT. FUNDING
WILL BE- WELL TARGETED. THE
MORE HAN HAPPY TO CIRCLE BACK
WHICH DEPARTMENT SEE WHAT
INFORMATION THEY CAN PROVIDE US
AND REPORT BACK TO THEM. YOU
MAY AS WELL- ALSO PART OF THIS
PROPOSAL THERE'S AN ASSESSMENT
OF. ONLINE OF THEIR ONLINE
PORTAL- WE DID RECOMMEND THAT
THE LEGISLATURE REQUIRED
APARTMENTS REPORT AT THAT
BUDGET HEARING ON. WHAT OTHER
FUND SOURCES COULD BE USE
BESIDES GENERAL FUND. AND WE
FIND THAT- CONDUCTING AN
ASSESSMENT OF THEIR ONLINE
PORTAL. DOES HAVE MERIT GIVEN
THAT- THE DEPARTMENT IS-
INDICATED THAT IS. BURDEN SOME
TECHNICAL INDUSTRY AND- A
PORTAL SUCH AS THIS WOULD- THE
DEPARTMENT ITS NEXT STEPS. WHAT
IT CAN DO TO CORRECT ISSUE AND
PROVIDE A MORE CONVENIENT
SERVICE AGRICULTURE INDUSTRY.
HOWEVER WE FOUND THAT THE- I'M
ASSESSMENT LARGELY. AGRICULTURE
SECTOR AND DOESN'T- HAVE A
BROAD ENOUGH A BENEFIT- WARRANT
OFFICER THE GENERAL FUND ON.
MISTER CHAIR I HOPE. THAT I NOT-
PROVIDING. ON THAT- JUST IN
YEARS AND DOING OUR EIGHTY- IS
EIGHTY THIRTY COME. YOU TO THE
STATURE DEADLINE UNDER WHICH WE
TO MEET WE WERE A- TO DO IT
INFORMATION ARCHITECTURE
ASSESSMENT- AND SINCE THAT TIME
WE HAVE IDENTIFIED THAT
INFORMATION ABOUT JUST
LICENSING IS SPREAD THROUGHOUT
TWO THOUSAND DIFFERENT WEB
PAGES. AT CDFA- FEW OF THEM IN
PROVIDING THAT INFORMATION
PROVIDE A WAY TO APPLY ONLINE.
AND SO WE FEEL THAT DURING THIS.
US HE PULLED ISN'T. TOGETHER IS
THE FIRST STEP THAT WE COULD DO
THAT WOULD IMPROVE OUR SERVICE
HAS GOVERNMENT. TO OUR OUR
CONSTITUENTS- AND THEN MAKE AN
ASSESSMENT OF HOW THAT SHOULD
BE FUNDED BUT CHEWING THIS
PERSON'S BASELINE- ASSESSMENT
ARCHITECTURE UP FOR THAT ALL IS
HOW WE PULL THAT THE ENGINE
CRUISER. THE FARMERS RANCHERS I
CAN'T THIS IS AN EXAMPLE OF FOR
SMALL FARMERS IN PARTICULAR
THEY DO NOT HAVE. YOU KNOW A
SPECIALIST ON STAFF AND MORE
AND MORE OF EVEN THAT SIZE
FARMERS ARE HAVING TO HIRE A
FULL TIME PERSON IF YOU
COMPLIANCE REPORTING AND KEEP
UP. WITH REQUIREMENTS ACROSS
MULTIPLE STATE AGENCIES THAT
THEY INTERFACE WITH. SO THIS IS
THE FIRST STEP THAT FOR US TO
DO THAT ARCHITECTURAL LANDSCAPE
ASSESSMENT. AND THEN MAKE
PROPOSALS AND HOW THE FUND THE
NEXT ACCESS BACK THANK YOU FOR
THE CLERK. LET'S HEAR FROM ONE
OF THOSE SPOTS SMALL FARMERS
VICE CHAIR DOLLARS. OF MY GOSH
DO I START- YOUR PERSONAL I'M I.
AS A FORMER. WHO DEALS WITH
GROUNDWATER REGULATION. SERVICE
WATER REGULATIONS. TOXICS
COUNTY AG DEPARTMENT IN WE ARE
WE ARE TRUE FARM I'M THIS
ANYWAY DOLLY IN THE OTHER HOUSE
DOES ALL THAT STUFF I RUN THE
TRACTOR. AND I WILL TELL YOU.
THAT WE ARE. CONSTANTLY IN FEAR
FIRST OF ALL OF TIME TO GET IT
RIGHT NUMBER ONE AND I ALL ALL
FOR STREAM THE PROCESS. BUT I
WILL TELL YOU. THE DOUBLES AND
DETAILS. WE DO ISSUE NUMBER ONE
THAT WE- UP TODAY IS ASKING FOR
MORE MONEY TO STREAM TO TRY TO
FIGURE OUT HOW TO DO PESTICIDES.
AND YOU KNOW WE STARTED OUT AT%
SEVEN MILLION AND NOW IT'S
TWENTY TWO POINT SEVEN MILLION.
AND WE'RE NOT THERE- THERE ARE
SO MANY IT PROBLEMS IN
CALIFORNIA'S GOVERNMENT THAT I
CAN DO IN ORDER START SO I'M A
LITTLE SKEPTICAL OF HOW IT
HAPPENS BECAUSE- I'M ALL FOR
IT. I WANT I WANT TO GO ONLINE
TO BE ABLE TO TAKE CARE OF ALL
THE ROUTE I MEAN WE HAVE.
DIVERGENT WATER DIVERSIONS OF
REALLY SMALL AMOUNTS THAT IN
SOME AREAS OF THE STATE. DON'T
EVEN HAVE CELL SERVICE TO BE
ABLE TO DO REAL TIME SO YOU GOT
TO SEND SOMEBODY OUT THERE TO
ACTUALLY FIGURE OUT HOW MUCH
WATER IS GOING THROUGH A PIPE.
SO I AGREE WITH THE- THE TOO
MUCH. GOVERNMENT INTEREST
INTRUSION INTO INTO FAMILY
FARMS AND SMALL FARMS. BUT I
WANNA KNOW HOW IT'S GOING TO
BE. IMPLEMENTED BECAUSE AT THE
END OF THE DAY IF WE'RE GONNA
PUT. YOU KNOW A COUPLE MILLION
NOW TO GET STARTED AND THEN.
TENS OF MILLIONS AND WE STILL
DON'T GET THERE I MEAN THESE
DEPARTMENTS DON'T TALK TO EACH
OTHER THERE'S- RATED.
REGULATIONS ON TOP REGULATIONS
ON TOP REGULATION SO- I NEED
MORE DETAIL ON HOW YOU'RE GOING
TO. MAKE IT EASIER FOR ME TO
STAY. A FAMILY FARM IN
CALIFORNIA. HEY THAT'S WILL
LEAVE THAT AT THAT AND- WE'RE
GONNA HOLD OFF ISSUE NUMBER
TWELVE AND LET'S MOVE ON TO THE
SWEET PROGRAM. YES SIGNATURE
ROSE WATER EFFICIENCY
ENHANCEMENT PROGRAMME IT'S BEEN
ONE OF OUR MOST OVERSUBSCRIBED
PROGRAMS- FOR THE PAST- SEVEN
YEARS WE'VE FUNDED EIGHT
HUNDRED TWENTY EIGHT PROJECTS
COVERING A HUNDRED AND THIRTY
FOUR THOUSAND ACRES- WITH AN
INVESTMENT OF EIGHTY. POINT
FIVE MILLION DOLLARS THAT HAVE
BEEN REPORTED TO DATE THAT'S
ALSO BEEN MATCHED BY THE
FARMERS AND RANCHERS QUALIFY
FOR THIS PROGRAM WITH FIFTY
MILLION DOLLARS OF THEIR OWN
INVESTMENT. AND WE ESTIMATE
THAT THIS WEEK PROGRAMS
RESULTED IN EIGHTY THOUSAND
METRIC TONS OF CO TWO
REDUCTIONS IN ADDITION TO
THIRTY SEVEN AND A HALF BILLION
GALLONS OF WATER STATE
ANNUALLY- THE BUDGET REQUEST
TWENTY MILLION DOLLARS IN
GENERAL FUND IN TWENTY TWENTY
TWENTY ONE. AND TWENTY MILLION
DOLLARS AND TWENTY ONE TWENTY%
TWO THE FUNDS ADDITIONAL
PROJECTS UNDER THIS VERY
SUCCESSFUL PROGRAM ESPECIALLY
BURKE AND THE OTHER EXTREMELY
TRIED HERE- THE QUESTION WAS
RAISED BY ALEJO ABOUT. THE NEED
FOR EARLY ACTION ON THIS OF
THIS JUST ALLOWS US TO CAT BIG
CONTRACTS AWARDED EARLIER TO
START THIS WATER SAVINGS
EARLIER IF WE WERE TO GET THE
FUNDING AS SOON AS IT'S
AVAILABLE WE WOULD BE ABLE TO
PUT OUT THE REQUEST FOR GRANT
PROPOSALS. AND AWARD THOSE
CONTRACTS SO THAT THE WORK
COULD BE DONE YET IN CALENDAR
YEAR TWENTY TWENTY ONE AS
OPPOSED TO WAITING FOR THE NEXT
YEAR BUT SOME OF THESE
PROJECTS. ON THE GROUND AND
IMPLEMENTING. THE WATER AND
ENERGY SAVINGS. THANK YOU A. O.
WHAT IT WHAT DO THINK THINK
ABOUT THAT EXTRA OF WHY WE
SHOULD LET HALF THE MONEY OUT
EARLY. I'M YEAH WE- AGREE THAT
THIS PURPOSE ALIGNS WITH PAST
LET. PRIORITIES AND REDUCING
GHG EMISSIONS AND
SUSTAINABILITY MANAGING WATER
RESOURCES. ARE WE STILL
RECOMMEND THAT THE LEGISLATURE
APPROVED- THE PROPOSAL TO BE
FOUND IN THE BUDGET YEAR- JUST
TO REDUCE- INITIATIVE
COMPLEXITY IN AWARDING TWO
GRANTS AND TWO CYCLES. AND
BASED ON THE DEPARTMENT'S
TIMELINE- I BELIEVE GRANTS
WITH. BUT WOULD BE AWARDED AND
COVER IT TWENTY TWENTY TWO SO-
THERE WOULDN'T BE ANY IMMEDIATE
FUNDING BEING PROVIDED WITHIN
THE NEXT SEVERAL MONTHS. THREE
I'M JUST WONDERING WE JUST DID
VOTED ON A NINE POINT SIX
BILLION DOLLAR- IMMEDIATE.
APPROPRIATION I WONDER HOW
COMPLEX IT HAS IT'S GOING TO BE
WITH DOING THESE- OTHER ONES
CENTER STERN YOU HAVE A
COMMENT. IT USED TO THE WORDS
OF MY MOUTH IS I MEAN. I
APPRECIATE THE COMMENT AND-
ANTICIPATED COMPLEX BUT- WE'RE
BROKEN RIGHT NOW IS IN A CON.
THAT SPEED IS GOING TO BE OUR
FRIEND SO I I'D LOVE TO HEAR
FROM. CDFA I MEAN I FEEL IT'S A
TREMENDOUS SENSE OF URGENCY
AROUND EARLY ACTION THAT I
APPRECIATE. WE IS THE
LEGISLATURE TO WANT TO HAVE.
FOR SIDE IN TIME AND DRIVEN
MINISTRY TO PROCESS BUT IF. YOU
KNOW IF WE NEED TO GET. FARMERS
BACK ON THEIR FEET OR PREPARE
FOR THIS DROUGHT SEASON RIGHT
NOW I MEAN THAT'S WHAT I'M MOST
WORRIED ABOUT THAT CLOCK IS
TICKING. AND SIGMA'S HITTING.
N. THE GREAT THE GROUNDWATER
YOU KNOW ASSESSMENT PLANS THE
GSA'S ARE COMING IN AND THERE'S
GOING TO BE  LOT OF TENSION IN
THE LAWSUITS HAVE ALREADY
STARTED. AND IF THERE'S SOME
WAY. TO MITIGATE THAT TENSION
RIGHT NOW SO THAT WE DON'T HAVE
A TRAIN WRECK. AT THE END OF
THIS SUMMER ACT I SAY GO SO I
JUST I WANT TO HEAR THAT. I
MEAN CAN YOU SOLVE THAT IT
MINISTRY TO COMPLEXITY ISSUE
SECRETARY ROSS- I MEAN LIKE HOW
I'D LOVE TO HEAR. A RESPONSE ON
THAT JUST BECAUSE- WE HAVE
DEBATED THIS THOROUGHLY BECAUSE
THIS INVOLVES NOT ONLY OUR
OFFICE OF ENVIRONMENTAL.
FARMING AND INFORMATION IT ALSO
INVOLVES OUR GRANTS OFFICE. AS
WELL AS OUR FINANCIAL SERVICES
BECAUSE OF THAT THE SCOUT
APPLICATION SO BASS BOTH ALL
TAKE A CERTAIN AMOUNT OF TIME.
TO ENTER INTO THE SYSTEM AND
WHILE IT DOESN'T IMPROVE. WHO'S
THE COMPLEXITY. WE ARE PREPARED%
TO MAKE THIS WORK BECAUSE WE
THINK IT'S THE RIGHT THING TO
DO FOR FARMERS AND RANCHERS. WE
HAVE A HIGH DEGREE OF
CONFIDENCE THAT WE COULD HAVE
CONTRACTS- IN PLACE- SO THAT
THE WORK IT ACTUALLY BEGAN. ON
LATE OCTOBER EARLY NOVEMBER I
DON'T THINK THAT'S OVERLY
OPTIMISTIC. THAT'S IMPORTANT
BECAUSE WE WANT TO GET IT DONE
BEFORE WE HOPE THE RAINS COME
LATER IN THE WINTER TIME. AND
THAT PUTS PROJECTS ON THE
GROUND. JUST START SOME OF
THESE WILL BENEFIT FROM YOU
KNOW IF WE HAD A WET WINTER
FROM RECHARGE AND BEING ABLE
TO. START THAT WORK SO. OUR
STAFF IS VERY DEDICATED WE WORK
WELL ACROSS OUR VARIOUS
DIVISIONS TO MAKE THESE
PROJECTS WORK IN AN INTEGRATED
KIND OF WAY AND I'M CONFIDENT
THAT WE GET THE WORK. IN THE
GROUND BEFORE. THE END OF
TWENTY TWENTY ONE. THANK YOU
GUYS PRESSURE DAHLE. I JUST
COMMENT LET THE BETTER END OF
THE DAY THERE'S APPLICANTS OUT
THERE FOR THE THERE ARE YOU
READY GO THEY JUST NEED
RESOURCES TO GO. OKAY THANK YOU
WE'RE GOOD TO HOLD THAT. AND
YOU BOTH FOR BACK TO STAFF ON-
THE FOLLOW UPS NOW LET'S. TALK
ABOUT MICROGRAMS FOR
UNDERSERVED. POPULATIONS AND OF
ON THE FARM PLUS ALSO SMALL AND
EVEN HI EVEN MEDIUM SIZE FARMS.
SECRETARY ROSS YES THIS IS A
TECHNICAL ASSISTANCE PROGRAM
FOR UNDERSERVED FARMS WERE
VERY. EXCITED AND GRATEFUL THAT
THE GOVERNOR HAS PROPOSED IN
HIS BUDGET THIS SPECIFIC
ASSISTANCE- FOR SMALL AND
UNDERSERVED FARMS IT'S A TOTAL
OF SIX POINT SEVEN MILLION
DOLLARS IN GENERAL FUND ONE
TIME. A THREE POINT THREE FIVE
AND IN EARLY ACTION AND- AT THE
NATIONAL POINT THREE FIVE FOR
THE NEXT FISCAL YEAR. 20% OF
CALIFORNIA'S FARMERS ARE IN THE
CATEGORY OF SOCIALLY
DISADVANTAGE WHICH IS THAT AT A
DESIGNATION UNDER THE FARM BILL
AND- THE USDA CENSUS OF
AGRICULTURE. IT'S A GROWING
NUMBER OF SMALL FARM BUSINESS
OWNERS THAT HAVE UNIQUE
CHALLENGES. THAT ARE LIKELY TO
BE UNDER RESOURCE THEY HAVE
LIMITED ACCESS TO CAPITAL THEY
FACE LANGUAGE OF EDUCATIONAL
BARRIERS. MARKETING THEIR
CROPS- AND THEY DON'T HAVE LONG
TERM ACCESS TO LAND. ON MANY OF
THESE CHALLENGES WERE
IDENTIFIED IN THE FORMER EQUITY
ACT THAT WAS DISTRIBUTED TO THE
LEGISLATURE EARLY IN TWENTY
TWENTY AS A RESULT OF THE
TWENTY SEVENTEEN FORMER EQUITY
ACT- THAT WAS PASSED- SO. WE
KNOW THAT THIS IS SHARED BY ALL
FROM FARM AND BECOME HAS. AS OF
ECONOMIC WEEK. NINE OF THE JUST.
HEAD THE PAYCHECK BY LOSS OF
RESTAURANTS. I'M SOMEWHERE
IMPACT BY FAR MARKET. MANY WERE
NOT ABLE TO HAVE IT TOO ONLINE
SALE DIRECTLY TO COST- THAT
THEY NEED THE TECHNICAL
ASSISTANCE TO GO THROUGH THE
MAZE OF THAT. WE ALSO KNOW FROM
THE FEEDBACK WE'VE GOTTEN FROM
OUR LISTENING SESSIONS WITH
SMALL FARMERS IN THE CBO'S THAT
SERVE UNDER RESOURCE FARMERS.
BUT MANY OF THEM WERE NOT ABLE
TO ACCESS USDA ASSISTANCE
PROGRAMS THAT WERE ESTABLISHED.
I'M THOSE ARE VERY COMPLEX.
PROCESSES AND YOU ARE VERY VERY
SMALL FARMERS AND UNDER
RESOURCE FARMERS WERE ABLE TO
TAP INTO THAT. SO A BIG
EMPHASIS ON THIS IS EQUIPPING
THE CBO COMMUNITY AND YOU SEE
ACTING NATIONAL RESOURCES
COOPERATIVE EXTENSION. SMALL
FARM ADVISORS SO THAT THEY CAN
OFFER THAT HANDS ON TECHNICAL
ASSISTANCE. TO HELP THE SMALL
DISADVANTAGED FARMERS TAP INTO
ANY RELIEF PROGRAMS THAT ARE
AVAILABLE AT USDA THE PACKAGE
THAT PASSED AT THE END OF
TWENTY TWENTY. HAS CONSIDERABLE
DOLLARS THAT ARE IN THE PROCESS
OF BEING DEVELOPER GRANT
PROGRAMS. BUT WE'RE VERY
ANXIOUS TO GET EARLY ACTION ON
THE US TO SUPPORT THE SMALL
FARMERS AND BEING ABLE TO.
ACCESS THOSE FUNDS INTO IN
ADDITION TO ANY RELIEF DOLLARS
THAT ARE AVAILABLE THROUGH THE
FOCUS OFFICE- WHAT WE
SPECIFICALLY PROPOSED ON
BECAUSE I KNOW THAT WAS A
QUESTION FROM THE L. A. O. YES
MORE SPECIFICS WE HAVE BEEN
ABLE TO DO A NUMBER OF
LISTENING SESSION SINCE THIS
PROPOSAL WAS MADE IN JANUARY.
SO FOR THE EARLY ACTION WE'RE
PROPOSING ONE POINT THREE FIVE
MILLION DOLLARS FOR TECHNICAL
ASSISTANCE. THE UC COOPERATIVE
EXTENSION IN ADDITION TO OUR
STAFF ASSISTANT. JUNIOR DOLLARS
FOR GRANT PROGRAM TO HELP AS
MANY CBO THAT. SOME ARE NEW IN
THE LAST DECADE THEY'RE
OFFERING LOW THE- AND CULTURE
APPROPRIATE ASSIST TO THE SMALL
FOR THAT HAVE. BUT A GROUP
CALIFORNIA AND THROUGHOUT OUR
WILL. THIS WILL BE A GREAT COOK.
IF THE CLIP OVER TO YOUR
CARRIER HELP FARMERS.
SPECIFICALLY TO TAP IN THOSE BY
ALL- DOLLAR AND THEN HUNDRED
DOLLAR FOR MY GRANTS THE FARM.
AND THE NEXT YEAR IT WOULD BE
ONE POINT THREE FIVE DOLLAR.
THROUGH YOU SEE SMALL. AND BY.
AS WELL AS THAT WOULD BE FOR
TWO TWENTY AND TWENTY TWENTY
THREE AND ONE POINT THREE FIVE
NINE DOLLARS FOR SECOND IS THIS.
FOR TWENTY THREE TWENTY. AND
SIX AND FIFTY THOUSAND FOR MY-
FOR FARMERS- AND THEN AS YEAR.
AVAILABLE. FOR THANK YOU
SECRETARY ARE RIGHTS. CALIO YOU
GARGLE BREAK COUNTY. IS THAT
ANSWER THE BECAUSE ABOUT THEIR
EARLY MONEY FOR GRANT SINCE
GRANT. OF THE DEPARTMENT OF AT.
OWN SKETCH DOESN'T GO UP UNTIL
OCTOBER. TO HIM MANIS. DO I
HAVE THE RIGHT I'M SORRY MR
WASN'T WAS HAVE TROUBLE AND MY-
NO GO AHEAD. YES THE INTENT OF
THE ROLE OF THE NOT RAY ANY CAN
WITH OUR OFFICE HOWEVER DO-
THREE THAT ARE IN THE OF THAT
WE CAN WOULD PROVIDE THE LET-
BUT- HE PIECE OF INFORMATION IN
ASSESSING THE TWO GRANTS BEING
PROPOSED. ONE OF THOSE
QUESTIONS RELATES TO THEM THE
RECENT FEDERALLY FACT IT CHEN
THE GRANTS THAT ARE BEING
PROPOSED THERE MAY BE SOME
DUPLICATIVE EFFORTS THERE- HOW
THE DEPARTMENT DEFINED SMALL
MID SIZE FARMERS USING THE USDA
DEFINITION OF SMALL AND MID
SIZE THAT. COMPASSES AROUND 85%
OF THE FARMS IN CALIFORNIA SO
WE FIND THAT THAT MADE ME MAKE-
FUNDING HARD TO TARGET AND
THEN- SECTOR US- PROVIDE
INFORMATION HOUSING MONEY WILL
BE SPLIT BETWEEN THE TWO GRAND.
AND THEN WE ALSO RECOMMEND THAT
THE LEGISLATURE PROVE ANY
FUNDING IN THE BUDGET YEAR. I'M
EARLY ACTION IS LIKELY NOT
WARRANTED GIVEN THAT FUNDING
WILL BE IS WILL NOT BE USED TO
SUPPORT IMMEDIATE SERVICES IN
THE CURRENT YEAR. YOU MAKE A
DISTINCTION BETWEEN THE EARLY
ACTION TO PROVIDE THE TECHNICAL
ASSISTANCE THROUGH THE OUT
REACH FOR THESE. MICRO FOLKS
VERSUS THE ACTUAL FUNDING OF
THE GRANT. IS BLACK DOES IT
SEEM CONCEIVABLE TO YOU THAT
THAT SOME OF THIS WORK COULD BE
DONE IF THEY GOT THE PCP WITH
IT THAT SOMEBODY PEOPLE COULD
ACTUALLY. GO OUT IN THE
COMMUNITY OR DO WHATEVER. ONE
DOES THE CONTACT THESE
UNDERSERVED FARMERS. I SEE THAT
IS A DIFFERENT FUNCTION THAT
ACTUALLY. YOUR PROOF FOR THE
GREAT BECAUSE THEY CAN CONSIDER
THE GRANT RIGHT THIS IS START
THE APPLICATION PROCESS. MISTER
CHAIRMAN I SPEAK TO THAT THAT
IS THAT IS THE- OF EARLY. IS TO
MAKE SURE WE HAVE GO THROUGH
YOU SEE COOPERATIVE. SMALL FARM
ADVISORS AND THE CV I WAS. AT
WORK WITH MANY OF THE SMALL SIT
DOWN FARMERS. THAT THEY ARE TO
DO THAT. ON TECH THIS
SPECIFICALLY. TO HELP THE SMALL
FARMERS TAP INTO FEDERAL
ASSISTANCE PROGRAMS FOR GRANT
PROGRAMS AS WELL AS ANY
PROGRAMS AT THE STATE HOUSE FOR
SMALL BUSINESS. I ALSO AND I
APOLOGIZE THAT I NEGLECTED. TO
ADDRESS THE QUESTION ABOUT.
DEFINITION OF SMALL FARM. HELLO
DOES HAVE SMALL FARMS THEN-
ACROSS YOU THAT STATES. BUT WE
PROPOSE. AFTER LISTENING
SESSIONS AND WE WILL DO
ADDITIONAL LISTENING SESSIONS.
TO MODIFY THE USDA DEFINITION
OF SMALL FARMS TO ONE HUNDRED
ACRES FOR THE LAST- THAT MAY BE
REFINED A BIT MORE BUT THAT IS
OUR INTENT. OR GOING OUT TO AN
ADDITIONAL AMOUNT OF LISTENING
SESSIONS BEFORE WE PUT THAT.
THE FINAL GRANT STAFF TOGETHER
FOR THE GRANT PROGRAM BUT FOR
TECHNICAL ASSISTANCE. THAT'S
THE PIECE THE BEST THAT WE FEEL
IS VERY IMPORTANT TO GET FUNDED
YEAH IN THIS. CURRENT YEAR
THANK YOU THANK YOU ALRIGHT
LET'S CONTINUE TO DISCUSS
THAT'S WHAT'S WILL MOVE ON TO
OUR LAST ISSUE IN PART A- WHICH
GOT A LITTLE BIT MORE
INTERESTING WITH THE ALEJO'S.
HI ANALYSIS OF THE TWO THIRDS
VOTE IS NECESSARY FOR THE- THE
MILL IF IT WASN'T ALREADY AN
INTERESTING. TOPIC THIS IS THE
TRANSITION TO SAFER MORE
SUSTAINABLE PEST MANAGEMENT.
AND THE SECRETARY. ROSS YOUR
JOB JUST GOT TOUGH. EVERY
PLEASE GO AHEAD. THE TERM AND I
THINK I WAS GOING TO PRESENT
THIS ITEM OKAY I APOLOGIZE. AND
I AND THE JOB JUST YET OUT TOP
BUT I'M A PART WITH THAT THE
HAS REGULATION INVEST THANK YOU
MISTER. FIVE I'M SORRY I SHOULD
GOTTEN THAT GO AHEAD MISTER
GOOD MORNING CHAIRMAN HOUSE AND
OF THE SUBCOMMITTEE AND THANKS
HAVING HERE TODAY. MY NAME IS
ALL SENIOR I'M THE TO. OF THE
TO OF PASSED REGULATION AT PA.
IF I'M I'D LIKE TO START
STATION WITH JUST A STATE ON
THE DEPARTMENT'S PROPOSAL IN
FRONT OF YOU. OUR DISCUSSION
TODAY WILL FOCUS ON OUR VCP TO
REQUEST SUPPORT TOO FOR THE
STATE'S TRANSITION TO SAFER AND
MORE SUSTAINABLE PEST
MANAGEMENT. THE GUY BUDGET
PROPOSES TO REPLACE THE CURRENT
BLACK FEMALE ASSESSMENT ON
PESTICIDE SALES. WITH A RISK
BASED HERE NO ASSESSMENT. WHERE
HIGHER TOXICITY PESTICIDES ARE
ASSESSED A HIGHER FEE. AND WE
BELIEVE THE TRANSITIONING FROM
A BLACK MALE TO A TIERED MILL
WILL BE A SIGNIFICANT MARKET
SIGNAL. WHERE WE WANT TO GO AS
A STATE REGARDING PESTICIDE
USAGE. ONCE FULLY PHASED IN BY
TWO THOUSAND TWENTY FOUR TWENTY
FIVE WE WANT TO GIVE ADEQUATE
TIME FOR BILL PAYERS TO ADJUST.
TO THE NEW TIERED MAIL THIS
BOLD AND INNOVATIVE APPROACH IS
ANTICIPATED TO GENERATE
APPROXIMATELY FORTY FIVE
MILLION DOLLARS IN ANNUAL
REVENUE. TO THE DVR FRONT. THE
ADDITIONAL REVENUE WILL FUND
VARIOUS DPR AND CDFA PROGRAMS.
WILL ALSO INCREASE OUR SUPPORT
TO COUNTY AGRICULTURAL
COMMISSIONERS FOR LOCAL
PESTICIDE USE ENFORCEMENT
ACTIVITIES. AND WILL ENHANCE
OUR ABILITY TO ENGAGE WITH
PESTICIDE IMPACTED COMMUNITIES
AROUND THE STATE OF CALIFORNIA.
IN ORDER TO ACCELERATE THE
STATE'S TRANSITION FROM HARMFUL
PESTICIDES TO MORE SUSTAINABLE
TOOLS. WELL THE GOOD NEWS IS
THAT DPR AND OUR SISTER
AGENCIES CERTAINLY INCLUDING
CDFA. ARE DEEPLY ENGAGED A
GREAT INVESTMENT ACTIVITIES
AROUND CALIFORNIA. FROM
ASSISTANCE TO CHILDCARE CENTERS
ANDSCHOOLS TO WORK IN
COLLABORATION WITH LOCAL
GROWERS. IN ADDITION WE HAVE A
SUSTAINABLE PEST MANAGEMENT
WORK READ THAT WILL COMMENCE
ITS ACTIVITIES IN A FEW WEEKS
AND REVIEW THESE ISSUES IN MUCH
GREATER DETAIL OF. ABOUT
EIGHTEEN MONTHS. BUT THE REALLY
GOOD NEWS THE GREAT NEWS I
THINK IS THE CALIFORNIA FARMERS
AND BACKYARD GARDENERS AND OPEN
SPACE MANAGERS AND MANY OTHERS.
HAVE BEEN UTILIZING INTEGRATED
PEST MANAGEMENT PRACTICES SINCE
THE NINETEEN FIFTIES AND SO I
THINK THAT WE'RE WELL ON OUR
WAY. ON THIS TRANSITION TO
SAFER AND MORE SUSTAINABLE PEST
MANAGEMENT TOOLS. AND WITH THAT
MISTER CHAIRMAN I'D BE HAPPY TO
ANSWER ANY QUESTIONS THAT THE
COMMITTEE MAY HAVE IN STORE
VERY GOOD SECRETARY. ROSS DID
YOU HAVE ANYTHING TO. ADD ON
YOUR SITE THE LEDGER. HE OF THE
ONLY THING I'D LIKE TO MISTER
BECAUSE THAT- IN ORDER TO DO
THIS THERE IS A GREAT
APPRECIATION FOR THE NEED FOR
MINUTES ON THE GROUND.
TECHNICAL ASSISTANCE TO SUPPORT
FARMERS AND RANCHERS IN DOING
THIS. IT IS A MATTER OF
ADDITIONAL RESEARCH FOR
ALTERNATIVES AND HAVING PEOPLE
IN THE FIELD TRUSTED SOURCES
FROM COOPERATIVE EXTENSION.
DOING FIELD TRIALS HOLDING
DEMONSTRATION DAYS PROVIDING
TECHNICAL ASSISTANCE TO FARMERS
RANCHERS AND THE PAST CONTROL
ADVISORS. WE ALSO INCLUDE AS
PART OF THAT GRANT FUNDING THAT
WOULD. WOULD COME ABOUT FROM
THESE FUNDS- THE AGRICULTURAL
RESEARCH INSTITUTE WHICH IS
PART OF THE CSU SYSTEM. THE CSU
SYSTEM- THROUGH ITS VARIOUS
COLLEGES THAT HAVE AGRICULTURE
DEPARTMENTS- HAVE BECOME ON THE
TRAINING GROUND FOR MANY OF OUR
PEST CONTROL ADVISORS IN
ADDITION. TO YOUNG
PROFESSIONALS IN AGRICULTURAL
SECTOR WHO DO THIS FOR THE
FARMERS AND RANCHERS THEY GO ON
TO WORK FOR. THANK YOU. I
NOTICED THAT THE GOVERNOR'S
REQUEST IS ASKING FOR FORTY
FOUR POSITIONS FOR DPR BUT NO
POSITIONS FOR- THE DEPARTMENT
OF FOOD AND AGRICULTURE. TO DO
THIS- COMPREHENSIVE TRANSITION
TO SAFETY IS THAT IS THAT. JUST
GONNA BE OBSERVABLE. WE BELIEVE
THAT'S A- BASED ON- CRY STATE
AT OFFICE OF AND BY FARMING AND
IF. AND OFF HAS CON. AND NOW-
WE ANTI TO RUN THE- THROUGH.
AND MAKE AS A AS TO GET THE
DOLLARS WORK. AS THE VISION AS-
AND STILL DIRECT THEM IN A WAY
THAT ALIGNS WITH STATE POLICY
BILLS. OKAY FIVE THANK YOU.
FIVE- BELIAU YOU HAVE A
DIFFERENT TAKE ON THIS. I'M
MISTER FRENCH MAN IS WITH THE
LEGISLATIVE ANALYST'S OFFICE-
WOULD LIKE TO POINT OUT THAT IT
WAS LEGISLATIVE COUNCIL THAT
MADE THE DETERMINATION THAT
THIS WAS A TWO THIRDS VOTE I'M
PRIOR TO GOING INTO MY ARM
ASSESSMENT- BUT OVERALL WE FIND
THAT ADJUSTING THE MOLASSES MAN
IS WARRANTED GIVEN THE
STRUCTURAL DEFICIT IN THE
DEPARTMENT SPECIAL FINE- IS THE
DPR FONG. WE FIND THAT
ESTABLISHING A TIERED BELL
ASSESSMENT THAT PLACES A HIGHER
CHARGE ON MORE TOXIC PESTICIDE
IS REASONABLE AND COULD ADDRESS
ISSUES RELATED TO THE NEGATIVE
EFFECTS OF PESTICIDE USE- WE
ALSO FINE. THAT THE SPENDING.
PROPOSAL BY THE GOVERNOR'S
REASONABLE GIVEN THAT IT
LARGELY ASSIST THE STATE IN
REDUCING PESTICIDE USAGE. AND
EXPAND THE STATE'S EFFORTS IN
UPHOLDING PESTICIDE LAWS AND
REGULATIONS. HAVE A RECOMMEND
THAT THE LEGISLATURE BASIN ANY
TOURNAMENT ASSESSMENT AND ONE
OR TWO YEARS INSTEAD OF THE
FOUR YEARS THAT THE GOVERNOR'S
PROPOSING. FIND AT A FOR YOUR
FACE AND IS- QUITE LONG
ALTHOUGH WE RECOGNIZE THAT AS
THE FACE AN WOULD REDUCE SHORT
TERM COST THE BUYERS AND
SELLERS OF PESTICIDES. IT DOES
HAVE SOME NOTABLE DRAWBACKS-
ONE AND POTENTIALLY A WEEKENDS
THE MARKET SIGNALED THAT THE
PROPOSAL'S TRYING TO ACHIEVE BY
SPREADING OUT- THE RATE
INCREASES OVER FOUR YEARS. AND
THEN IT GENERATES A SMALL
AMOUNT OF REVENUES EARLY ON
WHICH REQUIRES SOME GENERAL
FUND TO COVER PROPOSED SPENDING-
AND ARE. WE PROVIDE ALTERNATIVE
BASIN SO THE GOVERNOR'S
PROPOSAL THAT USES THE SAME
RATE. BUT ARE IMPLEMENTED A ONE
OR ONE OR TWO YEARS AND WE
THINK THAT PROVIDES-
FLEXIBILITY THE LEGISLATURE AND
ALSO PROVIDES- SPENDING OUR
REVENUES TO COVER PROPOSED
SPENDING. I WOULD ALSO
RECOMMEND THAT THE LEGISLATURE
ALIGN ANY NEW SPENDING WITH THE
RATE AT WHICH REVENUES ARE
GENERATED- WE BELIEVE THIS
ALLOWS- NúMERO MILK NúMERO
REVENUES THE FULLY FUND THAT
PROPOSED SPENDING. ELIMINATES
GENERAL FUND COSTS AND
POTENTIALLY PROVIDES MORE
IMMEDIATE RELIEF TO THE DPR
FIND. THEN WE ALSO HAVE TO-
LARGER POLICY QUESTIONS THAT
THE LEGISLATURE- MIGHT
CONSIDER. ONE IS SIGNAL WHERE
THE BEST BASIS FOR TIERED TAX-
MINISTRATION IS PROPOSING TO
BASE ITS TIERED MELLUS BASED ON
A- PRODUCTS SIGNAL WORD. WHICH
INDICATES A PRODUCTS RELATIVELY
CUTE TOXICITY TO HUMANS. AND
SPEAKING EXPERTS IN THE FIELD
ACUTE TOXICITY DOESN'T
NECESSARILY CORRELATE WITH
CHRONIC TOXICITY OR LARGER
ENVIRONMENTAL EFFECTS- SO THE
EXTENT THAT THIS PROPOSAL-
ADDRESSES THESE ISSUES IS.
UNCLEAR AS TO THE LEGISLATURE
MAY WISH TO EXPLORE THE
FEASIBILITY OF- ALTERNATIVES
THAT COULD ADDRESS A BROADER
RANGE OF PESTICIDE RELATED
CONCERNS. AND ALSO- SHOULD THE
PROPOSAL REFLECT REVENUE
TARGETS ARE MARKET SIGNAL- THE
GOVERNOR'S PROPOSED RATE
INCREASES WOULD RAISE ENOUGH
REVENUES TO COVER PROPOSED
SPENDING ONCE FULLY
IMPLEMENTED. THAT WOULD ADDRESS
THE STRUCTURAL DEFICIT IN THE
DPR FINE IN THE LONG RUN.
HOWEVER UPON FULL
IMPLEMENTATION THE PROPOSAL
WOULD LIKELY WIDE IN THE PRICE
DIFFERENCEBETWEEN THE HIGHEST
AND LOWEST TIER BY ROUGHLY TWO
PERCENT. I FIND THAT THE
RELATIVELY SMALL PRICE
DIFFERENCE WOULD NOT LIKELY
RESULT IN A LARGE- CHANGE IN
THE MIX OF PESTICIDES USED IN
THE STATE. THE LEGISLATURE-
COULD CONSIDER- A DIFFERENT SET
OF RATES THAN BEING. PROPOSED
BY THE ADMINISTRATION. OKAY IT
IS. THE THAT YOU KNOW WE HAVE
THE SAME GRADE PEST WE WANT
PEOPLE TO MOVE TO LA LESS TOXIC-
PESTICIDES IN IT MAY BE. IT MAY
NOT BE THE PHARMACY THE- MENON
WITH CAN GET ON THE SHELF IS
PRETTY TOXIC AND- WE KNOW FROM
FIRES THAT SOMETIMES. I'LL SAVE
THESE THINGS LIKE A TREASURE
FOR YEARS THOUSAND HUNDREDS
DECADES YOU KNOW THEY WANNA
THEY BOUGHT SOMETHING IN THE
SIXTIES. IF IT SEEMS TO ME THAT
THE VIEWS THE FEDERAL T. SIGNAL
WORD IT'S SOMETHING THAT
EVERYBODY'S FAMILIAR WITH
WHETHER IT'S BETTER OR WORSE
WHAT WOULD YOU. PROPOSE FOR
WHAT IS THE IS. ERIN CALIFORNIA
HAS MANY OF THEIR OWN STANDARDS%
SO THAT I DON'T WANT OPEN UP
THAT CAN OF WORMS TO SAY WELL
THIS IS WHAT THE REST OF STATES
DO WITH THIS IS CALIFORNIA WHAT
WOULD. WHAT WOULD IT BE WHAT
WHAT WHAT GIVE ME SOME IDEA OF
WHAT WOULD USE OTHER THAN THE
WORDS- MISTER CHAIR OFFICE
DOESN'T HAVE BEEN NAMED
ALTERNATIVE- AT THIS POINT IN
TIME- WE'RE JUST POINTING OUT
THAT. IN TERMS OF ADDRESSING
LARGER AFFECTS THE NEGATIVE
EFFECTS RELATED TO PESTICIDES
THAT SIGNAL WORD WHAT
NECESSARILY CAPTURE ALL OF THEM
SO JUST POINTING THAT OUT TO
THE LEGISLATURE AND- MAYBE
EVEN- CONSIDERING OTHER
ALTERNATIVES FROM THIS POINT.
AND DURING ITS DELIBERATIONS.
OKAY GOOD ENOUGH FOR US CENTER
DOLLY- MY GOSH OKAY THE- FIRST
OFF. I GOT A QUESTION WHAT WHAT
SO. THE MIL TAXES BEEN STATIC
BUT IT'S GROWN OVER OVER THE
OVER THE YEARS BY MORE THAN
TWENTY MILLION WHICH- HAS A LOT
OF THE DPR BUDGET TO GROW YET
FACING THE STRUCTURAL DEFICIT
CAN YOU EXPLAIN HOW THIS
OCCURRED. WELL SURE SENATOR
DOLLY- YOU KNOW WE'VE HAD A
NUMBER OF NEW OBLIGATIONS OVER
THE LAST SEVERAL YEARS
INCLUDING PERS PAYMENTS THAT
WE'VE HAD TO MAKE. EMPLOYEE
COMPENSATION AND YOU KNOW THE
DEMAND OUR PROGRAMS HAS BECOME
THAT MUCH GREATER AS WELL SO.
WE'RE DOING A WHOLE LOT MORE
ACROSS THE DEPARTMENT. WITH THE
SAME AMOUNT OF RESOURCES THE
BILL'S BEEN STATIC AS YOU POINT
OUT SINCE TWO THOUSAND FOUR.
AND SO WE BELIEVE THAT WE
REALLY NEED TO MAKE NEW
INVESTMENTS TO REFLECT SOME OF
THE NEW THINGS THAT WE'RE
DOING- I'M MINDFUL OF BEING A
CAREFUL STEWARD OF TAXPAYER
DOLLARS THAT'S A VERY IMPORTANT
PART OF MY CHARGE YOUR- AS THE
DIRECTOR OF THE PART. OF THE
DEPARTMENT. BUT WHAT WE'RE
BEING ASKED TO DO BY
CALIFORNIANS FROM THOSE IN THE
FIELD TO THOSE IN THE BACKYARD.
OUR NEW AND I REALLY WANT TO BE
ABLE TO INVEST IN. IN PRACTICES
AND TOOLS AND THINGS THAT WILL
BENEFIT WHAT CALIFORNIANS ARE
ASKING US NOW. I THAT
INFORMATION I UNDERSTAND THAT
THE COST OF- EMPLOYEES IS
CONSTANTLY GOING UP IN THE
STATE OF CALIFORNIA. AND THAT'S
YOUR YOU HAVE EIGHT MILLION
DOLLAR DEFICIT. WHILE YOU'RE
ASKING TO INCREASE THE TAX
WHICH I BELIEVE IS VERY- MISS
GUY I THINK THIS WHOLE THING'S
MISS KIND I THINK THE WRONG
TIME TO HAVE THIS CONVERSATION.
WE'RE A PANDEMIC. FOR USING
YOUR YOUR RECORD WE'RE ASKING
PEOPLE TO USE THESE THINGS TO
STAY SAFE. AT THIS TIME WE'RE
GONNA CHANGE THE WHOLE. CONCEPT
OF HOW WE- REGULATE AND TAX
THESE PRODUCTS EASIER HOUSEHOLD
PRODUCTS THAT PEOPLE USE
EVERYDAY I MEAN CENTER MCGUIRE
HAS A BOTTLE OVER HERE THAT HAS
INTERNET TIES ARE NOT THAT.
COULD BE TALKING TO SOMEBODY.
SO WHY IS THE TIME RIGHT NOW I
THINK I THINK WE NEED TO WAIT
ON THIS I THINK IT'S THE WRONG
TIME LOOK AS A FORMER WE'VE
BEEN USING. AND TRYING TO
REDUCE- LOOK WE DON'T WANT TO
USE THESE PRODUCTS WE HAVE TO
USE THESE PRODUCTS. IS SAME AS
THE HOUSEWIFE OR THE- THE
GENTLEMAN AT HOME THAT IS
TRYING TO KEEP HIS FAMILY SAFE.
SO YOU KNOW WE'RE WE'RE WE'RE
GOING AT A TIME I THINK THIS IS
JUST TOTALLY THE WRONG TIME I
THINK TO THE CHANGING HOW WE'RE
GOING TO IDENTIFY THEM. IS NOT
THE RIGHT WAY TO GO AND ON TOP
OF THAT. BUT WE DID TALK ABOUT
OF ISSUE ONE. WHICH IS ASKING
FOR ANOTHER FIVE MILLION
DOLLARS TO DO THAT THE I. T.
PROCESS WHICH IS. YOU KNOW
MAYBE A HIGHER DISNEYLAND THEY
SEEM TO MOVE PEOPLE VERY
EFFICIENTLY AND HAVE WITH THE
WAY TO GET THINGS DONE. AND
THAT THE I. T. IN CALIFORNIA
WHETHER IT'S THE E. D. WHETHER
IT'S DPR WEATHER'S DGSE.
WHETHER IT'S- YOU KNOW THE-
DEPART- NAG THEY'RE TRYING TO
FIGURE OUT THERE IT WAS IT'S A
BOY. AND IT'S- FUN. AND IT'S
BECAUSE- SO FROM I THINK THIS
IS. TOTALLY THE WRONG TO. I
THINK THAT. YOU KNOW YOU HAVE
EIGHT MILLION DOLLAR DEFICIT IS
BECAUSE WE'RE USING LESS
PESTICIDES. WE ARE WE'RE AND
THAT'S A PROVEN FACT THAT WERE
USING LESS WERE USING SOFTER
ONES. M. AND WE'RE DRAW AND
MORE SO AS THAT. DECREASES THE
REVENUE HAS TO COME UP
SOMEWHERE WE GET THAT. BUT AT
THE END OF THE DAY THIS THIS IS
THE WRONG TIME I DIMINISH THE
PANDEMIC TAX. RIGHT NOW WHEN
PEOPLE NEED. TO USE THESE
PRODUCTS YOU'RE PUTTING A TAX
ON IT SO FOR ME IT'S WRONG AND
I WANT TO JUST CLOSE WITH LAST
THING THAT I THINK IS THE MOST
IMPORTANT THING IN CALIFORNIA
RIGHT NOW WHEN WE TALK ABOUT
PESTICIDES. THERE ARE LITERALLY
THOUSANDS. OF PEOPLE WHO ARE
GROWING. POT MARIJUANA. IT ALL
OVER THE PLACE USING PESTICIDES
THAT ARE AND AREN'T BEING
ENFORCED ARE BEING REGULATED
AND IT'S DESTROYING OUR
WILDLIFE AND OUR IN OUR STREAMS
AND HAVE THAT THAT'S A FACT AND
IF THE IF YOU DON'T BELIEVE ME
JUST GO TO GOOGLE EARTH AND
LOOK AT SISKIYOU COUNTY. IS
IT'S CRAZY IF THERE'S A PLACE
THAT WE REALLY WANT TO DO
SOMETHING ABOUT PESTICIDES DR
WE WILL BE FOCUSING WOULD BE
PUT IN A PANDEMIC TAX RIGHT NOW
WHEN PEOPLE ARE NEEDING THESE
AND WE'RE GONNA CONFUSE AMONG
THE LABELING FOR THE PEOPLE
THAT ARE TRYING TO IMPLEMENT
IT. SO I THINK THIS NEED TO BE
A LITTLE MORE WELL THOUGHT OUT
I THINK WE SHOULD GIVE YOU
EIGHT MILLION DOLLARS TO FUND
YOUR DEFICIT. IT TAKE SOME TIME
THIS I THINK IS TOLD MISSED IN
THE WRONG TIME THANK YOU MISTER
CHAIR I APPRECIATE THAT SENATOR
DOLE IN IF I COULD JUST RESPOND
TO A COUPLE OF YOUR POINTS
THERE I AGREE WITH YOU ABOUT
THE CANNABIS ISSUE AND THAT'S
WHY WE'VE BEEN WORKING CLOSELY
WITH COUNTY SHERIFF'S
DEPARTMENT ALL OF THE STATE
PARTICULARLY IN THE NORTHERN
PART OF THE STATE WHERE MANY
ILLEGAL PESTICIDES THAT ARE
BROUGHT IN FROM OUT OF THE
UNITED STATES AND USED IN THESE
MARIJUANA GROWS. REALLY WREAK
HAVOC NOT ONLY ON THE LOCAL
ENVIRONMENT LOCAL WILDLIFE AND
FRANKLY SHERIFF'S DEPUTIES
GOING IN AND TRYING TO CLEAN
THOSE UP WITHOUT REALLY KNOWING
WHAT THEY'RE DEALING WITH SO
WE'RE TRYING TO WORK WITH
SHERIFF'S DEPARTMENTS AND LOCAL
LAW ENFORCEMENT ON THAT ISSUE
BUT WITH REGARD TO THE I. T.
PROJECT YOU KNOW I'M THE
DIRECTOR OF THE DEPARTMENT AND
I WILL TAKE THE HIT FOR WHAT
WE'VE DONE INCORRECTLY IN THE
PAST I THINK WE'VE RETHOUGHT
THE WAY WE'RE DOING ELECTRONIC
REGISTRATION OF PESTICIDE
PACKAGES AND THE PROPOSAL IN
FRONT OF THE LEGISLATURE THIS
YEAR IS FAR MORE POSSIBLE. BUT
WITH REGARD TO THE SIGNAL WORDS
YOU KNOW WE LOOKED AT THE
SIGNAL WORDS THAT ARE USED BY
U. S. EPA THE NON HARSH AND
WARNING. DANGEROUS FLASHPOINTS
AND- THERE ALTERNATIVES SENATOR
HOUSE LIKE YOU WRIST. MODE FOR.
NON RESTRICTED MATERIAL BUT WE
REALLY FELT THAT THE SIGNAL
WORDS. WERE MORE COMMONLY KNOWN
TO USERS OF PESTICIDES. AROUND
THE STATE AND THAT'S WHY WE
SETTLED ON THAT ISSUE. AND
FINALLY SENATOR DOLE YOU KNOW
YOU'RE ABSOLUTELY RIGHT THAT
I'D LOVE TO GET UP TO BEAVER AT
SOME POINT THIS SPRING AND
WALKED THE FIELDS WITH YOU AND-
TALK A LITTLE BIT MRE ABOUT
WHAT NORTH STATE FARMERS ARE
USING IN TERMS OF. PROPERTY
ACTION TOOLS I THINK THAT'S AN
IMPORTANT PART OF MY JOB. ABOUT
50% OF THE PESTICIDES THAT WE
REGULATE HERE AT THE P. R. OR
USED IN. THE AGRICULTURAL
SETTING IN ABOUT 50% YOU'D FIND
UNDER YOUR SINK. OR IN THE
HOUSEHOLD ENVIRONMENT SO WHAT
WE'RE TRYING TO DO WITH THIS
PROPOSAL. IS WORK TO SUPPORT
WHAT I HEAR EVERY DAY FROM LOTS
OF CALIFORNIANS INCLUDING
GROWERS. AND HOUSEHOLD FOLKS
AND COMMUNITY ADVOCATES AND
OTHERS WHO WERE IMPACTED. BY
PESTICIDES AND THAT'S TO
CONTINUE THE TRANSITION. THAT
THE STATE HAS EMBARKED ON OVER
THE LAST NUMBER OF YEARS TO.
SAFER AND MORE SUSTAINABLE WAYS
TO MANAGE PASS. YOU'RE RIGHT.
THE PESTICIDE USE REPORTS THAT
I SEE EVERY YEAR DO INDICATE.
THAT THE USE OF THINGS LIKE
BIOPESTICIDES AND SO OFFERS
ANOTHER ORGANIC COMPOUNDS. ARE
GOING UP. AND THE MORE
DANGEROUS OR TOXIC PESTICIDES
LIKE FUMIGANTS INORGANIC
PHOSPHATES AND OTHERS. ARE
GOING DOWN. WHAT WE HOPE TO DO
WITH THIS PROPOSAL IS
ACCELERATE THE TRANSITION. I
JUST WANT TO SAY LOOK I'M NOT.
MAKING THIS PERSONAL I BELIEVE
IN YOUR HEART THAT YOU'RE
YOU'RE TRYING TO DO THE RIGHT
THING. AND I'M AND I'M NOT.
SINGLING YOU OUT AS FAR AS I.
T. DEPARTMENT I JUST WANT TO
HAVE. I JUST ASK YOU YOU KNOW.
GIVE ME ONE EXAMPLE OF. IN THE
STATE WHERE I TEASE WORK IN IN
IT WHAT HAPPENS IS WE JUST
HEARD FROM. THE NEW DIRECTOR AT
THE EDT. AND YOU KNOW WE GET A
NEW DIRECTOR ABOUT EVERY SIX TO
EIGHT MONTHS MAYBE A YEAR%
BECAUSE- THEN THEY BLAME IT ON
THE LAST ONE I MEAN. THE POINT
IS THAT. I THINK IT'S B. WHO'S
THE LEGISLATURE TO DO SOMETHING
ABOUT IT ACROSS THE BOARD I'M
I'M I'M JUST MAKE AN EXAMPLE
OF. HERE'S A THE AND YES EVEN
IF I MAY IT'S TWENTY TWO.
POINTS MIL NOW ON A PROCESS
THAT WE DON'T HAVE. AN AYE AND
I'M ONE OF THOSE GUYS IT HAS TO
OUT THE- AND- THEN DO THIS FOR.
ARE MY OWN. SO LOOK IT'S NOT
PERSONAL IT'S JUST I THINK
ACROSS THE BOARD WE DID WE DID.
IN BUT WE TO HAVE A- AND SEE
WHAT IS THE- HERE I MEAN THIS
IS THE TECH CAPITAL WORLD.
THERE ISN'T VERY TO BE A STATE.
HERE BECAUSE NOTHING AS FAR AS
I. T. WE JUST HEARD FROM THE-
CALIFORNIA DEPARTMENT- NAG
ABOUT HOW WE CAN. STOP THE
DUPLICATION OB. YOU KNOW I'LL
PROBABLY BE DEAD BY THE TIME
THAT HAPPENS. BUT I'M
FRUSTRATED I WELL I HAVEN'T
HEARD YOU. ANYTIME YOU WANT TO
COME UP TO LET'S GO TO SISKIYOU.
COUNTY BECAUSE- YOU THERE'S
WILD BILL STILL THERE. BUT NOT
FOR LONG WE DON'T USE. ABOUT
THESE PROGRESS IN IT'S JUST. ME
UP THERE YOU KNOW WHO PENALIZED
IN THIS PROCESS. IS THE FORMER
TRYING TO DO IT. HE ALWAYS GETS.
BECAUSE YOU HAVE SAID THAT CAN
FIND HIM YOU CAN TAKE IT YOU
COULD DO SOMETHING TO HIM AND
EVENTUALLY PUT HIM OUT OF
BUSINESS. WITH A PARTNER OR
WOULD YOU. WE DON'T PUT HIM IN
JAIL. BECAUSE OUR WE'RE NOT OUT
OF JAIL. NOT NO THERE'S NO WAY
TO. THEM ACCOUNTABLE. YOU WANT
TO ABOUT FRESH. THE FARM DOWN
THIS. WHO IS. INSIST YOU CAN.
WHOSE IS TRYING TO HAVE. RIGHT
AS YOU LOOK UP ON THE HILL.
NCC'S ROAST EVERYWHERE.
DESTROYING THE WHILE. THAT HE
TRYING TO PUT. IT IS. FLAT
WRONG I'M GONNA PUT THE- YOU.
I'M SAYING. NEED TO. A GOOD
LOOK AT THIS WHEN. TO GO. OUT
THERE. AND DO SOMETHING ABOUT
IT BECAUSE- AT THE END OF THE
DAY. WE ARE DESTROYING OUR
WILDLIFE AND WATERSHEDS. WITH
ALLOWING THIS TO HAPPEN AND
IT'S ALL ON US. SO I'M I'M A
PARTNER WITH YOU. COME UP LET'S
GO DO IT ALL TAKE OUT THERE AND
WE'LL TRY TO FIGURE OUT A WAY.
TO LOOK I GOT I GET CALLS FROM
MY- SURE EVERY DAY. ABOUT THE
FRUSTRATION LEVELS THEY HAVE.
TRYING TO GET ENFORCEMENT THANK
YOU. OKAY OTHER. AT I'D LIKE
FOR. TO AND YOU CAN EVEN IT NOW
DO WITH. STRAIGHT EITHER. MISS
A- MISTER. I OUR MISTER HALL.
OR MISS. A C. INCLUDING IN HERE-
FOR BOTH. A MILL. PERCENT
POSITION ON GO. FOR AIR MATA.
THAT FUNDING AND THEN. IN
INCREASE COMMUNITY. IS SET
FORTH IN. AB SIX ONE SEVEN. WE
KNOW FINANCED YOU GUYS HAVE.
ARE ASKING FOR A BIG CHUNK OF
MONEY FOR- COMMUNITY ENGAGEMENT
AND AIR MONITORING FROM OUR-
CARBON REDUCTION PROGRAM CAP
AND TRADE. MY QUESTION IS. IS
THAT WE KNOW HOW MUCH- COMES
FROM PASSED WHAT COMES. FIX
SOURCES WHAT COMES ROTATION IS
THE- IS THE ONE POINT FIVE
MILLION THAT YOU'RE LOOKING FOR
THE DPR FUND WAITED IS THAT THE
PROPORTIONALITY OF POLLUTION
THAT'S CREATED FROM PESTICIDES.
HI LIZZY EERIE DEPARTMENT OF
FINANCE I'D ACTUALLY LIKE TO
ASK MY COLLEAGUES AT THE
DEPARTMENT PESTICIDE REGULATION
TO AND TAKE THIS QUESTION THANK
YOU. THEIR BRAINS CARRY MORE
SLIM ONE OF THE CSU TRACTOR IS
I THINK YOU ARE. AND SO DID THE
PURPOSE THE FUNDING THAT
PROPOSED FOR THE MONITORING AS
WELL TO WORK THIS BEING DONE SO.
WITHIN THE THAT WE HAVE TO
START FUND THROUGH. FUND I'M
AND THIS IS PRETTY FOR MOM OR
SIDES WE DO THE SAME OR WITH
CARD. AND IS ASKING KERR OF HOW
WE ABOUT AND- WITH AT
AGRICULTURE PASSES USE AND HOW.
AT. MONITOR THOSE AT. ACROSS
THE STATE. WITH REGARDS THE
BUSINESS OR- FOR ENGAGED. THIS
WAS REALLY PROMPT FIRED. AROUND
A SIX. IN SOME INTENSIVE
COMMUNITY. AND EVEN HAVING GET
IN PART WITH COMMUNITIES
HEARING. I CAN AS WELL AS WITH
CARBON WILL ARTISTS BUT WE SEE
THIS IS BEING AN AREA THAT WE
REALLY. TO EXPAND INTO AND ALL
OF THE WORK THAT DOING THERE IS
A AND COMMUNITIES THAT ARE NOT
INCLUDE IN THE EIGHTIES SEVENTY
AT YOU HAVE. A HAVE PESTICIDES
BEING YOU. WITHIN THEIR- IS ONE
TO MAKE SURE THAT WE HAVE
SUFFICIENT RESOURCE TO BE ABLE
TO ENGAGE WITH THOSE
COMMUNITIES STATE. OF THAT
MAYBE NICE THAT YOU REALLY WANT
TO DO THAT AND GOVERNMENT HAS
THAT'S A LOT OF OTHER THINGS MY
QUESTION IS AND THEY'LL HAVE TO
GET BACK RIGHT NOW BUT- BUT-
THIS ISN'T YOUR POLLUTION
PROGRAM. IT'S AN AIR POLLUTION
PROGRAM TO GO IN THE MONITOR
CARE POLLUTION AND SOME
PESTICIDES THERE'S GONNA BE
SOME PERCENTAGE OF POLLUTION
THERE ARE. AIR PARTICLE SINGLE
WINDOW IT'S RIGHTFULLY SO
COMING UNDER THE DPR. FINANCES
ASK FOR A LOT OF MONEY TO COME
OUT OF A CRIME RATE REDUCTION
GREENHOUSE GASES WHICH IS
NOTHING TO DO WITH AIR
POLLUTION YOU DON'T HAVE TO
MESS YOU COULD HAVE CARBON YOU
HAVE. MEANT THING IT GETS
FUNDED HERE SO I JUST WANT TO
LOOK TO SEE IF THE
PROPORTIONALITY IS SUCH IF IT'S
NOT AND WE JUST WANT TO DO
COMMUTING GAUGE WHEN. FOR
COMMUNITY ENGAGEMENT IN THE
PESTICIDE WORLD. BE SURE THAT
WE KNOW THAT THAT THAT
DISTINCTION THAT YOU'RE MAKING
THE TO SAYING WE NEED TO BE
ENGAGING THE COMMUNITIES FOR
PESTICIDES ON ITS OWN. NOT
BECAUSE OFTHE- SEVEN THE
POTENTIAL AIR QUALITY IMPACT IT
WOULD TAKE IS IT WILL HELP US
MAKING THESE DECISIONS AND-
DECIDING WHICH PART OF MONEY IS
MORE APPROPRIATE TO FUND THESE.
PROGRAMS THAT WE WANT TO DO
VERSUS GRABBING FOR THE DAY.
THE GREEN PORK THAT'S AVAILABLE
ON OTHER PROGRAMS SO THAT'S- IT
WILL GET BACK TO THAT THAT'S
GOOD. CONNECTICUT AND I CAN
PART ABLE OUR APPROPRIATE WE
HAVE DO SO. CHANGES OF A OF
STEPS WE'RE GOING TO TAKE A-
TWO MINUTES PAUSE ON THE
HEARING AND THEN WILL. WITH A
FOR A GENDER ON PAR BE WE WILL
HAVE- THE EXCEPT FOR. COMING.
OKAY ARE SUBCOMMITTEE- TWO OF
THE BUDGET IN FISCAL REVIEW ON
RESOURCES ENVIRONMENTAL
PROTECTION AND ENERGY-
UNFORTUNATELY WE NO LONGER HAVE
TRANSPORTATION WHICH IS
INTERESTING THAT WE WOULD HAVE
TO STEP FALLS OFF COMING IN.
WE'RE GOING TO START OFF WITH
PRESENTATIONS FROM THE ENERGY.
COMMISSION WITH A- MISTER
MONAGHAN AND THEN FOLLOWED BY
DIFFERENT COMPONENTS WITH THE-
YOUR RESOURCE BOARD AND- THE GO
BIZ SECTION SILVA MR MONAGHAN
GOOD MORNING WELCOME TO
SUBCOMMITTEE YOU MAY PROCEED.
IT MORNING SHARE NUMBERS- IT'S
ACTUALLY MS ON HAND. SO I'M
SPENDING MONEY DOWN ON THE LEAD
MR FOR TRANSFER AT THE ENERGY
PRESSURE- A WARNING TO ALL THE
OTHER I'M GOING BE DRINKING A
LOT OF HE ADVICE BE- APPARENTLY
MARKET A TODAY. THE MORE MY
ALLERGIES INTO HIGH SO
HOPEFULLY I WILL WILL MAKE IT-
BUT DESPITE MY OUR AND REALLY
BY TO BE HERE TALK ABOUT THE
GOVERNOR'S. AS A REAL TO THEIR
MISSION YEAH FOR THAT AS WE
LIKE CALL THEM. I DON'T YOU'RE
SAYING THAT THE WILL OF THE
ENERGY COMMISSION AND THE AIR
RESTORE BOARD ARE COMPLEMENT
AND IT'S THE WHAT COMES TO
THEIR MISSION VEHICLE MY AGENCY
IS THE LEAD FOR INFRASTRUCTURE
AND THE AIR RESOURCES BOARD IS
THE LEAD FOR VEHICLES. AND ARE
AGENCIES WORK VERY CLOSELY
TOGETHER- WHEN IT COMES TO THAT
AND WE ALSO WORK WITH OTHER
STATE AGENCIES LIKE THE PUBLIC
UTILITIES COMMISSION GO BEARS
AND OTHERS AND WE'RE ALL
WORKING TOGETHER AND
COLLABORATING TO SUPPORT
CALIFORNIA'S. GOALS ON CLIMATE
AND CLEAN TRANSPORTATION. TO
ADDRESS THIS CHALLENGE OF AIR
QUALITY IN CLIMATE CHANGE
BECAUSE YOU ALL KNOW. NEWSOM
HAS. GOALS THAT. THE ON A CLEAR
COLD. TO ELECTRIFY TRY. THESE
NEGATIVE ORDER THAT SUCH THE
GOAL THAT A 100% OF NEW
PASSENGER VEHICLES WILL BE
THEIR EMISSION BY TWENTY THIRTY
FIVE. AND ALSO ESTABLISHES
GOALS FOR DIESEL POWERED
VEHICLES AND EQUIPMENT TO
ELECTRIFY OVER THE NEXT FIFTEEN
TO TWENTY FIVE YEARS. OUR
SERVICE AND WE RECOGNIZE BOTH
THE CHALLENGES AND THE
OPPORTUNITIES TO ACHIEVE THESE
AMBITIOUS TARGETS. AND THE
CRITICAL IMPORTANCE OF HAVING
EQUITY AS A CORNERSTONE TO
EVERYTHING WE DO. POLLS WILL BE
BUILT ON WHAT WE ARE SEEING
HAPPENING AT A GLOBAL LEVEL THE
SEVENTEEN COUNTRIES HAVE
COMMITTED TO A 1100% ELECTRIC
VEHICLE FUTURE. IN JANUARY THE
GOVERNOR MASSACHUSETTS FOLLOWED
GOVERNESS AND LEAD AND SET THE
SAME GOAL CALIFORNIA HUNDRED
PERCENT. ED'S IN THE PASSENGER
VEHICLE SEGMENT BY TWENTY
THIRTY FIVE. AND I MAKERS ARE
SEEING THE WRITING ON THE WALL
AND THEY ARE DEEPLY INVESTING
IN TRANSLATIONAL APPLICATIONS
WELL. LAST MONTH GENERAL MOTORS
BECAME THE FIRST AMERICAN
AUTOMAKER HE SAID THE SAME GOAL
AS CALIFORNIA 100% YOU NEEDS BY
TWENTY THIRTY FIVE. AND JUST
LAST WEEK FORD ANNOUNCED THAT
IT WAS ELECTRIFYING ALL
PASSENGER VEHICLES.
INTERESTINGLY ALL COMMERCIAL
VEHICLES BY TWENTY THIRTY IN
EUROPE. THAT'S A REALLY THEY'RE
STARTING TO GO MAINSTREAM TODAY
THERE ARE FORTY SIX DIFFERENT
MODELS OF ELECTRIC CARS
AVAILABLE AND MANY MORE ARE ON
THE WAY. EARLY NEXT YEAR FORD
IS PLANNING TO RELEASE AN
ELECTRIC MODELS OF ITS
SIGNATURE. F. ONE FIFTY PICKUP
TRUCK WHICH IS THE BEST SELLING
CAR IN AMERICA. AND ACCORDING
TO FORD THE ELECTRIC MODEL WILL
HAVE THE BEST HORSE POWER THE
BEST WORK AND THE BEST
ACCELERATION OF ANY F. ONE
FIFTY SO. DOES THAT MEAN YOU'RE-
IT ACTUALLY MEANS YOU'RE
GETTING- A BETTER PERFORMING
VEHICLE. AND THE FORD F. ONE
FIFTY OKAY YOU'RE GOING TO BE
ABLE TO CHARGE YOUR POWER TOOLS
FROM THE VEHICLE AND FORD IS
ALSO- HAVING. THE POTENTIAL FOR
THE VEHICLETO PUT TO SUPPLY
ENERGY BACK TO THE GRID SO
THEY'RE REALLY THINKING ABOUT
THIS AS HOW DO WE CREATE A
WHOLE ECOSYSTEM OF
ELECTROCUTION THAT BENEFITS
CONSUMERS. CALIFORNIA HAS OVER
EIGHT HUNDRED THOUSAND DOES
FOLD WHICH IS JUST SHY OF HALF
OF THE U. S. TOTAL. AND I THINK
WHEN IT COMES TO ZERO EMISSION
TRANSPORTATION CALIFORNIA. IS
THE NEW MICHIGAN. FOR THEIR
MISSION VEHICLES WERE BECAME
OUR NUMBER ONE EXPORT LAST YEAR
THEY WERE NUMBER TWO THE YEAR
BEFORE. THERE ARE THREE HUNDRED
AND SIXTY INDIVIDUAL THAT
RELATED COMPANIES IN THE STATE
AND THIRTY FOUR THAT RELATED
MANUFACTURERS WITH A TOTAL OF
SEVENTY THOUSAND DIRECT JOBS IN
THE INDUSTRY. THE GOVERNOR'S
NEWSOME BUDGET- WILL HELP THE
STATE SCALE UP AND OVERCOME KEY
BARRIERS TO ELECTRIFYING THEIR
MISSION VEHICLES. ASSEMBLY THE
PROGRAM PROPOSES TO EXTEND THE
AB EIGHT PROGRAM PROVIDES FIVE
HUNDRED MILLION DOLLARS IN
INCENTIVES FOR THEIR MISSION
VEHICLES. AND GRANT THE C. C.
BONDING AUTHORITY TO FRONT LOAD
BILLION DOLLARS INVESTMENT IN
ZERO EMISSION VEHICLE
INFRASTRUCTURE AND I WOULD
EMPHASIZE THAT RUSSIAN VEHICLE
INFRASTRUCTURE INCLUDES BOTH
BATTERY ELECTRIC AND FUEL CELL
ELECTRIC. INFRASTRUCTURE SO WHY
INVEST IN VEHICLES NOW THE
GOVERNOR'S BUDGET PROPOSES A
HUNDRED FIFTY MILLION FOR GREEN
CARDS FOR ALL. WHICH ALLOWS
LOWER INCOME FAMILIES TO SCRAP
AN OLDER VEHICLE AND REPLACE IT
WITH THE ZERO OR NEAR ZERO
EMISSION VEHICLE. THE BUDGET
ALSO PROPOSES THREE HUNDRED
FIFTEEN MILLION FOR CARB HEAVY
VEHICLE INCENTIVES PROGRAM
PROJECT. WHICH PROVIDES GRANTS
TO REPLACE DIESEL VEHICLES WITH
ZERO EMISSIONS REPLACEMENT. ANY
GRANT PROGRAMS REALLY PROVIDE.
EARLY EDITION REDUCTIONS BEFORE
REGULATIONS ARE ESTABLISHED
THAT WOULD MANDATE THE SWITCH
TO ELECTRIC. AND THESE
PROGRAMS- ARE CRITICAL FOR AIR
DISTRICTS THAT ARE REALLY YOU
KNOW TURNING OVER EVERY ROCK IN
ORDER TO MEET THE PAYMENT
DEADLINES ARE LOOKING FOR
EMISSION REDUCTIONS. I'M
FOCUSED MORE ON INFRASTRUCTURE
SIDE CONSENSUS FATHER ENERGY
THAT- LET ME TALK ABOUT WHY
IT'S IMPORTANT TO INVEST IN
INFRASTRUCTURE NOW. WE OBSERVE
INFRASTRUCTURE THAT CONVENIENT
AND UBIQUITOUS ACROSS THE
STATE- WE ALSO NEED TO MAKE
SURE THAT THE MORE THAN HALF OF
CALIFORNIANS WHO LIVE IN
APARTMENT BUILDINGS. FOR
COMFORTABLE BUYING IS THEIR
MISSION VEHICLE BECAUSE THEY
HAD A CONVENIENT PLACE TO
REFUEL IT. WITHOUT INVESTMENT
NOW WE ARE NOT GOING TO MEET
THE STATE'S TARGETS FOR THAT
INFRASTRUCTURE FOR TWENTY
TWENTY FIVE. CURRENT GOAL IS TO
HAVE TWO HUNDRED FIFTY THOUSAND
CHARGERS TO SUPPORT ONE POINT
FIVE MILLION EDIE'S AND TWENTY
TWENTY FIVE. WE CONDUCTED
ANALYSIS OF ALL THE INVESTMENTS
THAT WE'RE MAKING UTILITIES ARE
MAKING PRIVATE INDUSTRY THAT'S
GROUP THAT'S REPORTED PUBLICLY
WHAT WE'RE FINDING IS A
SHORTFALL OF SIXTY THOUSAND.
CHARGERS BROUGH TWENTY ONE
STATIONS SHORT OF THE STATE'S
GOAL OF HAVING TWO HUNDRED
HYDROGEN STATIONS BY TWENTY
TWENTY FIVE. WE'LL NEED TO
SIGNIFICANTLY RAMP UP THAT
INFRASTRUCTURE POST TWENTY
TWENTY FIVE TO MEET OUR TARGETS
FOR TWENTY THIRTY AND BEYOND.
SO NOW SAYS THAT- WE ARE
REQUIRED TO DO GOING TO GET THE
LEGISLATURE IS TO PUBLISH-
ANALYSIS OF TWENTY THIRTY
CHARGING NEEDS WHICH WAS
REQUIRED BY AB TWENTY ONE
TWENTY SEVEN. WE'VE DONE A
DRAFT ANALYSIS THAT FINDS THAT
WILL NEED ABOUT ONE POINT FIVE
MILLION CHARGERS TO SUPPORT
EIGHT MILLION PASSENGERS ADDS.
AND THIS IS- WHAT THEY ARE
THESE MOBILE SOURCE STRATEGY
INDICATES THAT WOULD PUT US ON
A TRAJECTORY TO MEET A 100% OF
THAT BY TWENTY THIRTY FIVE.
OKAY PLAN ADVANCES FOR GOALS.
IMPROVING PUBLIC HEALTH.
CUTTING CLIMATE POLLUTION
ADVANCING ECONOMIC RECOVERY AND
JOB CREATION. PROMOTING EQUITY.
ON THE HEALTH SIDE I THINK YOU
THIS IS NO SURPRISE ALL OF YOU-
TRANSLATION IS A MAJOR SOURCE
OF CARBS AIR POLLUTION. IT'S
BECAUSE IT'S THE SOURCE OF 80%
OF THE STATE NOT FORMING
NITROGEN OXIDES 95% OF ITS
POWERFUL. DIESEL PARTICULATE
MATTER AND THIS IS ESPECIALLY
IMPORTANT FOR COMMUNITIES THAT
LIVE NEAR GOODS MOVEMENT
CORRIDORS. AND THAT ARE
PARTICULARLY IMPACTED BY THIS
HARMFUL POLLUTION. ON THE
CLIENT SIDE- IT'S THE SOURCES
50% HALF OF OUR GREENHOUSE
GASES WHEN YOU ACCOUNT FOR THE
EMISSIONS FROM SHALE
PRODUCTION. AND OVER THE LAST
DECADE WE'VE SEEN OUR EMISSIONS
FROM THE ELECTRICITY SECTOR CUT
IN HALF. TRANSPORTATION ISSUES
OF ACTION AND. TRENDING UPWARD-
IT SIDE YOUR BILL THAT OUT OF
SHOULD BE IT JUST. IS NOT
DIDN'T THAT WILL SUPPORT
RECOVERY EITHER SHOVEL READY
PROJECTS THEY'RE GOING TO PUT
CALIFORNIANS TO WORK BUILDING.
THAT WE NEED FOR THE FUTURE.
THE INVESTMENT ALSO SEND THE
MARKET SIGNAL THAT COMPANIES
CAN BANK ON. FINALLY ON THE ON
THE EQUITY SIDE- THE
LEGISLATURE PASSED SB ONE
THOUSAND WHICH REQUIRES THE
ENERGY COMMISSION TO DO AN
ANALYSIS EVERY YEAR ON EQUITY
IMPLICATIONS OF CHARTER
DISTRIBUTION. WE PUBLISHED THE
FIRST REPORT IN DECEMBER AND WE
FOUND- CHARTER DISTRIBUTION
PROBABLY FOLLOWS EASY
DEPLOYMENT BUT WE NEED TO DO A
BETTER JOB ENSURING THAT RURAL
AND MOUNTAIN COMMUNITIES AS
WELL AS LOW INCOME COMMUNITIES
HAVE ACCESS TO CHARGING
INFRASTRUCTURE. WE ALSO NEED AS
A MATTER BEFORE TO ADDRESS THE
FACT THAT HALF OF CALIFORNIANS
LIVE IN MULTIFAMILY DWELLINGS
AND WE NEED TO MAKE SURE THAT
THE BURDEN. FOR THEM TO CHARGE.
SO TO SUMMARIZE THEIR MISSION
VEHICLES ARE THE- NOT TO THINK
HELL. GLOBALLY IS ABOUT WILL
HELP OVERCOME ONE OF THE
BIGGEST TERRORIST BARRIERS WE
SEE TO THE COMMERCIAL.
COMMERCIALIZATION THEIR MISSION
GETS OLD WHICH IS THE OF
INTEREST. BY INVESTING. WE WILL
MARKETS IN ENCOURAGE ADDITIONAL
INVESTOR BY INTEREST HERE IN
OUR COSTA. GOOD JOB TO HELP THE
ECONOMY TO RECOVER. IT WILL
ALSO PROVOKE PROMOTE MORE
EQUITABLE ACCESS TO ENSURE
EVERYONE BENEFITS FOR THE
FUTURE. I'M JOINED BY HANNAH
RUSSELL WHO IS THE DEPUTY
DIRECTOR OF THE CHILDREN
TRANSPORTATION DIVISION AT THE
ENERGY COMMISSION. AND ALSO BY
SEVENTY PER GUEST WHO IS ADEPT
THE DIVISION CHIEF AT CARP FOR
THE MOBILE SOURCE CONTROL
DIVISION AND I'M GONNA TURN IT
OVER TO THANK YOU CAN MAKE A
FEW REMARKS ON BEHALF OF YOUR
REQUEST. FOR THANK YOU. THANK
YOU COMMISSIONER AND I THINK
YOU CHURN MEMBERS BY WAY OF
INTRODUCTION- MY DIVISION
OVERSEES MEDIUM AND HEAVY DUTY
VEHICLE REGULATIONS AND ALSO
MANY OF CARDS INCENTIVE
PROGRAMS THE CARSON CENTER
PROGRAMS ARE DESIGNED TO
ACHIEVE MULTIPLE GOALS
INCLUDING ELECTRIFICATION BY
MATT AND COMMUNITY HEALTH
BENEFITS AND THE NEED FOR
ACCELERATING- TURNING OVER
OLDER MORE POLLUTING EQUIPMENTS
AND VEHICLES JUST CAN'T BE
OVERSTATED. WELL WE'VE ALL MADE
GREAT PROGRESS OTHER
INVESTMENTS BY THE STATE
STAKEHOLDERS INDUSTRY AND LOCAL
AIR DISTRICTS OVER 90% OF
CALIFORNIANS STILL READ THAT
HEALTHCARE. THE REGULATIONS AND
INCENTIVES BOTH PLAN IMPORTANT
ROLE IN CALIFORNIA'S PORTFOLIO
REGULATIONS CAN SET DEADLINES
FOR THE MANUFACTURE PRODUCTION
ON THE SUBSEQUENT ADOPTION OF
ZERO EMISSION TECHNOLOGY. AND
INSTEAD OF TOPIC SALARY BUT
TAKE OF THAT TECHNOLOGY TO
ENSURE EARLY AIR QUALITY BEING
COMMUNITY HEALTH BENEFITS. SO
GIVE A BRIEF OVERVIEW OF THE
RELATIVE INCENTIVE PROGRAMS
BEFORE US TODAY THE CARL MOYER
PROGRAM YOUR QUALITY
IMPROVEMENT PROGRAM. ENHANCE
THE MODERNIZATION PROGRAM. SO
THE PROBLEM WHERE PROGRAM WAS
ESTABLISHED IN NINETEEN NINETY
EIGHT TO HELP LOCAL AIR
DISTRICTS ACHIEVE COST
EFFECTIVE EMISSION REDUCTIONS
NEEDED TO MEET OUR HEALTH
PROTECTIVE FEDERAL AIR QUALITY
STANDARDS. IT PROVIDES
INCENTIVES FOR THE PURCHASE OF
CLEAR TECHNOLOGIES. A CRITICAL
UNDERPINNING OF THE PROGRAM IS
THAT IT TOOK CELEBRATES THE
TURNOVER OF OLDER EQUIPMENT AND
VEHICLES DELIVERING MUCH NEEDED
COMMUNITY HEALTH AND AIR
QUALITY BENEFITS. AND IS THERE
A MOTION TECHNOLOGIES REACH
MARKET SCALE. THE GIRL WHERE
PROGRAM WILL PLAY AN INCREASING
ROLE IN TRANSITIONING THE FLEET
FROM COMBUSTION TO ZERO
MISSION. AND IN FACT RECENTLY
KARMANAU STREAMLINED
PARTICIPATION OPPORTUNITIES FOR
SMALLER FLEETS PURCHASING ZERO
EMISSION TRUCKS. THE OVERALL
THIS PROGRAM REALLY CULTIVATES
A STRONG PARTNERSHIP BETWEEN
CARBON THE LOCAL AIR DISTRICTS
BY BRINGING THE STATE LEVEL
RESOURCES TO BEAR AND UNIQUE
LOCAL. AND REGIONAL AIR QUALITY
SOLUTIONS. AIR QUALITY
IMPROVEMENT PROGRAM IS AN
INCIDENT PROGRAM ORIGINALLY
ESTABLISHED AB ONE EIGHTEEN
WITH THE PURPOSE OF HELPING TO
REDUCE CRITERIA POLLUTANT TOXIC
IN GREENHOUSE GAS EMISSION
REDUCTIONS. IT HAS AN ANNUAL
BUDGET OF ABOUT THIRTY FIVE TO.
TWENTY FIVE TO THIRTY MILLION
DOLLARS AND HISTORICALLY
EQUIPMENT SERVED AS A BLUEPRINT
FOR CLEAN VEHICLES EQUIPMENT
INVESTMENTS SUCH AS THE CLEAN
VEHICLE REBATE PROJECT. AND THE
HYBRID AND ZERO EMISSION TRUCK
AND BUS FUNCTION CENTER PROJECT
OR EACH OTHER. THIS YEAR THE
CARDBOARD ALLOCATED A QUICK
FUNDING TO SUPPORT. PURCHASE
VOUCHERS FOR CLEAN AND ZERO
EMISSION TRUCKS AND BUSES TO
REACH THAT AND PROVIDED FUNDING
FOR CLEAN CARS FOR ALL. THIS IS
A PROGRAM AUTHORIZED UNDER
EIGHTY SIX THIRTY WHICH
PROVIDES INCENTIVES TO LOW
INCOME INDIVIDUALS FOR THE
PURCHASE OF ELECTRIC VEHICLES.
THEY HAVE MODERNIZATION PROGRAM
OR IF HE WAS ALSO AUTHORIZED AB
ONE EIGHTEEN AND HAS AN ANNUAL
BUDGET OF ABOUT THREE MILLION
DOLLARS PER YEAR. THE PROGRAM
ITSELF HAS TWO MAIN COMPONENTS
AS GRAPPLING ELEMENT FOR LOW
INCOME VEHICLE OWNERS AND THIS
IS IMPLEMENTED THROUGH A
PARTNERSHIP WITH THE BUREAU OF
AUTOMOTIVE REPAIR. AND IT ALSO
HAS A SCRAPYARD PLACE ON MEANT
WHEN BY LOCAL AIR DISTRICTS IN
PARTNERSHIP WITH CARP. WHICH
HELPS LOW INCOME VEHICLE OWNERS
NOT ONLY SCRAP OLDER HIGHER
POLLUTING VEHICLES BUT ALSO
REPLACE THOSE WITH CLEAR
ALTERNATIVES INCLUDING ZERO
MISSION VEHICLES. SO WITH THAT
I THANK YOU FOR YOUR TIME. AND
HAPPY TO ANSWER ANY QUESTIONS
YOU MIGHT HAVE. BEFORE RIPPING
GOING TO HAVE. THE AIRPORT
ANYBODYELSE FROM THE A- THE
ENERGY DEPARTMENT. FOR GOBIZ.
TRINITY CHRISTIAN NOW OKAY I
GUESS WHAT WHAT WHAT WE HAVE
THE AIRPORT ON HERE YOU KNOW
THIS IS SAY THIS IS LBJ ONCE
SAID EXECUTIVE ORDERS ARE JUST
PAPER THEY'RE NOT LEGISLATION
RIGHT SO NOW WE'RE MOVING INTO
THE LEGISLATURE FEEL JUST GIVE
THAT IS BACKGROUND- MY QUESTION
IS ON WITH THE AIRPORT IS THAT
YOU KNOW WE'VE GOT THIS MIX WE
GOT A BILLION DOLLARS THAT YOU
WANT TO DO EXTENSION OF AB
EIGHT AND SECURITIZED THOSE AND
THEN. FOUR HUNDRED THIRTY FIVE
FOR CAP AND TRADE IN STAFF
REPORT. FULL ON SEPT THIRTY HI
CALIFORNIA REBATE PROGRAM WHICH
FOR SIX YEARS HAS BEEN
OVERSUBSCRIBED WAS NOT
OVERSUBSCRIBED LAST YEAR AND
OBVIOUSLY WE KNOW SOME THINGS
ABOUT THE PANDEMIC BUT BY THE
END OF THE FISCAL YEAR IS GOING
TO BE. DOWN THE ZERO. AND THEN
THERE'S NO MONEY IN THIS.
PROPOSAL TO MEET THE GOVERNOR'S
ORDER I GUESS JERRY BROWN'S
ORDER TO GET TO ONE POINT FIVE
EXAMS. BY TWENTY TWENTY FIVE.
SO IT APPEARS AT LEAST FROM
THIS MEMBER THAT. AIRBOARD IS
PULLING THE PLUG ON AN OVERLY
SUBSCRIBE PROGRAM TO PUT MONEY
INTO THE A HUNDRED FIFTY
MILLION FOR THE CLEAN CARS FOR
ALL ALL WHICH HASN'T BEEN
OVERSUBSCRIBED. EVER WHY. SO I
CAN START AND THEN PERHAPS ALL
DEFERRED IDEA OF COLLEAGUES SO
I WOULD SAY THAT THERE IS A
NUMBER OF OPPORTUNITIES HERE IN
THIS PROPOSAL BEFORE YOU
THERE'S A NUMBER OF PROGRAMS
HERE THAT DO SUPPORT ZERO
EMISSION VEHICLES AND THE REAL
VALUE THERE IS THAT THAT THAT
HEALTH AND AIR QUALITY
CHALLENGES THAT WE ARE UP
AGAINST YOU KNOW WE'RE LOOKING
AT A TRANSFORMATION OF THE SIZE
AND SCALE AND SCOPE OF WHICH-
IS REALLY CRITICAL FOR US TO
MEET OUR GOALS- AND SO OVER THE
HISTORY AND PURPOSE OF MANY OF
THESE PROGRAMS THEY HAVE GONE
TO SUPPORT ZERO EMISSION
VEHICLES SO FIFTY PERCENT. OF A
GROUP INVESTMENTS HAVE GONE TO
SUPPORT ELECTRIFICATION
HONORABLY SERVED AS A
FOUNDATION FOR PASSENGER AND
HEAVY DUTY SERVICE REBATE
PROGRAM. AND IF MPS COVERED
SPOKE. 81% OF THOSE FUNDS OF
GONE TOWARD ELECTRIC VEHICLES
IN ZERO EMISSION VEHICLES AND
EQUIPMENT AND INFRASTRUCTURE.
HAS ALWAYS BEEN AND WILL
CONTINUE TO BE ELIGIBLE UNDER
THE KOLLMEYER PROGRAM. BUT I
THINK IT'S REALLY IMPORTANT TO
HIGHLIGHT HERE. THAT THE AIR
QUALITY- RAMIFICATIONS TO
COMMUNITIES ARE ARE REAL AND SO
THAT THEY THE FEET PROPOSAL IN
FRONT OF YOU IS TO EXTEND THOSE
FEES THAT ARE PUT ON POLLUTING
VEHICLES. IT IS ALSO IMPORTANT
TO EMPHASIZE SINCE YOU'RE
ASKING FOR FOUR HUNDRED THIRTY
FIVE MILLION FROM OUR CLIMATE
PROGRAM WHICH IS DESIGNED TO
REDUCE TO DO SERIOUS TO
DECARBONISATION. THAT IF WE DO
SPEND. MONEY ON ON THE VALUABLE
PROGRAMS WE'RE NOT SPENDING
MONEY ON DECARBONISATION. AND
IF THE IF THE GOAL IS TO GET TO
POLLUTING CARS OFF THE ROAD. I
KNOW THAT WE NEED TO HELP
PEOPLE AND DISADVANTAGED
COMMUNITIES THAT'S NOT THAT'S
THAT'S NOT THE POINT. BUT EVEN
WE DON'T CARE AT LEAST FROM A
CARBON POINT OF VIEW AS WORLD
LEADERS. WE DON'T CARE IF IT'S
A RICH PERSON A POOR PERSON.
PERFECT PERSON SUBURBS ANYWHERE
WE WANT TO GET THOSE VEHICLES
OUT. AND WE AND WE HAVE. SEVEN
HUNDRED THOUSAND VEHICLES ARE
ELECTRIC VEHICLES NOW. ANY
APPEARS THAT YOU'RE SAYING.
DONE WITH MOST SUCCESS PROGRAMS
THAT WE HAVE. IT WITHOUT ANY
JUSTIFICATION OTHER THAN ONE
LINE IN THE BUDGET THAT SAYS
WE'RE GOING TO. THINK ABOUT IT
SO NOW WE HAVE YOU IN FRONT OF
US WITH MISTER COREY. IS THERE
TO SAY WAIT A MINUTE THIS IS
THIS IS GREAT THAT THE ENERGY
DEPARTMENT AND GOBIZ IN THE
GOVERNOR GOT TOGETHER AND YOU
GUYS COME UP WITH THIS PROGRAM
THAT WE WANT TO EARLY ACTION.
BUT WE'RE THE LEGISLATURE AND
IS GRANTED YOU GUYS WERE
TALKING BUT NOBODY WAS TALKING
WITH US. ABOUT THE PROGRAMS AND
ALSO IT APPEARS THAT NOBODY'S
PAYING ATTENTION. TO THE- THE
BUDGET RECOMMENDATIONS AT THIS
COMMITTEE AND THE SENATE HAVE
MADE FOR THE LAST FIVE YEARS
I'M WHAT PROGRAMS WE THINK ARE
GOOD. ON DECARBONISATION AND
AIR AIR POLLUTION SO- YES THIS
IS IN THE EARLY STAGES. WE HAVE
THE L. A. L. LET'S GO WITH THE
DAILY- YOU HAVE SOME COMMENTS
ON.THIS THE PROPOSAL. THANK
YOU MISTER CHAIRMAN MEMBERS
ROSS BROWN OF THE LEGISLATIVE
ANALYST'S OFFICE- I WILL-
APOLOGIZE IN ADVANCE YOU MIGHT
REMEMBER. LAST WEEK'S HEARING
THERE WAS A LEAF BLOWER RIGHT
OUTSIDE MY WINDOW THERE'S NOT
ONE RIGHT OUTSIDE MY WINDOW
RIGHT NOW BUT THERE IS-
SOMEBODY ACROSS THE STREET SO I
APOLOGIZE IF YOU. HEAR ANY
BACKGROUND NOISE- SO I DO WANT
TO MENTION BEFORE I KIND OF
OFFER SOME OF OUR COMMENTS ON
THE ADMINISTRATION'S OF.
RELATED IN AB EIGHT PROPOSALS
THAT WE HAVE A COUPLE REPORTS
RELATED TO. THAT AGENDA ITEMS
THAT ARE MOST ARE WEBSITE. ONE
RELATED TO G. G. R. OUT-
EXPENDITURE PACKAGE WHICH WE
DISCUSSED LAST WEEK AND THE
HEARING- BUT THERE'S ANOTHER
ONE RELATED TO THE EIGHTY EIGHT
EXTENSION ENDS- THE
SECURITIZATION PROPOSAL THAT
WAS MENTIONED SO I. JUST WHEN I
LIKE THAT- FOCUS MOST OF MY
COMMENTS ON THE- AB EIGHT
EXTENSION. OF SECURITIZATION
PIECE OF THIS PACKAGE- BECAUSE
WE DO THIN IT'S KIND OF THE
MOST SIGNIFICANT NEW PROPOSAL
THAT RAISES AN IMPORTANT POLICY
QUESTIONS FOR THE LEGISLATURE
TO CONSIDER- AND I THINK KIND
OF OUR OUR INITIAL COMMENT AND
TAKING KIND OF BIG PICTURE
TAKERS WE DO THINK THAT THE
LEGISLATURE SHOULD CONSIDER
THIS PROPOSAL. AND THE BROADER
CONTEXT OF THE STATE'S CLIMATE
AND AIR QUALITY STRATEGIES- SO
THE PROPOSAL WOULD EXTEND FEES
THAT RAISE ABOUT TWO HUNDRED
FIFTY MILLION DOLLARS ANNUALLY
FOR A VARIETY OF LONG STANDING
BY MIDDLE PROGRAMS- AS WAS
MENTIONED EARLIER- DAY
PRIMARILY FOCUSED ON REDUCING
TRANSPORTATION EMISSIONS BUT
NOT NECESSARILY ALL ON SAID SO
I THINK THAT'S IMPORTANT TO
KEEP IN MIND A LOT OF THESE
PROGRAMS IS STARKLY FOCUSED ON.
LOCAL AIR POLLUTION REDUCTIONS-
WE DID WANT TO FLY THAT YOU
KNOW THESE FEES WERE. MO RECENT
EXTENDED TWENTY FOUR. AND SINCE
THAT POINTS OF ERROR BUT WITH
THE STATE HAS ADOPTED A WIDE
VARIETY OF NEW GOALS. SINCE OUR
LAST EXTENDED RELATED TO-
TWENTY THIRTY GREENHOUSE GAS
TARGETS. AIR QUALITY GOALS THE
GOVERNOR AS AS YOU MENTION AS
ESTABLISHED EXECUTIVE ORDER
RELATED DISASTERS AND THERE'S A
COUPLE EXECUTIVE ORDERS. THE
LEGISLATURE ONE TO KIND OF
EVALUATE WHETHER IT DID. AGREES
WITH THOSE GOALS AND THOSE TIME
LINES- BUT THERE'S ALSO NEW
FUNDING SOURCES OF THE LAST
SEVERAL YEARS- AND INCREASES IN
FUNDING SOURCES CAP AND TRADE
FUNDS AS THE CHAIR MENTIONED-
RATEPAYER FUNDING THROUGH I'LL
USE LEGAL SETTLEMENT FUNDING SO
THERE'S A WIDE VARIETY OF
FUNDING SOURCES- THAT. KIND OF
NEED TO BE CONSIDERED IN
CONJUNCTION WITH THIS PACKAGE.
AS WELL AS NEW- NEW OR-
PROPOSED KIND OF REGULATORY
PROGRAMS THE CARS OR CARS THAT
ARE. IMPORTANT TO KEEP IN MIND
SO I THINK IT'S A GOOD
OPPORTUNITY TO RE EXAMINE THE
STATE'S OVERALL STRATEGY FOR
ACHIEVING BOTH CLIMATE AND AIR
QUALITY GOALS. I WANT POLICIES
REGULATIONS VERSUS X.
INCENTIVES FOR EXAMPLE SHOULD
BE USED TO ACHIEVE THOSE GOALS.
AND FRIENDS SENATE FUNDING- I'M
A WALK I WANNA WALK THROUGH
SORT OF A- A FEW KEY QUESTIONS
THAT WE THINK THE LEGISLATURE.
BY ONE THAT- CONSIDER PRIOR TO
ADOPTING THE GOVERNOR'S
PROPOSAL RELATED TO INCENTIVE
FUNDING- ONE IS WHAT'S THE BEST
SOURCE OF FUNDS FOR INCENTIVE
PROGRAMS SO THE EIGHTY EIGHT
THESE ARE. A FEW DIFFERENT
VEHICLE RELATED FEES WHICH WE
THINK. ARE REASONABLE AND HAVE
A REASONABLE NEXUS TO BE. A
MISSION RUSSIAN ACTIVITIES THAT
WOULD BE FUNDED- BUT THE
LEGISLATURE COULD EXPLORE OTHER
OPTIONS- FOR EXAMPLE- COULD
EXPLORE MODIFYING THE LEVEL OF
THE CITY AND MAYBE. SUCH
HONESTY THAT'S- BASED ON A
POLLUTION FROM A VEHICLE RATHER
THAN JUST SORT OF FLAT. FEE PER
VEHICLE. GOOD CONSIDER TYING
THE LEVEL TO FEED TO INFLATION-
OREGON JUST CAN CONSIDER
ENTIRELY DIFFERENT MAKES OF
FUNDING I MENTIONED. SORT OF
THE WIDE VARIETY OF OTHER
FUNDING SOURCES WE HOW FOR BOTH
YOUR AND SENATE AND FOR FUNDING.
I CONSIDER A MAKES YEAR FOR
EXAMPLE. WE HAVE SOME. OF YOU
KNOW I- ABOUT HI ELECTRICITY IN
THIS IN SOME THE YOU CAN IN A
BAR. LOOK ABOUT SOME OF THE
LEGISLATURE COULD CONSIDER.
SORT OF A DIFFERENT MIX OF
FUNDING FOR- SEVEN FOR
STRUCTURE MAY BE SHIFTING SOME
OF THE COSTS AWAY FROM
ELECTRICITY RATEPAYERS TO. EASE
LIKE ADHD IS OR SOME OTHER TYPE
OF FUNDING SOURCE- THE SECOND
QUESTION WE THINK THAT'S
IMPORTANT FOR THE LEGISLATURE
BE THINKING ABOUT IS WHAT'S THE
NEXT WHAT MAKES THE PROGRAM
SHOULD BE FUNDED- IDEALLY- THE
CONVERSATIONS AROUND THIS WOULD
BE INFORMED BY- AN ANALYSIS OF
WHAT WE KNOW ABOUT. THE COST
EFFECTIVENESS OF THE DIFFERENT
PROGRAMS THAT WE HAVE ON THE
DISTRIBUTION OF THE BENEFITS OF
THOSE DIFFERENT PROGRAMS. ON
MANY OF THE ABA PROGRAMS THAT
WE HAVE NOW DO HAVE ESTIMATES
OF- COST PER TON OF EMISSIONS
REDUCTIONS AND SO THOSE ARE
AVAILABLE AND SO I THINK THAT'S
A- PORTENT STOP UNFORTUNATELY-
THE INFORMATION ISN'T KIND OF
GATHERED AND PRESENTED HASN'T
BEEN PRESENTED TO US IN A WAY
WHERE IT'S EASY TO KIND OF
COMPARE ACROSS ALL THE
DIFFERENT PROGRAMS AND SO.
THAT'S SOMETHING WE'RE GOING TO
CONTINUE TO WORK TO TRY TO
GATHER AND WORK WITH THE
ADMINISTRATION. HOPEFULLY HELP
PRESERVE IT WASN'TINFORMATION
THAT HELPS YOU KIND OF COMPARE
THE COST EFFECTIVENESS TODAY
ACROSS DIFFERENT PROGRAMS
MISTER AND MISS SOMETHING. YOU
BROWN'S ACT. CAN YOU JUST STOP
BY THERE AND WE JUST MAKE THAT
FORMAL REQUEST OF THE- BECAUSE
THIS IS NOT AN EASTER EGG HUNT
HERE IF WE'VE GOT. IF THEY KNOW
THE COST PER TON ON ALL THESE
ABA PROGRAMS AND THEY'RE
LOOKING TO USE THE FEES WHICH
EVERYBODY PAYS TO REGISTER. TO
DO- ZEV CONSTRUCTION IN THE
ALLEY- AND ALL THE MEMBERS OF
THE COMMITTEE AND THE
LEGISLATURE SHOULDN'T BE. YOU
KNOW SHOULD WE SHOULD GET A
PRESENTATION SO WE KNOW BECAUSE
WE'VE- I KNOW THAT THE L. A. O.
HAS INSTRUCTED THE LEGISLATURE
TO TRY TO GET THE BIGGEST BANG
FOR THE BUCK ON THE MONEY THAT
WE'RE SPENDING. SO IF WE
SECURITIZE. FUNDS AND WE-ALREADY HAVE FUNDS GOING FOR
PROGRAMS THAT REDUCE. CARBON
AND POLLUTION WHY WOULD WE WANT
TO DEFER TO A DIFFERENT AT
LEAST AT LEAST LET US KNOW THAT
WE'RE MINDFUL BUT- IF. I CAN
GET THE ENERGY DEPARTMENT AND
THE AIRPORT TO GIVE US THAT.
THAT THAT THAT WOULD BE GREAT
PLEASE PROCEED. OKAY YES WE
WERE HAPPY TO KIND OF SUPPORT-YOU IN YOUR STUFF AND THEN
TRYING TO GATHER THAT
INFORMATION. I'M WORKING WITH
THE ADMINISTRATION- ABSENT KIND
OF THAT NOT MORE CONCRETE
INFORMATION THERE ARE. A
VARIETY OF FACTORS TO KIND OF
THINK ABOUT CONSIDER. ONE KIND
OF HOW IT HOW TO ALLOCATE
FUNDING ACROSS PROGRAMS YOU
KNOW A COUPLE OF THEM FOR
EXAMPLE ARE KIND OF HOW TO
EMPHASIZE LIGHT DUTY VERSUS
HEAVY DUTY- THEY'RE KIND OF
DIFFERENT- PERCENTAGES. OF
OVERALL EMISSIONS AND
GREENHOUSE GASES VERSUS AIR
QUALITY THERE SORT OF A
DIFFERENCE BETWEEN LIKE GETTING
UPDATED VEHICLES- BALANCE IN
CERTAIN NEAR TERM- GOALS VERSUS
LONG TERM GOALS AND PART OF
THAT GETS INTO. UNLESS YOU WANT
TO FOCUS ON KIND OF LONG TERM
DEBT REDUCTION GOALS- AND THEN-
THE ONE THAT- THE OTHER SORT
OF. I THINK YOU CONSIDERATION
THAT HAS ALREADY BEEN TOUCHED
ON IS THIS ISSUE OF HOW MUCH TO
FOCUS ON. THAT INFRASTRUCTURE
VERSES VEHICLE INCENTIVES AND
YOU KNOW THE STATE HAS PROGRAMS
THAT FOCUS ON BOTH- THE- BUDGET
PROPOSAL THIS YEAR AS HAS BEEN
MENTIONED ALREADY DOESN'T
INCLUDE ANY NEW FUNDING FOR CVR
PIECE OTHERS- THERE'S MORE OF
AN EMPHASIS ON CONCEPT
INFRASTRUCTURE AT LEAST AS PART
OF THE BUDGET PROPOSAL THIS
YEAR. OUR VIEW IS IN GENERAL WE
THINK FOCUSING ON BOTH.
INFRASTRUCTURE AS WELL AS
VEHICLE INCENTIVES MAKES. SENSE
AND THERE'S WE THINK THERE'S
SOME RESEARCH TO SUPPORT KIND
OF- POLICIES FOCUSING ON BOTH.
OUT WE DO THINK IF FUNDS ARE
LIMITED THAT YOU KNOW THAT THEY
HAVE AVAILABLE EVIDENCE DOES
SUGGEST THAT IF YOU'RE GOING TO
PUSH HARD ON ONE THAT.
INFRASTRUCTURE MIGHT BE A
HIGHER RIORITY THAN VEHICLES
BUT- NO REASON YOU KNOW THAT.
THE RESURGENT SORT OF ENTIRELY
CONCLUSIVE IN THIS AREA AND I
THINK REASONABLE PEOPLE CAN
DISAGREE BUT WE DO THINK OF A
FOCUS ON INFRASTRUCTURE DOES
HAVE A LOT OF MERIT AND
SOPHIA'S. IN MINISTRATIONS SORT
OF- PROPOSAL FOCUS ON
INFRASTRUCTURE HAS. HAS SOME
MERIT. FINALLY. I'M ON THE
ACCELERATE PLEASE- THE SEVEN
FOR SURE FROM. REALLY SORT OF.
WE VIEW IT AS AN EX. OF FUNDING.
IT WOULD BE A IN FUTURE YEAR
AND SO- INSTEAD SORT OF- HAVE
ANNUAL FUND AVAIL FOR SO FOR
SURE. OVER THE COUPLE OF
DECADES. YOU KNOW A BOND WOULD
BE ISSUED UP TO A ONE BILLION
DOLLAR BONDS- TO ACCELERATE
THAT MONEY FORWARD AND HAVE
THAT AVAILABLE IN THE NEXT FEW
YEARS- AND AS A RESULT THE
STATE WOULD BE PAYING DEBT
SERVICE. OF UP TO. ABOUT SIXTY
SIX MILLION DOLLARS ANNUALLY
OVER THE NEXT COUPLE OF DECADES
AND SO. ARE WE ARE NOT NOT NOT
AS MUCH AS SORT OF AN INCREASE
AS AS MUCH AS THAT KIND OF
SHIFT- AN ACCELERATION OF THE
FUNDING FORWARD- WE AND WE
THINK THERE IS SOME MERIT- KIND
OF THAT. APPROACH THERE IS AN
IDENTIFIED. GAP IN FUNDING OVER
THE NEXT FEW YEARS I WOULD
THINK THE FUNDING SOURCE
REVENUE SOURCE OF RELATIVELY
STABLE SO IT'S A REASONABLE
SOURCE TO USE- TO ISSUE BONDS.
TRADE OFF WAITING FOR THE
LEGISLATURE IS JUST TO- ON
BALANCE THE ABOUT SHORT TERM
INCREASE IN FUNDING WEST OUT
LONG TERM DECREASE IN FUNDING
AS THE STATE HAS TO MAKE THOSE
DEBT SERVICE PAYMENTS. IN
FUTURE YEARS- AND YOU KNOW
WHETHER THE SORT OF SHORT TERM
MARKET DEVELOPMENT BENEFITS
OVER THE NEXT FEW YEARS OR WERE
SORT OF LESS FUNDING AVAILABLE
IN FUTURE YEARS AND SO THE
COMMITTEE WANT MY ONCE A-
EXPLORE OF THE ADMINISTRATION
DURING THE HEARING ABOUT WHAT
THEIR EXPECTATIONS ARE ABOUT
LONG TERM FUNDING NEEDS BECAUSE
UNDER THIS PROPOSAL- A LOT OF
THAT. A LARGE CHUNK OF THE
FUNDING ON ENERGY COMMISSION
COULD BE- NEEDED TO PAY DEBT
SERVICE PAYMENTS IN FUTURE
YEARS OF ONE BE AVAILABLE FOR
PROJECT. RIGHT NOW I WILL. TRY
TO IN MY- THERE I DO WANT TO WE
HAVE A OF OTHER RECOMMEND.
RELATED TO ASK THE LEGISLATURE
DOES WANT TO ADOPT THE
ADMINISTRATION'S SECURITIZATION
PROPOSAL FROM OPTIONS FOR.
REDUCING THE INITIAL BOND
AUTHORIZATION AND LIMITING THE
CONTINUOUS APPROPRIATIONS JUST
A HEALTH INSURER. BUT THERE IS
ONGOING LEGISLATIVE OVERSIGHT
AUTHORITY. OVER SOME OF THESE
FUNDS ARE HAPPY TO KIND OF
THOSE- THOSE KIND OF DETAILED.
BUT ALL MY COMMENTS THERE ARE
NONE TO ANSWER ANY. BUT COULD
YOU GIVE A LITTLE INSIGHT I.
I'VE THE COMMITTEE THREE OR
SEVEN IS RE. FOR AT ALL THE AND
MONEY HAS BEEN EXHAUSTED
ANNOUNCED CHARGING STATIONS
WHICH IS GOOD NEWS. BUT WE
STILL HAVE A SENSE OF. FUNDS
THAT ARE IN THE QUEUE FROM THE
VOLKSWAGEN SETTLEMENT FROM THE
BMW CHRYSLER SETTLEMENT WITH
THE AYE YOU'LL USE YOUR
BUILDING. AND WHAT THE PRIVATE
SECTOR IS DOING WHAT'S YOUR
SENSE OF. WHAT'S HAPPENING
RIGHT NOW ON THE NATURAL THAT
THAT IT'S GOING TO BE DONE- ON
THE CONSTRUCTION OF- OF FIVE
STEPS BECAUSE WE'VE GOT THIS.
LONG TERM SHORT TERM- A BED AND
SET THAT MONEY HAS. TO BE SPENT
RIGHT WE HAVE THE- BORDERS.
NEGOTIATED A GREAT DEAL WITH
SOFTWARE. YEAH THERE YOU'RE
RIGHT THAT THERE ARE NONE OF
ALL THESE OTHER SORT OF
ACTIVITIES THAT ARE GOING ON-
AS MISS MONAGHAN MET
COMMISSIONER MONAGHAN MENTIONED
I THINK THERE'S- THE KIND OF
PROPOSAL BEFORE YOU DOES KIND
OF INCORPORATE WHAT
EXPECTATIONS ARE ABOUT HOW
MANY- CHARGING STATIONS- AND
PORTS WILL BE SORT OF
CONSTRUCTED WITH THOSE FUNDS OR
THE FUNDING KIND OF UNDER THIS
PROPOSAL WOULD BE USED TO KIND
OF IDENTIFY THE GAPS. BETWEEN
WHAT WHAT WOULD BE PROVIDED
WITH THOSE FUNDS AND WHAT'S
NEEDED TO MEET THE GOALS OF THE
GOVERNOR IS LAID OUT IN TERMS
OF INFRASTRUCTURE I MEAN I
THINK I THERE ARE SORT OF VERY
IMPORTANT QUESTIONS ABOUT- IN
THE LONG TERM WHAT IS THE
STATE'S. ROLLING KIND OF HOW
MUCH STATE SUPPORT WILL BE
NEEDED FOR INFRASTRUCTURE I
THINK THERE IS KIND OF AN
EXPECTATION THAT AS THE MARKET
DEVELOPS THEN IT MIGHT BE LESS
OF A NEED FOR STATE SUPPORT AT
THE PRIVATE MARKET WILL TAKE
OVER A LARGE CHUNK OF IT- BUT I
THINK OF IT AS IT KIND OF COMES
TO THINKING ABOUT WHAT LONG
TERM FUNDING NEEDS MIGHT BE
THERE ARE STILL ARE SOME OTHER.
A BIG PIECES THAT IT'S STILL
UNCLEAR- EXACTLY HOW MUCH STATE
SUPPORT AND I THINK THERE'S A
PRETTY STRONG ARGUMENT TO SOME
STATE SUPPORT MIGHT BE NEEDED
FOR EXAMPLE FOR MULTI FAMILY-
HOUSING- YOU KNOW THAT THAT
KIND OF YOU KNOW PRIVATE
MARKETABILITY OF THE KIND OF
THE PRIVATE MARKET TO PROVIDE
THAT WE THINK THERE ARE SOME
KIND OF SIGNIFICANT QUESTIONS
AND SO THERE MIGHT BE A KIND OF
A CONTINUED STATE ROLE FOR
THAT. ARE HEAVY DUTY AND FOR
STRUCTURE IS KIND OF A GROWING
EASTON VERY EXPENSIVE I KNOW
THE ENERGY COMMISSION HAS SOME
SOME ESTIMATES ON KIND OF WHAT
THE NEEDS MIGHT BE THERE SO-
YEAH THAT THERE'S A LOT GOING
ON BUT I THINK THERE'S JUST
GIVEN SORT OF THE NATURE OF THE
LEAST SOME OF THE GOALS OF THE
GOVERNOR HAS ESTABLISHED
THERE'S- YOU KNOW A LOT MORE
AND IT NEEDS TO BE DONE OVER
THE NEXT FEW YEARS. YEAH IT
JUST WOULDN'T. I DON'T WANT TO
SOUND LIKE A- RECORD ABOUT TWO.
TO BEEF UP THE- AND TRADE
PROGRAMS THAT A PERFORMANCE
BETTER. AND CREATES MORE
REVENUE AND IF WE'RE TALKING.
YOU KNOW AT THE END GAME IS TWO
HUNDRED FIFTY MILLION DOLLARS
PER YEAR. THAT'S NOT THAT MUCH
BEEFING UP THAT THAT NEEDS TO
BE DONE. THAT THIS IS A TWO
THIRDS VOTE IT'S A IT'S A-
SIGNIFICANT CHANGE IN. HOW THE
FUNDING GOES FROM. THE PROGRAMS
FOR REGISTRATION FEE SO IT'S-
A- I THE HOPE THAT WE ALL LOOK
AT ALL THE TOOLS IN THE TOOLBOX
OF FEAR. IF WE'RE GOING TO TAKE
THIS- THIS STEP BECAUSE- YES.
IT IS IMPORTANT TO GET CHARGING
STATIONS AT. AT APARTMENT
COMPLEXES IT'S EQUALLY AS
IMPORTANT TO GET THOSE
APARTMENT APARTMENT COMPLEXES
ENERGY EFFICIENT BECAUSE THEY
MAY BE. ARE SPROUTING UP MORE
POLLUTION AND MORE GREENHOUSE
GASES THAN THE DELTA IS SO
THERE'S A LOT OF THINGS BE DONE
THIS IS JUST ONE OF THINGS
SENATOR STERN. YOUR QUESTION
YES THANKS MISCARRIAGE WANT TO
FOLLOW UP ON YOUR- INQUIRY AND
I GUESS CAN WE DRILL DOWN A
LITTLE FURTHER THAN. WHAT
WHAT'S THAT NEEDS ASSESSMENT
LOOK LIKE RIGHT NOW FROM THE
ADMINISTRATION'S PERSPECTIVE.
ON THE SORT OF. TO REACH THE
GOALS THE GOVERNOR'S LAID OUT.
WHAT WHAT'S THE SORT OF ALL IN
NEED FOR INFRASTRUCTURE AND HOW
FAR WILL THIS PROPOSAL GET US
THERE. THANK YOU FOR THE
QUESTION- STERN. SO OUR
ANALYSIS- SPUR OF THE CHAPTER
BOARD THAT FOR AB TWENTY ONE
TWENTY SEVEN WHICH REQUIRES US
ON A BIANNUAL BASIS TO LOOK AT-
THAT WHETHER WE'RE MEETING OUR
GOALS FOR INFRASTRUCTURE AND
WHAT WHAT WE FOUND IS THAT FOR
TWENTY TWENTY FIVE WE ARE SIXTY
THOUSAND CHARGERS SHORT OF OUR
GOAL AND WE'RE TWENTY ONE
HYDROGEN STATIONS SHORT OF OUR
GOAL OF- TWO HUNDRED STATIONS.
SO THERE IS A GAP AND THAT
ANNOUNCER STRUCTURE ACCOUNT.
ALL THE INFORMATION THAT WE
COULD COLLECT IN TERMS OF-
INVESTMENTS BY UTILITIES AND BY
ELECTRIFY AMERICA OTHER
SETTLEMENT AGREEMENTS- AND WE
STILL HAVE THAT DELTA. SO WHAT
WE WOULD USE OUR- BONTA SPORTY
DO THE FIRST FIVE HUNDRED
BILLION IS TO FILL THAT GAP WE
WANT TO MAKE SURE THAT
CALIFORNIA IS ON TRACK TO MEET
OUR SHORT TERM TWENTY TWENTY
FIVE GOAL WITH THE RIGHT AMOUNT
OF THAT INFRASTRUCTURE. AND OUR
OUR ASSESSMENT IS THAT I MEAN
AT THIS POINT INFRASTRUCTURE IS.
ARGUABLY THE BIGGEST BARRIER I
MEAN I THINK THAT- RIGHT THE
BATTERIES IN PARTICULAR HAS
FALLEN BY 90% OVER THE LAST
DECADE. MANY ARTICLES ARE ON
TRACK TO BE CHEAPER ON A COST
BASIS AND THEIR INTERNAL
COMBUSTION COUNTERPARTS OVER
THE NEXT TWO TO FIVE YEARS. AND
SO NOW- THE BARRIER IS WILL I
LIVE IN APARTMENT BUILDING I
DON'T HAVE A PLACE TO CHARGE MY
VEHICLE I'M NOT GOING TO GET AS
THEIR MISSION YES- I WOULD
ARGUE- AND WE WANT TO MAKE SURE
THAT. NO MATTER WHERE YOU LIVE
YOU CAN HAVE ACCESS TO THEIR
MACHINE VEHICLE. AND PART OF
THE INCENTIVE FOR THIS HONESTLY
IS THAT THESE VEHICLES ON A
LIFE CYCLE BASIS FOR CHEAPER
SO. CONSUMER EPORTS FOUND THAT
THESE VEHICLES ARE SAFE
CONSUMERS- ELEVEN HUNDRED TO
SEVENTEEN HUNDRED DOLLARS PER
YEAR ON REDUCE YOUR MAINTENANCE.
COSTS SO WE WANT TO MAKE SURE
THAT. EVERYBODY CAN BENEFIT
FROM THAT JUST PEOPLE WHO LIVE
IN SINGLE FAMILY HOME BUT
EVERYTHING. IN IN SEARCH JUST
FOLLOWING UP ON THAT POINT I
MEAN WE TALKED ABOUT THE
CLIMATE CATALYST. A LITTLE
EARLIER AND SORT OF LEVERAGING
IN FINANCE SO IF YOU WENT WITH
THE STREET SORT OF CASH
APPROACH. VERSES THIS.
FINANCING APPROACHES BEEN POSED
HERE HOW HOW LIKE HOW MUCH
FURTHER CAN WE GET THROUGH
LEVERAGE LIKE DO YOU ANTICIPATE
FOLLOW ON PRIVATE CAPITAL SAID
THAT THIS IS AN ENTIRELY.
PUBLICLY FINANCED HERE. YES OUR
VISION IS THAT OVER TIME WE
WILL REDUCE THE LEVEL OF PUBLIC
FUNDING PER CHARGER HARPER
HYDROGEN STATION AND WE'VE SEEN
THAT ACTUALLY PLAY OUT. ON IT
WELL YOU KNOW OUR OUR GOAL IS
LIKE LET'S MAKE SURE THAT WE
CAN MEET OUR TWENTY TWENTY FIVE
GOLD LOOKS SET A COURSE FOR
TWENTY. THIRTY AND- LET'S
WITHDRAW THE AMOUNT OF PUBLIC
INVESTMENT. RATCHETED DOWN OVER
TIME SO WITH THE STEADY
DECREASE AND THE MARKET SEES
THAT BOTH THE CALIFORNIA IS
INVESTING AND THAT WE ARE WE
ARE EXPECTING THE PRIVATE
MARKET TO TAKE OVER I MEAN THIS
IS NOT IN PERPETUITY THIS IS A
SHORT TERM INFUSION OF CASH
MAKE SURE THAT WE ARE ON COURSE
TO MEET OUR GOALS. AND TO AND%
TO GET MORE PRIVATE CAPITAL
FLOWING INTO THE STATE OF
CALIFORNIA. THE LAST QUESTION
THANKS FOR THE TIME MISTER
CHAIR- SO. JUSTICE CENTER
DOLLIES POINT EARLIER WHEN
WE'RE TALKING ABOUT CLIMATE
CATALYST UNCERTAINTIES POLICY
EXTERNALITIES THAT MAY LIMIT
YOU KNOW YOU GOT MONEY BUT
THERE'S OTHER BARRIERS IN THE
WAY TOO AND I YOU TALKED ABOUT
YOUR YOUR PLANNING PROCESS AND
SOME OF THE GOALS YOU'VE SET
OUT ON SAY SIXTY THOUSAND A
YEAR OR TRYING TO HIT THAT TWO
HUNDRED HYDROGEN A YEAR- I
DON'T KNOW. IF IT'S IT C. E. C.
OR IF IT'S IF THIS IS MORE OF
LIKE A GO BUSINESS QUESTION.
BUT THE CENTRAL PLANNING
FUNCTION AND SORT OF
STREAMLINING THE
INFRASTRUCTURE. IT SEEMS LIKE.
AN ISSUE RIGHT NOW LIKE ACTUAL
THE ACTUAL CONSTRUCTION
TIMELINE FOR GETTING. THESE
DIFFERENT STATIONS ARE CHARGING
OPERATIONS BUILT. HITS ALL
KINDS OF IMPEDIMENTS NOT
UNIFORM. LOCAL MUNICIPAL CODES-
YOU KNOW DIFFERENT INFORMATION
ABOUT WHAT FIRE MARSHAL NEEDS
ARE- UNDERGROUNDING ISSUES SO
IS THERE IS THERE SORT OF.
COROLLARY EFFORT THAT MATCHES
WITH THIS FINANCING PROPOSAL TO
LOOK AT WHAT THE POLICY
BARRIERS ARE AND TRY TO HAVE
SOME LEADERSHIP AT THE
GOVERNOR'S LEVEL TO LIKE. TO
REALLY DRIVE THIS FORWARD. I'M
NOT SURE IF THEY CAN I CAN
SPEAK ON BEHALF OF COPAYS YEAH
AT LEAST IT ASSEMBLY NOT OKAY
SO GOOD OKAY. YEAH DEVELOP AND
THAT STRATEGY THEY HAVE
DEVELOPED A STRATEGY- IN
CONSULTATION WITH STAKEHOLDERS.
AND WITH AGENCIES. THERE ARE
BARRIERS YOU POINT OUT AT THE
LOCAL LEVEL THERE'S JUST.
STREAMLINING THAT NEEDS TO
HAPPEN SO THAT THAT THE-
PROJECT CAN HAPPEN MORE
QUICKLY. AND TO GO BEEN HAS A
PERMANENT OLYMPICS WHERE
THEY'RE REALLY TRYING TO CREATE
YOU KNOW IT IT JUST SPREAD THE
KNOWLEDGE TO LOCAL GOVERNMENTS
THAT THIS ISN'T A PAIR THAT
NEED TO BE OVERCOME. AND YOU
KNOW THIS. CHANGE THAT WE ARE-
WE'RE SPEAKING IT'S GOING TO
TAKE ACTION AT THE LOCAL LEVEL.
AT THE STATE LEVEL AT THE
FEDERAL LEVEL. AND THERE ARE
BARRIERS ALONG THE WAY IT
MIGHT. MY SENSE IS THAT THESE
BARRIERS ARE ALL SURMOUNTABLE-
IT'S JUST A MATTER OF. WORKING
TOGETHER AND SO GOBIZ IS REALLY
THE POINT FOR THAT. THAT
STRATEGY ON THE INFRASTRUCTURE
SIDE THE CDC IS REALLY THE
POINT FOR THAT AND THAT'S
BECAUSE THE LEGISLATURE YOU
HAVE GIVEN US THAT AUTHORITY.
BUT I WANT TO SAY THE RECORDS
THAT WE HAVE TO DO THAT AB
TWENTY ONE TWENTY SEVEN ON
WHETHER WE'RE ATTRACTED MEET
OUR GOALS FOR INFRASTRUCTURE.
AND THAT THE ALBUM REPORT THAT
REQUIRES US TO LOOK AT EQUITY
IMPLICATIONS OF OUR CHARTER
DISTRIBUTION. THE OTHER
CRITICAL ANALYSIS THAT WE ARE
USING TO INFORM AND TAYLOR ARE
INVESTMENTS. AND I MEAN I THINK
IT IN TERMS OF HOLDING US
ACCOUNTABLE YOU HAVE GIVEN US
TOOLS. TO TO HOLD OUR
INVESTMENT ACCOUNTABLE TO
WHETHER WE ARE MEETING OUR
GOALS AND WHETHER WE'RE GETTING.
JUST AND EQUITABLE WAY. IT'S
ZERO POINT YOU'RE NOT ON TRACK
TO MEET THOSE GOALS THAT WE'VE
ASKED YOU TO MEET. AND THIS IS
THE STOP GAP. THE FIRST FIVE
HUNDRED BILLION DOLLARS WOULD
BE USED TO MAKE SURE THAT WE
NEED OUR TWENTY TWENTY FIVE
GOALS. AND THE SECOND FIVE
HUNDRED MILLION WILL BE SENT TO
SET US ON COURSE FOR TWENTY
THIRTY. BUT I EXPECT HIM INSIDE
ENOUGH THAT OUR GOAL IS YOU
KNOW HOW EVENTUALLY WANT TO GET
RID OF THE PUBLIC WE DON'T WANT
PUBLIC DOLLARS GOING TO THE-
MARKET TO TAKE OVER. AND BUT
THE MARKET ISN'T. DRIVING IT
BECAUSE THERE JUST AREN'T
ENOUGH ELECTRIC VEHICLES OUT
THERE. THE WINNER IS- ANOTHER
SELECTIVE VEHICLE YOU KNOW
ENOUGH ABOUT STOCKTON ELECTRIC
VEHICLE. CHARGING PROVIDERS
WILL MAKE MONEY AND WE DON'T
WANT TO KEEP FUNDING THEM.
THERE MAY ALWAYS BE A ROLE I
THINK FOR SOME PUBLIC
INVESTMENTS TO MAKE SURE THAT
OUR- ACCESS TO AFFORDABLE SO
PUBLIC ENEMY DRAWINGS AND LOW
INCOME DISADVANTAGED
COMMUNITIES NORTHERN
COMMUNITIES FOR ALL COMMUNITIES
LIKE THERE'S- THERE ARE PLACES
WHERE. WE MAY NEED TO INVEST
FOR A LONGER PERIOD. SO THE
FOLLOW UP ON THAT IS IT THE
SHOULD. COMMITTEE OTHER. THAT
BUILT THE OLD CLICHE WE'RE
GOING TO AT THE LOW HANGING.
THAT'S OUT THERE SO IF YOU GO
TO CITY. PICKLE RIVERA AND THEY
SAY WE GOT. ONE TWO THREE FOUR
FIVE NINETY NINE NINETY EIGHT
LOCAL CONDITIONS THAT YOU HAVE
TO MEET. YOU SAY SIERRA AND YOU
GO DOWN TO THE NEXT TOWN AND
THEY SAY WE DON'T HAVE ANY
CONDITIONS WE WANT TO WORK
WITH. WITH THE CDC AND GULBIS
TO PUT THIS IN. IF THE GOAL IS
TO TWENTY TWENTY FIVE THAT
WE'RE GOING TO GO TO THE LOO.
THE AREAS THAT ARE. MAKE IT.
INVITING FOR CHARGING STATIONS
AND HYDROGEN STATIONS GO WIN
INSTEAD OF SAYING OH NO WE
WANTED IN. CENTER WILL CAL SKIS
DISTRICT AND WILL SPEND TWELVE
YEARS GOING THROUGH. PERMITTING
AND PLANNING WITH THAT WITH THE
CITY THAT. THAT IS.
UNBELIEVABLE AND WE ARE WE ALL
KNOW. WE ARE CERTAIN LOCAL
GOVERNMENTS SO WE- HAVE AN IDEA
CENTER DOLLY. I REALLY DON'T
HAVE A QUESTION I JUST MORE OF
A COMET- MAYBE FOR THE
LEGISLATORS IN JUST MY OWN
PERSONAL. FEEL GOOD TO SAY YOU
KNOW THE DEFINITION OF INSANITY
IS DOING THE SAME THING. ANNEX
IS NOT CHANGING AND GETTING THE
SAME OUTCOME- BECAUSE WHAT'S
YOUR NUMBER NUMBER ONE THAT
THIS IS ALLOWING THE C. C. TO
SPEND A HUNDRED MILLION DOLLARS
WITHOUT ANY LEGISLATIVE
OVERSIGHT THE FUTURE THE
SENATOR JUST. THE REASON WHY
COUNTY JUST MENTION SOME OF HIS
FRUSTRATIONS WITH. THE PROGRAMS
AND HOW THEY'RE IMPLEMENTED SO
I THINK THAT'S SOMETHING THAT
WE DEFINITELY SHOULD TAKE A
LOOK AT THAT GIVES US SOME
ABILITY TO COME BACK AND
SCRUTINIZED. HOW THIS MONEY IS
BEING SENT SPENT NUMBER ONE.
NUMBER TWO. WE'D WE- AGAIN A IN
THE IN SOME OF THE COMMENTS WAS
TALKED ABOUT. NO 80% AN AUCTION
95% OF. DIESEL PARTICULATES
COME. BUT WE DON'T EVEN COUNT
AND I'M GO BACK TO THIS I'M
GONNA KEEP AFTER IT UNTIL MAYBE
SUNDAY IT ACTUALLY GETS
QUALIFIED AND I HAVE A
LEGISLATION TO DO THAT THIS
YEAR. WE DON'T COUNT ALL THE
EMISSIONS IN CALIFORNIA. YOU
TALK ABOUT AIR QUALITY WE BURN
FOUR POINT TWO MILLION ACRES
LAST YEAR AND MILLIONS OF ACRES
IN THE YEARS BEFORE. AND WE
DON'T COUNT THOSE IN OUR CARBON
EMISSIONS. SO WHEN I TALK ABOUT
BEING INSANE I KEEP TALKING
ABOUT DO WE HAVE IF WE REALLY
CARE ABOUT THE ENVIRONMENT AND
WE REALLY CARE ABOUT OUR CARBON
OUTPUT. THEN WE WOULD COUNT ALL
THE CARBON THAT WE PUT OUT. AND
YOU KNOW THE FOREST HAS BEEN
MANIPULATED BY US. THE NATIVE
AMERICANS AND GOD ALMIGHTY WITH
LIGHTNING MANAGED ARE FORCED
BEFORE WE CAME ALONG AND MESSED
IT UP. WE SUPPRESS FIRE FOR THE
LAST ALMOST HUNDRED YEARS. AND
WE HAVE A FORCED IT'S OVER WELL
AND WITH FUEL AND IT'S
CATASTROPHICALLY BERNIE ON TOP
OF. OUR CLIMB IS CHANGING WE
HAVE LATER SNOW MORE RAIN AND
WIND AND DRYER SEASON SO I JUST
WANT TO MAKE IT CLEAR THAT.
INTEL WE REALLY TALK ABOUT THE
ENVIRONMENT IN ITS TOTALITY. IN
ANY AND WHEN WE DO WE GO ON
HERE WE'RE GONNA TAX THE TWENTY
THREE YEAR IS EXTENDING A FEE
IN TAX TWENTY THREE YEARS.
WE'RE GONNA FRONT LOAD IT TO
PAY OFF WHAT THE GOAL WAS HALF
A BILLION TO PAY THE GOAL. FOR
TWENTY TWENTY FIVE WHICH WE'VE
ALREADY SET AND NOW UNDER.
RIGHT BECAUSE HE SAID NOBODY
TALKS TO US YOUR BE A
REPUBLICAN AROUND HERE. I MEAN
TALK ABOUT NOBODY TALKING TO
YOU. IS THIS IS THIS IS MY
OPPORTUNITY TO TALK ABOUT THE
THINGS I CARE ABOUT THAT I
THINK WE SHOULD ALL CARE ABOUT.
BECAUSE IN THE POLICY
DISCUSSIONS WE DON'T WE GET
LEFT BEHIND AND- THEN IT SEEMS
LIKE WE'RE GONNA FOCUS ON. YOU
KNOW MORE LIKE TWO CARS WE HAVE
AN EXECUTIVE ORDER TO GET YOU
CAN PUT EVERY YOU CAN MAKE
EVERY SINGLE. VEHICLE IN
CALIFORNIA ELECTRIC AND WE CAN
STILL HAVE A CARBON OUTPUT
PROBLEM. BECAUSE WE'RE NOT
COUNTING EVERYTHING SO I JUST
WANNA MAKE THAT VERY CLEAR I
KNOW YOU ALL KNOW WHAT YOU GUYS
HAVE HEARD IT. THE LAST TIME
I'VE BEEN HERE. BUT ON THIS DAY
AFTER DAY UNTIL WE ACTUALLY
QUANTIFY IT AND WE DO IT RIGHT
BECAUSE I DO TRULY CARE. ABOUT
THE ENVIRONMENT. AND IT'S JUST
FRUSTRATING TWO OTHER THINGS I
WANT TO MENTION. NUMBER ONE WE
HAVE NO RECYCLING PLANT FOR ALL
THESE EV'S. N. N. N. SOLAR
PANELS THAT WHEN THERE'S LIFE
IS SPENT WHAT WE GONNA DO WITH
THEM AND THAT AND THAT AND I
RAN A BILL TWO YEARS AGO. THAT
THAT FORCED THE- ADMINISTRATOR
NOT TO MENTION THE DEPARTMENT.
TO COME UP WITH A PLAN FOR
RECYCLING BATTERIES WE DON'T WE
DON'T EVEN KNOW THE HAZARDOUS.
IF ONE OF THESE GOES INTO IT
GETS IN AN ACCIDENT AND GOES
INTO RIVER WHAT THE TOXICITY OF
IT IS THAT OUTPUTS RIGHT THEN
SO I THINK WE NEED TO FOCUS ON.
YOUR BATTERIES RECYCLING AND
WHAT THE ENVIRONMENTAL IMPACT.
THAT IS BECAUSE OF THOSE AND
THE OTHER THING I THINK WE
SHOULD FOCUS ON. TO IS THE
RECYCLING OF SOLAR PANELS
THERE'S A LOT OF THE SOLAR
PANELS OUT THERE THAT THEIR
LIFESPAN IS COMING UP AND
THERE'S BEEN NO BONDS. NO NO WE
HAVE NO WAY TO GO OUT AND-
QUANTIFY HOW WE'RE GOING TO
THEM THIS IS THIS ISN'T. GOING
TO BE JUST LIKE. MINES WE HAVE
I HAD TO HAVE A SUIT ACIDIC
MINE AN INCH SHASTA COUNTY
THERE'S BEEN PUTTING SULFIDES
INTO. THE RIVER FOR YEARS AND
IT'S A SUPERFUND SITE. WE'RE
GONNA SEE THE SAME THING WITH
SOLAR PANELS RECEIVE THESE
THESE COMPANIES OR AWAY.
BECAUSE THEY TAX CUT. AND
THEY'RE GONNA E THEY'RE GONNA
BE SITTING OUT THERE WE HAVE TO
DO SOME OF THE I JUST WANT TO
MAKE IT. KNOWN TO THE PUBLIC.
AND FOR THE RECORD THESE ARE
THINGS. THAT WE SHOULD BE
TALKING ABOUT AND WE DON'T TALK
ABOUT WE GET FOCUSED ON.
TRANSPORTATION ONLY WHEN
THERE'S OTHER THINGS OUT THAT
ARE CAUSING. CARBON OUTPUTS
THANK YOU MISTER CHAIR FOR
INDULGING ME. WORK TO BE DONE
AND WE'RE GOING TO HOLD ISSUE
NUMBER TWO. OKAY OKAY I'M GONNA
HOLD ISSUE NUMBER TWO AND GO ON
THE ISSUE NUMBER THREE WHICH IS
IMPLEMENTATION OF AV AT EIGHT
FOUR ONE I KNOW- DIRECTOR BILL
HAND YOU'RE ON THE LINE WHEN
YOU WITH YOUR PRESENTATION CAN
YOU HAVE BEEN A WE'VE HEARD
THAT THE PRICE IS A
CERTIFICATION ON THIS E. V. E.
I. T. P. PROGRAM IS GONE FROM
LIKE SEVENTY FIVE BUCKS A TWO
HUNDRED SEVENTY FIVE DOLLARS ON
HOW CAN WE ENSURE THAT THAT.
REMAINS ECONOMICAL FOR PEOPLE
IT HAD BEEN ALTERED SMALL
BUSINESSES IN THESE CONTRACTORS
HAVE TO PAY FOR THE
CERTIFICATION AND ALSO IS THERE
ENOUGH TRAINING CAPACITY TO
MEET THESE AMBITIOUS EVEY
CHARGES THANKS SO. WITH THAT
YOU RECOGNIZE. THANK YOU CHAIR
AND- MEMBERS APPRECIATE THE
OPPORTUNITY TO SPEAK TO YOU
THIS MORNING AGAIN GROUP- AND-
EXECUTIVE DIRECTOR OF THE
CALIFORNIA ENERGY COMMISSION
AND WE'RE EXCITED TO BE THE
IMPLEMENTOR OF THE SCHOOL
ENERGY EFFICIENCY STIMULUS
PROGRAM. WHICH WAS ESTABLISHED
BY AB EIGHT FORTY ONE WHAT WHY
DON'T I CHAIR TAKE YOUR YOUR
FIRST QUESTION BEFORE
PROCEEDING WITH THE DISCUSSION.
OF THIS ITEM AND ONE OF THE
THINGS WE'RE SEEKING FROM THE
LEGISLATURE IN THIS REQUEST IS
FUNDING FOUR POINT SIX OF A P.
Y. SO A FRACTION OF AN
INDIVIDUAL STAFF PERSON. TO
LOOK AT THE VERY QUESTION
YOU'RE ASKING ABOUT THIS
PROGRAM THE EVE V. I. T. T.
PROGRAM THAT PROVIDES TRAINING
FOR THE USE BOB- FOR THAT THE
INFRASTRUCTURE THAT WERE YOU
DISPATCH SOMETIME TALKING
ABOUT- BEFORE THIS ITEM SO WHAT
WE'RE LOOKING AT THAT- I CAN
GET BACK TO YOU WITH SPECIFICS
ON WHAT THE COSTS ARE LOOKING
LIKE THAT THIRTY TO SEVENTY
FIVE DOLLARS IS A FIGURE THAT
HAD BEEN USED- THERE WAS
DISCUSSION ABOUT MAKING SURE WE
HAD TRAINING AVAILABLE ONLINE I
BELIEVE IT IS NOW- BUT THIS IS
SOMETHING WE'RE GONNA BE TAKING
A LOOK AT OVER TIME. AND I
WANNA MAKE SURE I GET YOU THE
MOST UP TO DATE INFORMATION
BECAUSE IT IT IT IS A LITTLE
BIT DYNAMIC RIGHT NOW I
APPRECIATE EXACTLY STAFF REPORT
TALK ABOUT WHETHER THE STAFF
REPORT AT LEAST WHAT WE'VE GOT
HAVE IN FRONT OF US IS THAT
THIS POSITION ARE SIX TENTHS OF
A POSITION IS GONNA LOOK AT
SUPPLEMENTS THE PROGRAM VERSES.
ANALYSIS SERVER AND
UNDERSTANDING OF THE PEOPLE FOR
TO DO THAT AND IS THERE ENOUGH
CAPACITY IN A GIVEN GIVEN
WHAT'S IN FRONT OF US ON THE ON
THE PREVIOUS ITEM THANKS THAT'S
RIGHT YES WE WILL WE THAT
YOU'RE RIGHT THE FUNDING IS FOR
AN ONGOING- UP SUPPORT TO LOOK
AT THESE ISSUES BUT WE- NEED
IMMEDIATE ANSWERS TO OTHER
QUESTIONS YOU'RE RAISING SO
WE'RE WHAT WE'LL GET BACK TO
YOU AS TO WHERE THE PROGRAM
STANDS RIGHT THIS MINUTE AND-
WE HAVE A WORKSHOP COMING UP TO
EXPLORE THESE ISSUES AND. TO
TAKE A STEP BACK THE BILL
CREATES- TO YOU PROGRAMS A
FORTY ONE THAT THE PART WE'RE
TALKING ABOUT- ELECTRIC
INFRASTRUCTURE IS A IS A
SEPARATE PEACE BUT THE PRIMARY-
FUNCTION OF THE BILL AND WHAT
WE'RE ASKING THE LEGISLATURE TO
SUPPORT IS- FOCUSED ON. SCHOOLS
LOCATED IN OUR UNDERSERVED
COMMUNITIES AND THE BILL
CREATES TWO PROGRAMS ONE IS
FOCUSED ON CLASSROOM
VENTILATION AND THE OTHER IS
FOCUSED ON INEFFICIENT PLUMBING
FIXTURES THE BILL IS INTENDED
TO AND I'M GONNA QUOTE FROM THE
TEXT BRIEFLY IT'S DESIGNED TO
SAVE ENERGY. A JOBS A TIME OF
ECONOMIC CRISIS AND PROVIDE
DIRECT SUPPORT TO SCHOOLS AND
SCHOOL CHILDREN IN UNDERSERVED
COMMUNITIES AND QUOTE. THAT'S A
PRETTY TALL ORDER BUT WE'RE
CONFIDENT WE CAN DELIVER ON
THOSE PROMISES AS OF TODAY TO
BRING UP TO SPEED WITH WHERE WE
ARE THAT THE CDC IS CONCEIVED
DRAFTED AND PUBLISHED PROGRAM
GUIDELINES WHICH ARE. ESSENTIAL
TO RUN THE PROGRAM WE HELD A
PUBLIC WORKSHOP AND HAVE
RECEIVED NUMEROUS PUBLIC
COMMENTS FROM A WIDE VARIETY OF
STAKEHOLDERS. BASED ON THOSE
COMMENTS WERE PLANNING TO-
PUBLISHED UPDATED GUIDELINES
AND THEN STAFF PLANS TO PRESENT
THESE GUIDELINES TO THE ENERGY
COMMISSION MAY. FOR FOR
PROPOSED OPTION AND AT THAT
POINT WE'LL BE ABLE TO START
FUNDING- ROGER. SAID HE
AUTHORIZED UP TO FIVE MILLION
DOLLAR PER FROM. THIS MORNING
WE'RE SEEKING ARE ONLY THREE
POINT SIX FIVE MILLION TO
SUPPORT TWENTY THREE STAFF.
ALSO INCLUDES TOWARD THOUSAND
DOLLARS FOR TECHNICAL SUPPORT.
AND SHARE TO YOUR POINT- NINETY
THOUSAND DOLLARS FROM A
DIFFERENT FINANCIAL BERKELEY
TRANSPORTATION FUND. FOR THIS
POINT SIX P. Y. FOR THE FOR THE
SEPT PORTION. THANK YOU. L. L.
L. YOUR COMMENT. YEAH THANK YOU
MISTER CHAIR SO WE DON'T HAVE
ANY CONCERNS WITH THE REQUEST
FOR ADDITIONAL STAFFING
RESOURCES TO IMPLEMENT THE BILL
I THINK OUR- THE ONLY ISSUE WE
DID ONE FY I GUESS THAT THERE'S
A COMPANY IN TRAILER BILL
LEGISLATION PROPOSED TRAILER
BILL LEGISLATION THAT WOULD
CONTINUOUSLY APPROPRIATE THE
FUNDING. FOR THIS PROGRAM- ANDS
AND ARGUED THERE NEEDS TO BE AS
YOU KNOW I THINK SORT NEEDS TO
BE A STRONG RATIONALE FOR
PROVIDING CONTINUOUS
APPROPRIATION AUTHORITY AS IT
WOULD REDUCE OF LEGISLATIVE
OVERSIGHT OF THE OF THE FUNDS
AND SO AT THIS TIME IT'S NOT
CLEAR THAT THE- A CONTINUOUS
APPROPRIATION AUTHORITY IS
NEEDED TO SUCCESSFULLY
IMPLEMENT THE PROGRAMS WITHIN
THE LEGISLATURE MIGHT WANT TO
CONSIDER. INSTEAD ALLOCATING
THE FUNDING FOR THE ANNUAL
BUDGET PROCESS. SENOL CENTER
DOLLY. SO WITH THE THIS I'M
TRYING TO UNDERSTAND- THE
BENEFIT TO THE RATEPAYERS WILL
BE FUNDING THE SCHOOL ENERGY
EFFICIENCY STEMLESS PROGRAMS.
ALL THE SCHOOLS ALL OVER FOR
THE SPAWNING AND HOW TO THE
RATEPAYERS BENEFIT. IT'S A GOOD
QUESTION SENATOR- YES IT IS
RATEPAYER FUNDING AND THEY THEY
DO BENEFIT AND THEY BENEFIT. BY
VIRTUE OF. LUCK LIKE HER
SOLUTION SHE PROGRAMS AS WE
MAKE OUR SYSTEMS MORE EFFICIENT
IN THIS CASE- BUILDINGS IN THIS
CASE OUR SCHOOLS. MORE SESSIONS
AND- UTILIZING LESS ELECTRICITY
THAT- PRODUCTION BENEFIT OF ALL
THE GREAT PLAYERS WHO WOULD BE
CONTRIBUTED TO THESE PROGRAMS.
THE BILL OF THE FUNDS WILL BE
DISPERSED IN THE APPROPRIATE-
JURISDICTIONS SO ANOTHER WORDS-
PACIFIC GAS AND ELECTRIC
RATEPAYERS WILL PAY INTO A FUND
THAT WILL SUPPORT SCHOOLS
LOCATED IN PGNIG SERVICE
TERRITORY. SIMILAR WITH THE
OTHER. PLAYERS THAT ARE
CONTRIBUTING TO IT AND IN TERMS
OF ELIGIBILITY OF SCHOOLS THE
LEGISLATION DIRECTS US TO FOCUS
ON LOW INCOME SCHOOLS OUT FIRST
AND THAT'S THAT'S WHAT WE
INTEND TO DO. NOT JUST A QUICK
FOLLOW UP SO IF YOUR BUSINESS
IS ONLY A CHARGING I'LL USE SO
IF YOU'RE OUTSIDE OF THE I. O.
U.'S TERRITORY. ARE YOU IS YOUR
SCHOOL STILL AVAILABLE.
AVAILABLE FOR THESE BONDS. THE
ONLY ELIGIBLE SCHOOLS ARE THE
ONES LOCATED WITHIN THE SERVICE
TERRITORIES THAT ARE PLENTIFUL.
OKAY THANK. FORGET ALL RIGHT
SEEING NO OTHER HANDS WE'RE
GOING TO HOLD THIS MATTER AND
MOVE ON TO CONTINUE EITHER
SCHOOL BUS THING ISSUE NUMBER
FOUR WHICH IS- SB ONE TEN IS A
TWO YEAR. THREE QUARTERS OF
MILLION DOLLAR I REQUEST AND
LET'S SEE WHO WE HAVE. MISCIBLE
HOT YOU'RE UP AGAIN. EIGHT
THANK YOU THANK YOU GET YOUR
MEMBERS RIGHT SB ONE TEN
DIRECTED SEVENTY FIVE MILLION
DOLLARS TO- GO TO ELECTRIC
SCHOOL BUSES THESE WERE FUNDS
THAT WERE LEFT OVER FROM THE
PROP THIRTY NINE PROGRAM. AND
THIS PROGRAM HAS BEEN A GREAT
SUCCESS DESPITE THE MANY
CHALLENGES OUR SCHOOLS FACED
LAST YEAR. YOUR REALLY QUICK
BACKGROUND WE ISSUED A
SOLICITATION IN MAY OF TWENTY
EIGHTEEN TO ALL SCHOOLS WHO
MIGHT BE INTERESTED IN
PARTICIPATING AND MANY DID. WE
RECEIVE APPLICATIONS FROM TWO
HUNDRED SCHOOLS FOR OVER
FIFTEEN HUNDRED PLUS. THE
FUNDING ALLOCATED PERMITTED US
TO AWARD A TOTAL OF TWO HUNDRED
THIRTY FIVE BUSES. AS OF
DECEMBER THIRTY FIRST OF LAST
YEAR SIXTY ONE OF THOSE BOXES
HAVE BEEN DELIVERED TO SCHOOLS-
SO WE FEEL GOOD ABOUT THAT OUR
GRANTS ALSO PROVIDED SIXTY
THOUSAND DOLLARS PER BOX FOR
CHARGING INFRASTRUCTURE.
FINALLY WE AWARDED SIX POINT
ONE MILLION DOLLARS FROM A
DIFFERENT FRONT FUNDER CLEAN
TRANSPORTATION FUNDS. FOR
TWENTY FIVE COMPRESSED GAS
BUSES TO EIGHT SCHOOL
DISTRICTS. WERE PLEASED TO SAY
THAT 90% OF THE AWARDEES SERVE
ROUTES TO GO THROUGH
DISADVANTAGED COMMUNITIES- THE
ORIGINAL TWENTY EIGHTEEN BUDGET
ACT FUNDING WAS THROUGH THIS
FISCAL YEAR AND WE COME TO YOU
THIS MORNING SEEKING THE FUNDS
YOU MENTIONED SHARE. TO SUPPORT
FIVE STAFF FOR TWO YEARS TO
ASSIST SCHOOL DISTRICTS IN
SELECTING BOSSES PREPARING THE
INFRASTRUCTURE- ETCETERA DO
DEPENDING ON THE SCHOOL THEY
HAVE DIFFERENT LEVELS OF
SOPHISTICATION WITH- WITH. THE
BILL MANY SORTS OF CHANGES.
THANK YOU. SOURCE STAFF REPORT
TALKS ABOUT N. F. PROP THIRTY
NINE THAT THE MONEY HOW MUCH
MONEY IS LEFT IN OF THE PROP
THIRTY NINE BECAUSE WE HAVE IT
LOOKS THAT WILL GET ALLOCATE
SEVENTY FIVE MILLION TO WE DID
THAT IN TWENTY. SEVENTEEN SO
WHAT ARE WE LOOKING AT WE HAVE
THE STAFF PEOPLE FOR TWO YEARS
WE'RE GONNA RUN OUT OF MONEY IN
THIS PROGRAM I GUESS IS WHAT
I'M ASKING. YEAH THE PROPERTY
NINE PROGRAM OVERALL WAS VERY
SUCCESSFUL- WE HAD.
APPROXIMATELY ONE POINT SEVEN
FIVE BILLION DOLLARS THAT WORK
WAS WAS ALLOCATED OVER THE FIVE
YEAR PERIOD THAT THE FUNDS WERE
COLLECTED. AND WE HAD SOMETHING
LIKE TWO THOUSAND THAT THE
TWENTY ONE HUNDRED ELEAZAR- IN
LOCAL EDUCATION AGENCIES IN THE
STATE PARTICIPATE SO THERE'S
GREAT UPTAKE AND THE MONEY WAS
DISPERSED WIDELY TO SERVE
SCHOOL STRUCTURE TO CALIFORNIA.
AND WE YOU KNOW WE ARE STILL IN
THE FINANCE YOUR QUESTION- THIS
SEVENTY FIVE MILLION DOLLARS
WAS WAS FUNDS THAT WERE
IDENTIFIED A COUPLE YEARS AGO
IS NOT HAVING BEEN- REQUESTED
THERE WAS VERY LITTLE LEFT OVER
MONEY AND SEVENTY FIVE MILLION
OUT OF ONE POINT SEVEN FIVE
BILLION WAS WHICH ONE OF THOSE
TRUMP. AND HOWEVER AS WE SIT
HERE TODAY WE HAVE. WE STILL
HAVE PROJECTS THAT ARE NOT
1100% COMPLETE SO THERE ARE
SOME FUNDS. THAT ARE- THEY
HAVEN'T BEEN SET YET- IT AS WE
SPEAK AND I CAN GET YOU EXACT
FIGURES ON THAT SENATOR. I
THINK THAT'S PART OF WHAT WE
CALL THE MAY REVISE EVERY GET
RE PURPOSING NOT MINE NUMBER
SOLD COMMITTEE OKAY. LMAO ARE
YOU HAVE A COMMENT ON THE
SCHOOL BUS. I REQUEST. WE DON'T
HAVE ANY ISSUES RAISED WITH
THIS- PROPOSAL MR. OKAY VERY
GOOD TO US. THANK YOU ON THE
CLARIFICATION AND THE
AFFORDABILITY ON THE- THE
ELECTRICAL SIDE LET'S WE'RE
GONNA HOLD ISSUE NUMBER FOUR
MOVE ON TO. ISSUE NUMBER FIVE
AND THIS IS THE EPIC PROGRAM-
MISTER DIRECTOR BOHAN EUROPE
AGAIN. YEAH THANK YOU VERY MUCH
AGAIN MEMBERS- THIS THIS THAT
THE THINK THE ENERGY COMMISSION
SEPARATE PROGRAM THIS IS OUR
RESEARCH PROGRAM THE PREMIER
RESEARCH PROGRAM IN AMERICA IF
LINE'S ENERGY RESEARCH AND
INNOVATION PROJECTS NEARLY ALL
THE FUNDING THAT WE AWARD ISSUE
COMPETITIVE AND WE AIM TO KEEP
IT THAT WAY THIS IS A
COMPETITIVE PROGRAM HOWEVER OUR
PROCESS IS VERY THOUGHTFUL
DELIBERATE. IT TAKES ABOUT A
YEAR FROM CONCEIVING- AN AREA
WE WOULD LIKE TO FIND HOLDING
WORKSHOPS PUTTING OUT THE
SOLICITATION ITSELF EVALUATING
APPLICATIONS ETCETERA
ULTIMATELY AWARDING FUNDS THAT
WHOLE PROCESS CAN OFTEN TAKE A
YEAR LAST YEAR. SENATE BILL ONE
FIFTEEN GRANTED US AUTHORITY TO
PROVIDE WHAT WE CALL FOLLOW ONE
FUNDING FOR MERITORIOUS
RESEARCH PROJECTS UNDER VERY
STRICT CONDITIONS AGAIN ALMOST
ALL FUNDS ARE AWARDED
COMPETITIVELY BUT WE WANTED
NARAL CARVE OUT THE END OF WHAT
WHAT THE CONDITIONS WERE FLAWS
IN ORDER TO PROVIDE FALL ONE
FUNDING SO IN ORDER TO AWARD
FUNDING TO A MERITORIOUS
RECIPIENT. TO COMPLETE A
PROJECT TO DO ADDITIONAL WORK
AND MEET A BUNCH GREATER I WILL
READ THEM ALL BUT JUST TO GIVE
YOU A SENSE THE PRIMARY RISK.
OF YOU KNOW TO BE LOCATED IN
CALIFORNIA. JIM SPELLMAN OF 80%
OF FUNDING ITSELF. THE ORIGINAL
PRICE HAD TO HAVE BEEN
COMPELLED BID. THE PROJECT TO
HAVE DONE IT'S A RISK. THE OF
ESTá POTENTIAL EXTRA DRESSING
TERM PRIORITIES SUCH A WHILE
FOR AND THE LIST GOES ON BUT
JUST TO GIVE A SENSE THIS THESE
ARE THESE ARE VERY NARROW STRIP
CONDITIONS UNDER WHICH THE
FOLLOW ON FUNDING WOULD BE
APPROPRIATE. WHAT WE'RE SEEKING
DOES THIS MORNING FROM YOU IS
AFFORDED TO CONTINUE TO UTILIZE
THIS STRUCTURE WE'VE BUILT TO
ALLOW FOLLOW ON FUNDING GOING
FORWARD SB ONE FIFTEEN GRANTED
ONLY FOR THIS YEAR AND WE'D
LIKE TO CONTINUE IT. AND WE
THINK IT'S- IT. GIVEN THAT
WE'VE GOT SOME PROJECTS THAT
WOULD BE ELIGIBLE FOR FOLLOW ON
FUNDING THAT COULD- SERVICE
BOB. CHALLENGES WE'RE FACING
THIS COMING SUMMER WITH
RELIABILITY. NOW THIS THE
ENERGY DEPARTMENT PUBLISHED A
REPORT OR SORT OF A SENIOR YEAR
AND I THINK THAT SORT OF THAT
THAT ANALYZES THESE TO THE
COMPETITIVE GRANTS WE GAVE OUT
THESE ARE ALL THE GOOD THINGS
THAT WE'VE DONE THIS IS HOW
IT'S AFFECTED YOUR LIFE THAT
TYPE OF STUFF IT DESERVES A
LIKE THAT COMES OUT OF.
ABSOLUTELY WE DO AN ANNUAL
REPORT. AND WE PROVIDED TO THE
PUBLIC UTILITIES COMMISSION AND
IT'S AVAILABLE TO THE
LEGISLATURE AS WELL AND I CAN I
CAN GET YOU THE MOST RECENT
ONE- OR OR ANY OF THE U. S.
OKAY LMAO YOU INDICATE THAT.
YOU WANT SOME SORT OF
NOTIFICATION BEFORE THINGS ARE
FUNDED ON THE FOLLOW ON. WHAT
DO YOU THINK ABOUT THE EPIC.
JUST REPORTING WHAT THEY DID
BECAUSE THIS DOESN'T SEEM LIKE
IT'S AN EXTREME AMOUNT OF MONEY
THAT'S AND THEIR- WHO'S HERE.
YEAH THAT'S THAT'S RIGHT MISTER
CHAIRS ACROSS FROM OF THE
LEGISLATIVE ANALYST'S OFFICE-
WE DO THANK PROVIDING THIS TYPE
OF AUTHORITY AND FLEXIBILITY-
COULD MAKE A LOT OF SENSE- IN
THOSE SORT OF LIMITED
CIRCUMSTANCES OF THE- DIRECTOR
TALKED ABOUT- BUT WE THINK THE
LEGISLATURE MIGHT WANT TO
CONSIDER ADDING A REQUIREMENT
THAT THE ENERGY COMMISSION
NOTIFIES. LEGISLATURE BEFORE
KIND OF AWARDING THE FOLLOW ON
FUNDING- RIGHT RIGHT NOW I
THINK THE PROCESS WOULD BE THAT
THE NOTIFICATION WILL COME
AFTER THE AWARD AND SO-
PROVIDING THE NOTIFICATION
BEFORE THE AWARD WOULD JUST ADD
A LITTLE ADDITIONAL KIND OF
OVERSIGHT BEFORE THE MONEY IS
ACTUALLY ALLOCATED AND- THIS
COULD BE SIMILAR TO THERE'S AN
EXISTING. JAIL BC NOTIFICATION
PROCESS THAT THE CDC USES ONE
OF THE AWARDS- SOLE SOURCE
CONTRACTS WHERE THERE'S SORT OF
AN EXEMPTION TO THE REQUIREMENT
FOR COMPETITIVE BIDS AND SO THE
LEGISLATURE COULD CONSIDERING
ADOPTING SORT OF A SIMILAR TYPE
OF PROCESS HERE AS. WELL GOT IT
SENATE ALI. I WOULD JUST SAY I
BE IN. THAT I THINK WE NEED TO
HAVE. MORE OVERSIGHT THAN LAST
WE'VE SEEN. OVER THE PAST YOU
KNOW TIME THAT THERE'S YOU JUST
CAN'T MAKE SURE THEY'RE
COMPETITIVE AND IT'S DONE RIGHT
AND I THINK IT'S OUR OBLIGATION
TO DO THAT SO IN THIS IS.
ASKING FOR PERMANENT AND THEN
IN THIS EPIC LAST YEAR WAS ONE
WELL I WON YOUR AUTHORIZATION
AND THIS IS WOULD BE- CONTINUES
TO. BASICALLY A PERMANENT-
PROGRAM AND SO I THINK WE
SHOULD MAYBE LOOK AT THAT AS
WELL. OKAY THIRTY BEHIND THANK
YOU VERY MUCH WE'RE DONE WITH
THE ENERGY DEPARTMENT THIS
MORNING- AND LET'S SEE WHAT IN
EARTH. LET'S GO ON TO ISSUE
NUMBER SIX WHICH IS THE PUBLIC
UTILITIES COMMISSION CAN COME
FORWARD THIS IS- ANOTHER I. T.
PROGRAM. THE MORNING CHAIRMAN
HUSKY THE BOARD MEMBERS MY NAME
IS JONATHAN MARKETS AND I'M A
PROGRAM MANAGER IN THE CPC'S
COMMUNICATIONS DIVISION TODAY
WERE REQUESTED ONE POINT SIX
MILLION DOLLARS IN THE BUDGET
YEAR PLUS BUNGLING FUNDING OF
TWO HUNDRED NINETY THOUSAND
DOLLARS PER YEAR FOR
MAINTENANCE AND SUPPORT TO
IMPLEMENT THE PROGRAM CLAIMS
MANAGEMENT SYSTEM OR PC MASS
WHICH WAS ORIGINALLY PART OF A
TWO THOUSAND SIXTEEN BUDGET
CHANGE PROPOSAL. THE SYSTEM
WILL PROVIDE A FULLY INTEGRATED
STANDARD ENTERPRISE WIDE
TECHNOLOGY PLATFORM. TO
AUTOMATE MANY FUNCTIONS ARE NOW
BEING PERFORMED MANUALLY AND
WITH PAPER BY BOTH
COMMUNICATIONS SERVICE
PROVIDERS AND COMMISSION STOP.
THE ULTIMATE GOAL IS TO MAKE IT
EASIER AND MORE EFFICIENT FOR
THE CPUC. REGULATED
COMMUNICATIONS SERVICE
PROVIDERS TO FILE PUBLIC
PURPOSE PROGRAM CLAIMS TRACK
THEIR PAYMENTS AND OTHERWISE
INTERACT WITH OUR AGENCIES
PUBLIC PURPOSE PROGRAM CLAIMS
PROCESS. IS SIMPLER MORE
ACCURATE AND MORE TRANSPARENT
WAY. THE IMPLEMENTATION OF THE
PC MASS WAS DELAYED PRIMARILY
DUE TO ORACLE NO LONGER
SUPPORTING SOME OF THE
TECHNOLOGY THAT WAS USED TO
BUILD THE ORIGINAL SPLISH. IN
ADDITION IN THE MEANTIME CLOUD
BASED TECHNOLOGY REACH MATURITY
AND OFFERS A BETTER SOLUTION
I'M HAPPY TO ANSWER ANY
QUESTIONS YOU MAY HEALTH. AND
YOU BELIEVE THAT THAT THIS
TRANSPORTATION CURRIER CARRIER
PORTAL IS THAT TECHNOLOGY IN
THE CLOUD IS EASILY
TRANSFERABLE TO THE- PROGRAM
THAT YOU MANAGE. YES THAT'S
CORRECT END UP. BERMAN THE
SOLICITATION FOR THAT PROGRAM
PART OF THE GOAL WAS TO MAKE
THE TECHNOLOGY IS EASILY
TRANSFERABLE AS POSSIBLE INDEED
THAT WAS INDICATED IN THE
SOLICITATION. OKAY- HELLO
MISTER I'M BROWN. NO CONCERNS
WITH THIS REQUEST MR CHAN
CENTER DOLLY. ALONG WITH MY
TEAM OF MAYBE WE SHOULD GET
DISNEYLAND TO FIGURE OUT HOW TO
MANAGE OUR SYSTEMS- WHO ARE YOU
AND THIS IS THE THIRD TIME IN
THIS HEARING THAT WE TALK ABOUT
IT WE SPENT EIGHT MILLION
DOLLARS SO. CAN YOU GIVE ME
SOME ASSURANCES ON. WHAT KIND
OF TECHNOLOGY YOU'RE GONNA USE
THIS IS ACTUALLY GONNA BE-
AVAILABLE FOR LONG TERM AND SO
THAT WE CAN. WE CAN STREAMLINE
THE PROCESS IS NO PRIVATE
BUSINESS WOULD BE ABLE TO KEEP
CONTINUE TO GO BACK AND PUT
THIS KIND OF RESOURCES INTO
THEIR I. T. PROGRAMS- IN STATE
BUSINESS IN IS QUITE.
FRUSTRATING ON SO MANY LEVELS
AS A LEGISLATOR TO I MEAN EDT
DMV. DTS I MEAN CAN YOU CAN YOU
GIVE ME SOMETHING THAT WOULD
MAKE ME WANT TO VOTE FOR THIS.
I UNDERSTAND YOUR FRUSTRATION
AND I THINK THAT WE SURE TO.
THE NOOSE- TECHNOLOGY THAT'S
BEING USED AT THE CORE OF THE
TRANSPORTATION CARRIER PORTAL
THAT WAS REFERENCED BY THE
CHAIR THE SALES FORCE BASED
PLATFORM. AND AS A RESULT WE
BELIEVE THAT THAT PLATFORM
PROVIDES A MORE STABLE AND LONG
TERM SOLUTION. AND THAT SALES
FORCE HAS BEEN VERY RESPONSIVE
IN WORKING WITH US ON THE
TRANSPORTATION CARRIER PORTAL
AND THAT MANY ELEMENTS OF THAT
PORT OR ALSO WILL BE PART OF
THE PROGRAM CLAIMS MANAGEMENT
SYSTEM. AND WHAT IT WHAT DO YOU
THINK THE LONG TERM VIABILITY
OF THIS PROGRAM IS AS IT IS A
GOOD FOR TWO YEARS FIVE YEARS
HOW HOW I MEAN I'M ONLY GONNA
BE ANOTHER THREE YEARS AND YOU
KNOW MAYBE. BY THEN WE CAN
FIGURE OUT HOW TO GET SOME OF
THESE PROGRAMS IN PLACE AND-
YOU KNOW WHERE MAYBE. PEOPLE
ARE ACCESSING A JUST GOING OUT
AND YOU KNOW DO THEIR GOOD WORK
SPECIALLY WAS ALSO DISINTEGRATE
RIGHT NOW SO WHAT WHAT'S THAT
HOW LONG. HOW LONG WITH THIS
PROGRAM- OR OR COULD IT BE-CONTINUE UPDATED LIKE TO DO MY
IPHONE EVERY COUPLE DAYS AT
HOME IT JUST TELLS ME IT'S
GONNA. DRAYTON IT WORKS PERFECT.
I'M HAPPY TO TEND TO ANSWER
QUESTIONS AND ALSO WE CAN.
SCHEDULE SEPARATELY- MORE
DETAILED BRIEFING. IN THE
CRITTER INFORMATION TECHNOLOGY
STAFF MY UNDERSTANDING IS THAT.
SALES FORCE REGULARLY UPDATES
OUR PLATFORM. AND SO THEY
SHOULD BE A LONG TERM
SUSTAINABLE SOLUTION. OUR GOAL
IS TO PUT IN PLACE- CLAIM
MANAGEMENT SYSTEM THAT CAN BE
USED. REPEATEDLY BY SERVICE
PROVIDERS FOR THE FORESEEABLE
FUTURE. THAT'S OUR GOAL. I'M
LOOKING FORWARD TO HOLD MY
BREATH. WELL WE HAVE THE . YOU
SEE IN FRONT OF US FOR THEM I'M
SURE I SPEAK FOR THE OTHER
HUNDRED NINETEEN MEMBERS OF THE
LEGISLATURE IS. LET'S GET SOME
DECISIONS TO AND WERE WE HEAR
ON A DAILY BASIS FROM OUR
CONSTITUENTS ABOUT THE PVC CAT
THE CAT. CAN PUBLISH IT
DECISION CAN'T MAKE A DECISION
SO WE'RE URGING YOU RIGHT NOW
TO. YOU KNOW. CONVENE AND
DECIDE AND MOVE ON- THAT'LL BE
GOOD THAT MEASURE WE'RE GOING
TO HOLD ALSO SO WE- WELCOME TO
OUR PUBLIC OF- TESTIMONY PUBLIC
COMMENT- HEARING BASED ON THE
GOVERNOR'S PROPOSED BUDGET AS A
REMINDER TODAY'S PARTICIPATION
NUMBER IS. 844-291-6364 IT'S ON
THE SCREEN. MAX SIX CODE IS
FOURTEEN SEVENTEEN SIX OH NINE.
AS A MENTION DUE TO CONSTRAINTS
REGARDING THE WHITE THE FEAR
IT'S TECHNOLOGY CONSIDERATIONS
AND CLEANING PROTOCOLS
COMMITTEE CHAIRS WHICH WOULD BE
ME IN THIS INSTANCE MASON MAY
INSTITUTE TIME LIMITS ON
TESTIMONY WE HAVE A HARD STOP
ELEVEN. FIFTY FIVE- TODAY I'M
GOING TO ASK EACH MEMBER
REPUBLIC PROVIDE COMMENT
REMARKS AND LIMIT THEM TO ONE
MINUTE PLEASE INDICATE WHICH
ITEM NUMBER IN WHICH PART OF
THE AGENDA HI YOU'RE CALLING
I'M WE MAY BE ABLE TO FINISH
FINISH THAT WITH THAT DO WE
HAVE WITNESSES IN THIS HEARING
ROOM PLEASE COME FORWARD AND
LET'S. LET'S HEAR FROM YOU.
MORNING THIS IS A MEMBER ANY
MORE. FOUNDED IN TWO THOUSAND
SEVEN CAMPBELL BASED CHARGE
POINT IS A LEADING PROVIDER OF
EVEY INFRASTRUCTURE HARDWARE
AND SOFTWARE IN NORTH AMERICA
AND TO DATE WE HAVE COMPLETED
EIGHTY EIGHT MILLION CHARGING
SESSIONS AND DRIVEN MORE THAN
TWO POINT SEVEN BILLION
ELECTRIC MILES. WE WANT TO
THANK THE GOVERNOR FOR MAKING
FOR PROVIDING THIS PROPOSAL IN
THE BUDGET CHARGE PORT CHARGE
POINT SUPPORTS THIS BUDGET
PROPOSAL THAT WILL CREATE JOBS
AND ECONOMIC GROWTH WHILE
REDUCING AIR QUALITY THAT
RANKED BROTHER YOUR POLLUTION
AND PROVIDING GREATER AIR
QUALITY WILL PROVIDE SUPPORT
FOR LOW INCOME CALIFORNIANS WHO
PURCHASE CLEANER VEHICLES BY
SECURITIZE IN EVEY REGISTRATION
FEES THE STATE CAN INCENTIVIZE.
AND ACCELERATE THE BUILD OUT
THE EEVEE CHARGING
INFRASTRUCTURE CHARGE POINT
LOOKS FORWARD TO CONTINUING TO
WORK WITH THE ADMINISTRATION
WITH THIS COMMITTEE AND THE
LEGISLATURE TO ENSURE FUNDING
OF FOR PROGRAM SUPPORTED BY
THIS BUDGET THAT RESULTS IN A
QUICK AND EFFICIENT DEPLOYMENT
OF EVEY INFRASTRUCTURE.
SPECIFIC PROGRAMS ARE MADE
AVAILABLE FOR DISADVANTAGED AND
UNDERSERVED COMMUNITIES IN THE
STATE MEETS ITS AMBITIOUS Z.
VEHICLE THANK YOU MISTER. THANK
YOU LET'S GO WERE THERE ANY
WITNESSES ON OUR OVERFLOW ROOM
ONE ONE TWO WHO WISH TO PROVIDE
PUBLIC COMMENT SINGLE ONE WEEK
LET'S MOVE TO THE WITNESSES
WAITING TO PROVIDE. PUBLIC
COMMENT ON OUR TELECONFERENCE
ARVEST MODERATOR IF YOU WOULD
PLEASE PROMPT INDIVIDUALS
WAITING FOR FIVE PUBLIC
COMMENT. WE WILL BEGIN. THANK
YOU MISTER CHAIR THE- PROVIDE
PUBLIC COMMENT OVER THE
TELEPHONE PLEASE PRESS ONE.
FOLLOWED BY ZERO USING YOUR
TELEPHONE KEYPAD. ONCE AGAIN
THAT COMMANDERS ONE AND THEN
THE. ZERO ARE YOU READY FOR THE
FIRST COMMENT. PLEASE PROCEED.
PRETTY GOOD WATER LINE TWENTY
THREE. TWO THREE PLEASE GO
AHEAD. R. A. AND THANK YOU
TRACTARIAN CALCIUM MEMBERS TEAM
YOU CAN USE- WITH THE COMMUNITY
ALLIANCE WITH FAMILY FARMERS
WHICH STRONGLY SUPPORT ITEM
FOURTEEN THE PROPOSED SEVEN
POINT SEVEN MILLION TWO CDS
THANKS FOR TECHNICAL ASSISTANCE
AND MICRO GRANT MOMENT I'VE
BEEN UNDERSERVED FARMERS GIVEN
THE URGENT NEED TO HELP SMALL
FARMERS ACCESS FEDERAL COOLEY
RELIEF WE ASK THAT YOU MOVE
QUICKLY TO APPROVE THE PROPOSED
THREE POINT THREE FIVE MILLION
PER FISCAL YEAR TWENTY TWENTY
ONE. CAPEN GREENS WITH DEFINING
SMALL FARM AS A HUNDRED ACRES
LESS HAVE ALSO SUPPORTS THE
ITEM FIFTEEN THE PROPOSED.
TRANSITION TO SAY FIRST OF. AND
IT MEANT INCREASED EMAIL MALE
FEET I MEAN IN THE MAIL OF. ONE
AND YOU NEED DETAILED BUDGET
LANGUAGE CHANGE THESE GO TO
ASCEND PROGRAM DESCRIBE. P.
INCLUDING RENEWING CITY AND A
LARGE INTEGRATED I MEAN. AND I
PROGRAMS HAVE CONSIDER BEST A
PRETTY HIGH IN PRO. THE CSU IPM.
TO HELP GROWERS EMPLOY. TURNS
EXPANDED I REACH GRANT BUT
PRACTICES FROM. IT IS IMPORTANT
TO CAPS AND THAT FOR HAVE TO
THE BEST BASED INFORMATION
FINALLY BRING OUR COFFEE THANK
THE- PROPOSED SUITE FUNDING
THANK YOU VERY. THANK YOU NEXT.
WELL I AM THIRTY EIGHT THREE
EIGHT YOUR LINE IS PEN. GOOD
MORNING CAROL CAL SKI AND
COMMITTEE MEMBERS UNDER ITEMS
EIGHT FIVE SEVEN ZERO CDFA MY
NAME IS ALISON CHENEY AND I'M
THE CEO OF THE FORTY EIGHT THIS
NUMBER IN FAIRGROUNDS IN
PETALUMA THANK YOU FOR THE
OPPORTUNITY TO SPEAK TODAY
REGARDING THE FUNDING FOR THE
FAIRGROUNDS. THE ENTIRETY OF
THE NETWORK AFFAIRS HAS BEEN
DECIMATED BY CODE FOR THE PAST
ELEVEN MONTHS GET ALL FAIR
GROUNDS HAVE ANSWERED THE CALL
TO SUPPORT THEIR COMMUNITIES
WITH COVERED RELATED TESTING
VACCINATION INFORMATION FOOD
DISTRIBUTION AS WELL AS
WILDFIRE EMERGENCY SERVICES. MY
FAIR GROUNDS ALONE IS HOUSE
OVER THREE THOUSAND PEOPLE AND
LIVESTOCK IN THE PAST THREE
YEARS OR FIVE OF THEM. EACH
FAIRGROUNDS IS UNIQUE AND I
DEPEND ON MY NEIGHBORING COUNTY
FAIRS TO USE THEIR UNIQUE
QUALITIES AND ABILITY. TO MEET
THE NEEDS MY FAIRGROUNDS CANNOT
FILL DURING EVENTS LIKE THE-
BECAUSE OF THE SUPPORT OF THESE
NON GAAP FARES PROVIDED TO US
OF THE GENERAL COMMUNITY AND
THE FACT IS FOUNDER DONATED FOR
OPERATIONS. I'D LIKE TO SEE
THIS ALLOCATION DISTRIBUTED TO
ALL THE FARES ON THE NETWORK.
THANK YOU. THANK YOU THE NEXT.
NINE TWELVE ONE TWO PLEASE GO
AHEAD. GOOD MORNING CHAIR AND
MEMBERS OF THE COMMITTEE MY
NAME IS A MEASURE RISING I'M
HERE ON BEHALF OF ADVANCED
ENERGY ECONOMY AND NATIONAL
ASSOCIATION OF ADVANCED ENERGY
AND TRANSPORTATION BUSINESSES
AND MY COMMENTS ARE AROUND THE
GOVERNOR'S THAT PROPOSED
BUDGET. EIGHT WE SUPPORT THE
FOCUSED ON YOUR MISSION
VEHICLES INFRASTRUCTURE THE
PROPOSED BUDGET WE SEE THIS AS
AN IMPORTANT DOWN PAYMENT ON
CALIFORNIA'S CLEAN
TRANSPORTATION COMMITMENT
MYSTICALLY WE SUPPORT EARLY
ACTION PROPOSED BUDGET ITEMS AT
THEIR CRITICAL PAIN CREATING
ACCESS TO CLEAN MOBILITY
PROGRAMS AND INCENTIVIZING ZERO
EMISSION TRUCKS AND BUSES. IN
EVERY REGION OF THE STATE. ALSO
AT THE MISSION MONEY HAD
MENTIONED- EARLIER THE EASIEST
TRACKING TWENTY ONE TWENTY
SEVEN SACRAMENTO. WHICH IS
MANDATED BY THE LEGISLATURE
CONFIRMED WE HAVE THE
INFRASTRUCTURE GAP. AND EVEN
MORE SO IF YOU CONSIDER THE
GOVERNOR'S WE CAN BE OUT. EIGHT
A POLICE REPORT THE RE
AUTHORIZATION OF EIGHT EIGHT
FUNDS INTERROGATION AT THE
DIRECT NEEDS TO SCALE BACK INTO
STRUCTURED GAP. ALSO BE
OPERATING THIS COMMITTED
FUNDING SOURCE FOR
INFRASTRUCTURE INVESTMENT. AND
THE STRONG SIGNAL TO THE
PRIVATE SECTOR THAT ONE FACT
GREATER INVESTMENTS HELPING
SCALE INFRASTRUCTURE BUILD OUT
ACROSS THE STATE THANK YOU SO
MUCH. THANK YOU NECKS. WINDS
SIXTY THREE SIX THREE PLEASE GO
AHEAD. MISTER CHAIRMAN OR
SPENDING TO A COMEBACK FOR THE
CALIFORNIA AIR POLLUTION
CONTROL OFFICERS ASSOCIATION
COMMENTING ON AGENDA PART B.
ISSUE TO- WE SUPPORT THE
GOVERNOR'S BUDGET PROPOSAL
EXTENDING CLEAN AIR PROGRAM
FUNDING THAT WAS RE AUTHORIZED
IN TWENTY THIRTEEN BY AB EIGHT-
WHICH WAS AUTHORED BY THEN
ASSEMBLY MEMBERS PRAY AND
SKINNER. THESE PROGRAMS WHICH
INCLUDE THE CARL MOYER MEMORIAL
AIR QUALITY STANDARDS
ATTAINMENT PROGRAM AND EIGHTY
NINE TWENTY THREE LOCAL
INCENTIVES PROGRAMS ARE
CRITICAL TO MEETING
CALIFORNIA'S CLEAN AIR GOALS IN
THE SINCERELY APPRECIATE THAT
RECOGNITION AND COMMITMENT IN
COOPERATION WITH CARP
CALIFORNIA AIR RESOURCES BOARD
AIR DISTRICTS ADMINISTER THE
HIGHLY SUCCESSFUL CARL MOYER
PROGRAM WHICH PROVIDES
INCENTIVES TO PRIVATE
BUSINESSES AND PUBLIC AGENCIES
TO VOLUNTARILY. CLEAN UP OLDER
DIRTIER VEHICLES AND MOBILE OFF
ROAD ENGINES SINCE ITS
INCEPTION IN NINETEEN NINETY
EIGHT THE MORE YOUR PROGRAM HAS
ENABLED THE REPLACEMENT
SCRAPPAGE ARE REPAIRABLE FOR
SIXTY EIGHT THOUSAND ENGINES
RESULTING IN REDUCTION OF MORE
THAN ONE HUNDRED NINETY FOUR
THOUSAND TIMES AND- KNOCKS AND-
WE AT REACTIVE ORGANIC GASES.
WHICH CONTRIBUTE TO SMOG
FORMATION AND REDUCTION OF OVER
SEVENTY ONE HUNDRED TIMES AND
PARTICULAR MATTER WHICH IS IN
THEIR TOXIC THE LOCAL EIGHTY
NINE TWENTY THREE INCENTIVES
PROGRAM PROVIDES FUNDING FOR
SCHOOL BUS REPLACEMENTS
AGRICULTURAL EQUIPMENT LIKE
DUTY VEHICLE SCRAPPING PROGRAMS
IN CARL MORE QUALIFYING
PROJECTS THIS CRITICAL FUNDING
IS ESSENTIAL FOR REACHING OUR
FEDERAL AND STATE HEALTH
PROTECTIVE AIR QUALITY IN
PAYMENT STANDARDS. AND RE
AUTHORIZING THESE TWO PROGRAMS
WHICH ARE PRIMARILY LOCATED
LOCALLY OPERATED EFFICIENT AND
EFFECTIVE AND ADDRESS LOCAL
CONDITIONS AND PRIORITIES THE
SENSUAL AND MEETING
CALIFORNIA'S CLEAN AIR GOALS
THANK. YOU MISTER CHAIRMAN AND
CENTERS. THANK YOU ENACT.
WELCOME SIX ONE SIXTY ONE
PLEASE GO AHEAD. LUCKY NUMBER
SIXTY ONE. HI EVERYBODY THREE
TO COOK HERE TODAY ON BEHALF OF
THE CAP. COALITION I AM
TESTIFYING IN REGARDS TO PART
BE ISSUE TO. OUR MISSION
VEHICLE- PLAN- THE CALIFORNIA
HYDROGEN COALITION ARE MEMBERS
OF HYDROGEN FUEL PRODUCERS
HYDROGEN FUEL DEVELOPERS AND
KILTS ALL OF YOUR CALL MAY BE
FACTORED- WE LIKE THE QUEEN
HER. ROOM AND WERE INTRIGUED BY
THE ORGANIZATION OR ALSO PLEASE
TAKE THAT HYDROGEN WILL BE
ELIGIBLE FOR THE PROGRAM HEAVY
DUTY OKAY. WE ARE HOWEVER
ALARMED AND CONCERNED THAT THE
LANGUAGE AB DESCRIBED PASSED BY
THE ADMINISTRATION- DID NOT
ACTUALLY COMMIT TO THAT TWO
HUNDRED HYDROGEN ASIAN CALL.
WHICH I WILL ALSO POINT OUT ON.
AT LEAST THAT PERCENT OF THE
FIVE HUNDRED MILLION BEING
SPENT- CONCERNING AT THIS IS
THE ONLY PROGRAM WITH THE
EXCEPTION OF THE- BILL
STANDARDS SUPPORTING THE BUILD
OUT OF HYDROGEN FUELING. I
DIDN'T HAVE TO BE A PART OF
CALIFORNIANS EMISSION VEHICLE
ACT IF WE EXPECT TO MAKE COST
EFFECTIVE DATE. BUT THAT ACCESS
TO THE 40% OF CALIFORNIANS
LIVING IN MULTI FAMILY
DWELLINGS. ARE SUPER COMMUTERS
AND VEHICLES AND AGAN
CONSTRUCTION WORKFORCE FOR THE
THREE THAT WE LOOK FORWARD TO
WORKING WITH YOU AND THE
ADMINISTRATION ON WEIGHT MAKE
THIS PROGRAM MORE CHECKUP
NEUTRAL AS WE ALL WORK TOWARD
OUR TWENTY THIRTY FIVE BEFORE.
THANK YOU THANK YOU NEXT. WINDS.
SIXTY FIVE SIX FIVE. GOOD
MORNING CHAIRED COMMITTEE
MEMBERS I HAPPEN TO SOUTH COAST
AGENCY I'LL BE COMMENTING ON
PART BE ISSUED IT IF WE SUPPORT
THE PROPOSAL THE GOVERNOR'S
BUDGET YOU'VE GOT RIGHT HERE
QUALITY OF SOURCES IF YOU THINK
BETTER BY AB. AUTHORIZED THE
CALL. PRO WILL HELP ADDRESS WE
APPROVED HEALTH X. IN. MY
CURRENT UP THE STATE VEHICLE
FOR X. TO OF CLEANER TECH.
EXTENSION TO FORTY SIX THE
THING WHAT THE GOVERNOR
EXPECTED ORDER. BUT A CALL TO
SHE DIDN'T OF THAT ORDER. WE'RE
THE CARL MOYER PRO PROVIDING TO
ASSIST IN THE PURCHASE OF THE
REQUIRE HEAVY DUTY THERE ENGINE
BUT- ARE ONLY HAS RIPPLE.
EIGHTY SIX TIME OF. NUMBER TWO
HUNDRED FORTY NINE OF MATTER
EMISSION REDUCTION. FROM THE
SOUTH COULD REGIONAL. CHECK OUR-
FINDINGS EXPOSE TO AIR. I THE
CODE. EIGHTY THAT'S A THAT'S A
NEGATIVE HOW IMPACTS. OVERSTOCK
DEFEAT FEDERAL DEADLINE. USING
YOUR POLLUTION AND IF NOT MAY
THE GOLDEN STATE. STRUCTURES
OUT BUSINESS OKAY BURKE BUT A
CURRENT THANK YOU. NEXT WELL I
AM SIXTY SIX SIX. YOUR LINE IS
OPEN. THANK YOU FOR CARING
MEMBERS ALL THE SHANTI HOW HOUR
MARK IN BALLY ERR POLLUTION TO.
I'M HERE ON ECON AND PART B.
ISSUE NUMBER. THE DISTRICT
COURT BUDGET PROPOSAL LIKE THAT
ME AN ERROR PROGRAM BATTERY
OPERATED TWENTY THIRD BY
EIGHTEEN. I NEED INCLUDE FROM
AND EIGHTY NINE TWENTY THREE
PER AND THEY HAVE A DEFECT
BELIEVE REVIEWS MARC BERMAN AND
MISSION. AND PROVIDE EVERY NINE
IN GROUND FUNDING AT THE LOCAL
A NINE THREE AM TEN POINT BROKE
PROVIDES FUNDING FOR
BLOCKBUSTER PLAY PROPOSAL
EQUIPMENT LIKE DUTY ARE FROM.
AS WELL AS FROM FINE. I HOWEVER.
PERSONS IN THE ARTICLE THERE'S
SIX FIRING TWENTY FOUR THE
TIMING IS HERE RIGHT THE
PROGRAM AND THEY ARE. IN
MEETING. AND THE DISTRICT
NUMERICAL. VALUE CANNOT REACH
HE MET WITHOUT BREAKING MADE
ALLOW AND- BASED MEASURE ARE
NOT- JUSTICE PRODUCTION MISSION
THANK YOU. BOND THAT IN THE
LOCAL AND ECONOMY YOU CAN BE
THERE ARE FOR THAT THAT ARE
CRITICAL TO. ABOUT. BURKE THANK
YOU. NEXT IT WILL TO LINE SIX
LINE AS OF. THANK YOU MISTER IN
MEMBER MICHAEL PHELPS. BAKER
DIRECTOR OF THE TRANSIT. HI
HERE VOICING OUR SUPPORT FOR
ISSUE TO IMPORT B. OF THE
GENDER I RELATED IS THE
CONTRACT PROGRAM I KNOW THAT
THIS PROGRAM IS ESSENTIAL TO
TRANSFER BECAUSE THEY TRAIN. TO
ZERO EMISSION TECHNO OUTLINE IN
THE RESOURCE FOR INNOVATIVE
CLEAN TRANSIT PRO. WE ALLEGE
THAT MOVE THIS PROPOSAL FORWARD
I AM HOPING YOU MIGHT
COMMUNICATE YOUR INTENT THE
ADMINISTRATION AND THE T. V.
ABOUT THE IMPORTANCE OF
THINKING CHEN BACK IN YOUR
MISSION BUT ACKNOWLEDGED HE-
INFRASTRUCTURE PROGRAMS THAT
ARE. BEING RE AUTHORIZATION I
WE WANT TO EMPHASIZE COURT THAT
PUBLIC DOLLARS ON THAT ARE MADE
AVAILABLE BY THE STATE SHOULD
BE INVESTED IN PUBLIC PURPOSES
I CAN DELIVER MULTIPLE CO
BENEFIT. AIR QUALITY MOBILITY
AND JOB PUBLIC TRANSIT IS THAT
AND HOPE THAT YOU CAN
ENCOURAGE- THE ADMINISTRATION
TO CONTINUE TO FOCUS ON PUBLIC
TRANSIT AT THE KEY. STRATEGY
FOR CLEAN TRANSPORTATION THANK
YOU. THANK YOU NET. NEXT WE'LL
GO TO LINE EIGHT YOUR LINE IS
OPEN. SURE MEMBERS DANIEL
BROUGHT ON BEHALF OF THEIR CLUB
CALIFORNIA I'M ALSO COMMENTING
ON PART B. AS YOU KILL. FRENCH
JOHNSON PART OF THE GOVERNOR
THERE ARE MISSION
TRANSPORTATION PROJECTS.
CALIFORNIA EVER GOING TO HAPPEN
BREATHABLE AIR OR KEEP ITS
CLIMATE GOALS WE NEED TO GET
INTERNAL COMBUSTION ENGINE OFF
THE ROUTE. BILLION DOLLAR
PROPOSAL FOR THE REMISSION
TRANSPORTATION INFRASTRUCTURE
EXPANDS AND LEVERAGES SB THAT
ALREADY EXPENSE. BUT THE CARPET
OF ADVANCING CLEAN
TRANSPORTATION. AS COMMISSIONER
MONAGHAN EXPRESSED IT BONDS
WILL GO A LONG WAY TO ALLAY
CONSUMER FEARS AROUND VEHICLE
RANGING EIGHTY. AND WILL NOT BE
CRITICAL TO WIDESPREAD ADOPTION
OF ZERO EMISSION CARS. THE
PROPOSAL FOR GIGI R. F. DOLLARS.
I WILL BE APPROPRIATELY SPENT
ON GUARANTEED GREENHOUSE GAS
EMISSION REDUCTION. JORDY BE
FUNDS FOR PLACE HEAVY DUTY
DIESEL ENGINE AND MAKE
CALIFORNIANS THAT QUICK HEART
AND LUNG DISEASE EVERY DAY. WE
LOOK FORWARD TO WORKING WITH
YOU TO EXPAND THINKING KEY
BUDGET ITEMS. THANK YOU NECKS.
NEXT TO LINE FIFTY NINE FIVE
NINE YOUR LINE IS OPEN. GOOD
MORNING TERM MEMBERS IS MICHAEL
MILLER WITH THE CALIFORNIA
ASSOCIATION OF WINE GRAPE
GROWERS. BOB THANK YOU VERY
MUCH. HELLO NUMBER FIFTEEN THE
P. R. YES THEY- GRANTSBURG HERE
NO YEAH MUCH OPPOSED THE
CURRENT PROPOSAL- WE DO ENJOY A
GREAT RELATIONSHIP OF BOTH YOU
CARE AND CDFA AND WE BELIEVE WE
TO WORK TOGETHER ON EIGHTY
EIGHT AYE AYE SOLUTION TO
ADDRESS OUR STRUCTURAL DEFICIT
BUT- LONG TERM AS DAN. IT IS
BEST THE BOOK HERE IS JUST. A
VERY UNWORKABLE ESPECIALLY ON
THE MERITS OF THE ARTICLE BUT
NINETEEN ENDEMIC WHERE
INDUSTRIES. AG INDUSTRIES
ROBBERS ARE SUFFERING
INCREDIBLE HISTORIC LOSSES-
WITH A GREAT OPTION WITH THE L.
A. L. RECOMMENDATION THAT YOU.
DOWN A PREGNANT. AS AND MORE
QUICKLY I THINK TOOK TO THAT MY
FACE QUICKLY A LITTLE BIT OF
WELL WE LIVE IN- PEOPLE SO FOR
LAS. BECAUSE THEY CAN'T ACCESS.
CENTRAL GETTING THE WORK DONE
AND HIGHER LEVEL DOES IT SEEM
LIKE THAT'S FROM AT THIS TIME
AND WE WOULD IS THAT RECOMMEND
WORKING TOGETHER ON SOMETHING
THAT SHORT. PROGRESS HE VOEPEL.
IN THE CURRENT. I'M THANK YOU
VERY MUCH FOR YOUR TIME HAVE A
GREAT DAY. THANK YOU NECKS.
NINE TWENTY SEVEN TWO SEVEN GO
AHEAD. GOOD MORNING THIS IS
GAIL DELLA HALF WITH WESTERN
GROWERS ASSOCIATION AND I'M
CALLING ON BEHALF OF OUR
MEMBERS IF THE COURT ISSUE
NUMBER THIRTEEN THIS WEEK
FUNDING OF FORTY MILLION
DOLLARS IN GRANTS THE FOCUS ON
GROUNDWATER SUSTAINABILITY. AS
YOU KNOW AS THEY MIGHT GET-
ROLLING OUT THE DOOR WITH ALL
OF THE PLAN THIS IS A CRITICAL
AMOUNT OF MONEY- BUILDING
INFRASTRUCTURE AND MAKING SURE
THAT OUR GROUNDWATER BECOME
SUSTAINABLE. WE ARE ALSO
CALLING IN REGARDING ISSUE
NUMBER FIFTEEN WE OPPOSE THIS
MEASURE FOR ALL OF THE REASONS.
THAT MICHAEL MILLER WITH THE
CALIFORNIA WINE GRAPE GROWERS
JEFF MENTIONED WE DO FEEL THAT
THIS IS- I'M WORKABLE AT THIS
TIME AND HAS MANY UNINTENDED
CONSEQUENCES. THANK YOU VERY
MUCH. THANK YOU NEXT. WE'LL GO
TO LINE SEVENTY SEVEN ZERO
PLEASE GO AHEAD. GOOD MORNING
THIS IS BILL MY GOVERNMENT
COALITION FOR CLEAN AIR ALSO
SPEAKING THIS MORNING ON BEHALF
OF THE NATURAL RESOURCES
DEFENSE COUNCIL ON ITEM NUMBER
TWO. WE SUPPORT THE GOVERNOR'S
REQUESTS FOR THREE HUNDRED
FIFTEEN MILLION DOLLARS FOR
CLEAN TRUCKS BUSES AND OFF ROAD
EQUIPMENT BECAUSE THE FINE
PARTICULATE MATTER THAT'S
PRODUCED BY THOSE DIESEL
ENGINES IS PARTICULARLY HEALTH
THREATENING. WE ALSO SUPPORT
THE GOVERNOR'S REQUEST FOR A
HUNDRED FIFTY MILLION DOLLARS
FOR CLEAN CARS FOR ALL AND
OTHER TRANSPORTATION EQUITY
PROJECTS THAT ARE PROVIDING
CLEAN MOBILITY TO LOW INCOME
CALIFORNIANS AND DISADVANTAGED
COMMUNITIES. CLEAN CARS FOR ALL
IS IN FACT OVERSUBSCRIBED THE
MONEY IN THE SOUTH COAST
DISTRICT HAS ALREADY RUN OUT
AND WILL RUN OUT SHORTLY IN THE
SAN JOAQUIN DISTRICT IF YOU DO
NOT TAKE EARLY ACTION ON THIS
VERY POPULAR PROGRAM. WE ALSO
SUPPORT THE RE AUTHORIZATION OF
EIGHTY EIGHT WHICH PROVIDES
IMPORTANT FUNDING FOR AIR
QUALITY PROGRAMS AND WE SUPPORT
THE SECURITIZATION OF ONE
BILLION DOLLARS. TO MAKE EARLY
INVESTMENTS IN THE CHARGING AND
FUELING INFRASTRUCTURE NEEDED
TO SUPPORT OUR ZERO EMISSION
VEHICLES- AS YOU HEARD THE
TESTIMONY FROM COMMISSIONER
MONAGHAN. THANK. YOU VERY MUCH
NECKS. NINE SEVENTY TWO SEVEN
TWO PLEASE GO AHEAD. THANK YOU
MISTER CHAIR MEMBERS DON KEPT
HE WOULD MAKE YOU CAPTAIN
ASSOCIATES ON BEHALF THE
CALIFORNIA MANUFACTURERS AND
TECHNOLOGY ASSOCIATION AND
CHEMICAL INDUSTRY ACCOUNTABLE
CALIFORNIA I WITH REGARD YOU
PART A ISSUE FIFTEEN THAT
DEPARTMENT I REGULATIONS
THEY'LL PACK PROPOSAL
UNFORTUNATELY THE NGA AND GI SB
FIVE MUST RAISE CONCERNS WITH
THE PROPOSAL- ADD THAT
CURRENTLY CONSTRUCTED RELATIVES
YOU THAT YOUR APPROACH FEELS
RECOGNIZE ATHLETES ALREADY
UNDERTAKEN BY MANUFACTURERS. A
DIFFERENT PLATFORM
ANTIMICROBIAL PATH AS WELL AS
OUTSIDE PRODUCT I HAD THAT
ADDRESS MANY CONCERNS ARE
RELATED TO SUSTAINABLE
APPROACHES INCLUDING AMONG
OTHER THINGS CONCENTRATION
EFFORTS TO ADDRESS ISSUES
AROUND WHAT A WATER USE OUR
PACKAGING REDUCTION AND MORE
ARE FURTHER WE BELIEVE THAT THE
PROPOSED ALLIES HERE TO ADD
THAT YOUR APPROACH IS
CONSTRUCTED. OUT COULD RESULT
IN DEFENSE THE SIMPSONS
ADVISORY NEEDS THAT FIRST YEAR-
I REDUCE WATER USAGE AS WELL AS
PACKAGING- USAGE- AND AS WELL
AS ISSUES RELATED TO
TRANSPORTATION- KIND OF LARGER
OUR PRODUCT APPLICATIONS
ADDITIONALLY IT COULD IN FACT
RESULT IN UNINTENDED
CONSEQUENCES. ARE RELATED TO
THE POTENTIAL NEED TO REDUCE
CONCENTRATION OPERATE THAT
ATTACH LEAD YOU OVER YOU OUR
PRODUCTS- INFO CERTAINLY
WOULDN'T WANT TO PURSUE THAT
HOW WOULD YOU LOOK FORWARD TO
WORKING WITH THE DEPARTMENT
ADMINISTRATION AND THE
LEGISLATURE ON THAT APPROACH
THE SIZE ADDRESS THE NEEDS OF
THE DEPARTMENT ADDED AT THIS
TIME AND WE MUST OUR VOICE. OUR
CONCERNS THANK YOU. THE YOU
NEXT. NINE SEVENTY SEVENTY
PLEASE AHEAD. EACH GOOD MORNING
KERR WHITE HOUSE IN NUMBER OF
THE ON I'M ALLEN ABS WITH BAY
AREA AR QUALITY MAN DISTRICT
COMMENT ON THE ISSUE TO THE-
MISSION BE A PROPOS. IN
ALIGNMENT WITH COLLEAGUE FROM
THE SOUTH COAST SAN JOAQUIN
CAPCO- THE BAY AREA AIR QUALITY
MANAGEMENT DISTRICT BOARD
GOVERNOR'S BUDGET PROPOSAL BE
AUTHORIZING AB EIGHT PROGRAMS
INCLUDING THE CARL MOYER AND
EIGHTY NINE TWENTY THREE
PROGRAMS THE HIGHLY SUCCESSFUL
PROGRAMS ARE CRITICAL TO
MEETING THE BAY AREA'S CLEAN
AIR GOLD INCLUDING REDUCTIONS
IN OZONE PRECURSORS PARTICULATE
MATTER AIR TOXICS IN GREENHOUSE
GASES. ALSO NOTE THAT THE
SUPPORTING KARL MOYER IN NINE
TWENTY THREE OF NOT CHANGED
SINCE INCEPTION WOULD SUPPORT
FUTURE INCREASES THE P. I OR
OTHER MECHANISM LAST FALL NOTE
OUR SUPPORT BETWEEN CARDS FOR
ALL PROGRAM IN THE AREAS
PROGRAMS CURRENTLY DESCRIBED
THIS PROGRAM IS CRITICAL IN
MAKING ZERO EMISSION VEHICLES
AVAILABLE TO LOW INCOME AND
DISADVANTAGED. COMMUNITIES IN
THE BAY AREA THANK YOU NEXT.
NINE FOURTEEN ONE FOUR PLEASE
GO AHEAD. THANK YOU AND GOOD
MORNING YEAH ON BEHALF OF THE
HOUSEHOLD AND COMMERCIAL
PRODUCT ASIAN I AM PROVIDING
COMMENTS ON OUR. EIGHT FIFTEEN
WE REPRESENT A VARIETY OF MANY.
NON PESTICIDE WOULD LIKE
DISINFECTED WITH HE COUNT 450%
OF THE REVENUE COLLECTED BY
EPR. BUT THAT'S NOT BUT WE HAVE
SEVERAL CONCERNS WITH THE BEAT
HE AND- YOUR RAISIN RESTRUCTURE
THE NOT THAT. INTERESTED
ADDITION I WILL ECHO THE
CONCERNS. CONCENTRATED PRODUCT
AND- ADD THAT WE WOULD ALSO
KNOW OUR MAN- IT BEGINNING
REGULAR BREAK. INCREASE
REGISTRATION B. WHICH ARE PAID
BY THE MANUFACTURER TO PAY IT
AND ALL PACKED WITH. MANY
CONSIDERED WOULD DELIVER. OUT
OF AND KNOWING. AND WE
ENCOURAGE THAT CAN TO CANCEL AT
THE OF REVENUE THE OF THE P. SB
BACK THERE TO IN INCREASE IN
THE FINE IN LARGE PART. FAILED
BACK IN. IT INCREASED WOULD GET
THE DEPART. MADE DURING IN OUR
ROBOT. OR PROCESS. DEVELOPED AT
THE- THAT AVOIDS. AS WE LOOK IF
YOU. CONTINUE TO INITIATION IF
YOU'RE ON. YEAH THANK YOU NECKS.
NINE THIRTY FIVE THREE FIVE
YOUR LINE IS OPEN. MR CHAIRMAN
MEMBERS OF THE COMMITTEE LOUIS
BROWN CALLING TODAY ON THREE
ISSUES FIRST WITH CDFA ISSUE
ELEVEN ON BEHALF OF WESTERN
FAIRS ASSOCIATION WHERE IN
SUPPORT OF THE APPROPRIATION
THAT THE GOVERNOR IS INCLUDED
IN THE BUDGET AND APPRECIATE
THE CONSIDERATION FOR THE
OPERATIONS AFFAIRS. BUT BELIEVE
THAT AS IT'S BEEN STATED BEFORE
ALL FARES HAVE BEEN SUFFERING
AS A RESULT A COVERT- AND
THEREFORE OPERATIONAL MONEY
SHOULD BE DISTRIBUTED TO
DISTRICT ASSOCIATIONS AS WELL
COUNTY. IN FACT HISTORICALLY
WHENEVER THERE'S BEEN MONEY
APPROPRIATED FOR OPERATIONS IT
HAS BEEN APPROPRIATE IS ALL
FAIRS AND I POINT- YOU TO
SPECIFICALLY BUSINESS AND
PROFESSIONS CODE ONE NINE TWO
SIX TWO ZERO THAT SPECIFICALLY
PROHIBIT THE ALLOCATION. BASED
ON GOVERNANCE STRUCTURE WHEN IT
COMES TO- MONIES FOR AFFAIRS. I
WOULD ALSO LIKE TO POINT OUT
THAT THE DEPARTMENT OF GENERAL
SERVICES IT HAS AN INVENTORY OF
THIS PROPERTY. I THINK THAT-
THEY'VE DONE AN INVENTORY OF
STATE AFFILIATED FAIRGROUNDS IN
THE PAST AND WE MAY WANT TO
REVISIT THAT BEFORE
APPROPRIATING THREE MILLION
DOLLARS- FOR THE DEPARTMENT FOR
THIS PURPOSE. SECOND ISSUE-
ISSUE FIFTEEN WITH DPR- WE ARE
CONCERNED IN OPPOSED TO THE
TIERED ASSESSMENT- THE
DEPARTMENT. BUDGET HAS GROWN BY
15% LAST FIVE YEARS- THIS WILL
GIVE ANOTHER 40% INCREASE OVER
FOUR YEARS. HI IF THERE ARE
STRUCTURAL DEFICIT ISSUES TO BE
ADDRESSED WE ARE INTERESTED IN
TALKING ABOUT THOSE BUT BELIEVE
THAT THE- CURED APPROACHES- THE
WRONG APPROACH AT THIS TIME.
FINALLY IN PART BE- ISSUE TOO I
WANT TO JUST ECHO THE COMMENTS
OF THE HAMLET CARE CARE.
QUALITY DISTRICT AS WELL AS
CAPCO- THAT OUR AGRICULTURAL
CLIENTS ARE IN SUPPORT OF THE
EXTENSION OF AB EIGHT- IN
PARTICULAR THE CARL MOYER FUNDS
WHICH HAVE BEEN USED IN THE SAN
JOAQUIN VALLEY TO. EXCHANGE
DIESEL ENGINES AND AGRICULTURAL
EQUIPMENT AND REDUCE AIR
QUALITY ISSUES SIGNIFICANTLY
THANK YOU. QNX WE'LL GO TO LINE
THIRTY THREE ZERO PLEASE GO
AHEAD. GOOD MORNING AND THANK
YOU MISTER CHAIR IN THE MEMBERS
OF THE COMMITTEE MY NAME IS
LAURIE KING AND THE DEPUTY
MANAGER THE BIG FRESNO FAIR
FRESNO COUNTY. I'M CALLING
REGARDING ITEM NUMBER EIGHT
FIVE SEVEN ZERO UNDER THE CDS
THEY ISSUED NUMBER ELEVEN AND I
AM IN FULL SUPPORT OF THE
GOVERNOR'S BUDGET FOR THE
NETWORK OF CALIFORNIA FAIRS THE
SEVENTY SEVEN CALIFORNIA THERE
ARE THE LIFELINE OF EACH
COMMUNITY IN OUR GREAT STATE
FAIRGROUNDS SERVE THE
COMMUNITIES WE RESIDED. AT THE
BIG FRESNO FAIR WITH OPENED OUR
DOORS. TO BE. WHILE TYLER AND
BACK. CENTERS INCLUDING THE
DEVASTATING CREEK FIRE THIS
YEAR SERVED AS THE DISTRIBUTION
CENTERS. AND BEING CRITICAL IN
OUR COMMUNITY HELLO AT
INDOCTRINATION. EVERY FAIR IN
CALIFORNIA'S DRUG. IT REVENUE
AND FOLLOW ALL STATE GUIDELINES
WE'VE ALL LOST YEAH AM FOR THE
PRIME EXAMPLE OF TRYING TO DO
MORE WITH LESS. THE BAD AND ALL
FARES IN CALIFORNIA WE NEED
YOUR ASSISTANCE AND NEED THE
MONEY TO MAKE THE CALIFORNIA
AFFAIRS NETWORK ALL AND MAKE US.
DR PLEASE HELP CALIFORNIA THANK
WITH FUNDING FOR ALL WHEN YOU
VOTE ON THE MEASURE YEAH. THANK
YOU THE EX. BLOODLINE SEVEN
THREE ONE SEVEN PLEASE GO AHEAD.
THANK YOU CHAIRED MEMBERS MY
NAME IS JULIE JORDAN WITH
LEADERSHIP COUNSEL FOR JUSTICE
AND ACCOUNTABILITY ALSO
COMMENTING ON BEHALF OF CENTRAL
CALIFORNIA ENVIRONMENTAL
JUSTICE NETWORK AND PRINTER
EIGHTY. NINE ISSUE FIFTEEN WE
ARE PLEASED WITH THE STATE'S
SUPPORT FOR THE TRANSITION AWAY
FROM HARMFUL PESTICIDES IN
SPORTS OR GENERATIVE
AGRICULTURE. THOSE RISK STATES
LET PESTICIDE KNOWN. THE
FOURTEENTH THE SUN FOR STRAY
AND- THERE MY- NEAR ENGAGEMENT
ENTRY. FARMERS AGRA. PRACTICES
THAT PROTECT PEOPLE AND
BIODIVERSITY AND WE LOOK-FORWARD TO WORKING WITH THE
LEGISLATURE AND ADMINISTRATION
TO APPROVE IT WILL BE THAT
MEANINGFUL INCLUDE DIRECT
COMMUNITY PROTECTION. REQUIRED
TO MITIGATE EXPOSURE FOR THOSE
IMPACTED BY TESTIFIED AT HOME
OR AT WORK FOR
DISPROPORTIONATELY LOW INCOME
COMMUNITIES OF COLOR. AND IF
THE LONG OVERDUE. LASTLY WE
OPPOSE ANY FUNDING THAT
DIRECTLY OR INDIRECTLY SUPPORT
I GESTURES OR DAIRYBIOGAS
PRODUCTION IN THE STATE'S
BUDGET INCLUDING WITHIN THE
PROPOSED. CLIMATE CATALYST MON
SUN. THANK YOU. THANK YOU NOW.
GO TO LINE TWENTY SIX TWO SIX.
THE MORNING THANK YOU WHERE AND
THAT MEMBERS OF THE COMMITTEE
MY NAME IS BECKY BAILEY FINDLEY
REPRESENTING THE WESTERN FAIRS
ASSOCIATION AND CALIFORNIA
FAIRS IN- NETWORK I'M CALLING
IN SUPPORT OF THE APPROPRIATION
AT IN THE GOVERNOR'S BUDGET FOR
THE FAIR NETWORK AND FURTHER
SUPPORT THE SENATOR'S COMMENT.
THAT THIS FUNDING BE AVAILABLE
TO THE ENTIRE NETWORK OF
CALIFORNIANS BEARS.
HISTORICALLY APPROPRIATIONS
FROM THE STATE FOR OPERATIONAL
NEEDS HAVE BEEN MADE TO ALL
FAIR REGARDLESS OF GOVERNANCE
STRUCTURES. AND AS COMMITTEE
MEMBERS HAVE PREVIOUSLY STATED
IN THE FACE OF CRISIS OR
EMERGENCY ALL FAIR GROUNDS ARE
IMMEDIATELY ACTIVATED. THOSE IN
CRISIS DON'T WORRY ABOUT
WHETHER IT IS A COUNTY FAIR OR
CITRUS FRUIT. A STATE AFFILIATE
OF FAIR OR ACTUALLY THE STATE
VERY SELF. FARES ARE EQUAL
OPPORTUNITY COMMUNITY BASED
CENTERS THAT PROVIDE COMMUNITY
BUILDING SOCIAL WELL BEING
ECONOMIC STIMULUS AND OUR
SOURCES FOR EMERGENCY RESPONSE
BUT PEOPLE AND ANIMALS. ALL.
SHARES HAVE BEEN HIT HARD.
THANK YOU NECKS IN. DID YOU
HAVE SOMETHING OUT OF LINE
TWENTY NINE. TWO NINE FISCAL.
GOOD MORNING MR CHAIRMAN AND
MEMBERS OF THE COMMITTEE MY
FIRST BILL BABBITT AND I'VE
BEEN A MEMBER OF THE DOWNEY POP
COUNTY FAIR BOARD FOR THE PAST
TWENTY YEARS ALSO THE PRESIDENT
OF THE CALIFORNIA POULTRY
FEDERATION AND I'M CALLING-
TODAY AND LISTENING TO YOUR
GREAT COMMENTS ABOUT SUPPORTING
THE OPERATION IN THE GOVERNOR'S
BUDGET FOR THE FAIR NETWORK ONE
K. GOT IT MOST PEOPLE I'VE MET
IF YOU THINK THE MONEY SHOULD
BE AVAILABLE TO THE ENTIRE
NETWORK AFFAIRS. AND IT IN THE
PAST- PREPARATIONS FROM THE
STATE PROP RACIAL NEEDS HAVE
BEEN USED FOR ALL FARED
REGARDLESS OF THEIR STRUCTURE
ALTHOUGH THERE'S BEEN THAT
WOULD HAVE BEEN HARD BY CODE
BUT I CAN TELL YOU ARE BEARISH
ET IN DOUBT THAT THAT THEY ARE
EVIL ARE WE NEED ASSISTANCE
WITH OUR OPERATIONAL IF I'VE
NEVER SEEN IT IN MY TWENTY SIX
YEARS. THE WORD WHAT WE'RE
DEALING WITH THE DAY WE HAVE A
HOST YOU FOR EXAMPLE AT IN THE
FIRES IMPLIED WE CONTINUED TO
DO ARE YOU READY HERBED EVEN.
WITH A VERY VERY SMALL YEAH.
JAI YOUR SUPPORT IF YOU AND WE
LOOK FOR. WORKING YOU IN A-
THANK YOU FOR. THANK YOU EX.
BLIND'S. SEVENTY ONE SEVEN ONE.
GOOD MORNING JERRY MEMBERS
UNION OF CONCERNED SCIENTISTS
FIRST A GREAT TO SEE THE BUDGET
PRIORITIZE ELECTRIC VEHICLES
ARE **** IDIOT NEED FOR THE
STATE TO CONTINUE TO ACCELERATE
A RESPONSE TO THE ONGOING
CLIMATE EMERGENCY BEGAN ITEM
NUMBER TWO WE BELIEVE THAT
THEIR MISSION AT NICKEL BUDGET
APPROPRIATELY PRIORITIZES
NEEDED TO BUILD OUT THAT
INFRASTRUCTURE I THINK YOU'RE
FUTURE HE PROCEEDS COLLECTED
FOR THIS EASY YOU CAN
TRANSPORTATION PROGRAM
PREVIOUSLY AUTHORIZED BY EIGHTY
ONE NINETEEN EIGHTY EIGHT.
WHICH OPERATED FOR EIGHTY ONE
NINETEEN EIGHTY EIGHT
REAUTHORIZATION OTHER CLEAN
TRANSPORTATION PROGRAM AN AIR
QUALITY IMPROVEMENT PROGRAM I
DO NOT KNOW CONTINUE PUBLIC
SUPPORT FOR CHARTERED A PLANE
THAT IS ESSENTIAL TO MEDIA
STATE THAT AIR QUALITY AND
CLIMATE NEEDS YOU SEE I THOUGHT
YOU SEE I ALSO SUPPORT THE
GOVERNOR'S REQUEST TO DIRECT
THE HUNDRED FIFTY MILLION FOR
PASSENGER VEHICLE EQUITY
PROJECTS SUCH AS GREEN CARD FOR
ALL WHICH IMPORTANTLY FOCUSES
ON LOW INCOME BUYERS AND THE
USED CAR MARKET. LOOK FOR TO
WORKING WITH YOU. THROUGHOUT
THE DAY ARE THANK YOU. THANK
YOU THE EX. WE'RE GONNA LINE
FOR NINE FOUR NINE. GOOD
MORNING MISS CHAIRMAN OF THE
COMMITTEE MY NAME IS PATRICK
I'D BEEN THEM HE OPENED ABOUT A
COUNTY FAIRGROUNDS AND
BEAUTIFUL GRASS VALLEY PROBABLY
LOCATED THE- PERSON AT.
TESTIFYING TODAY ON ISSUE
ELEVEN IN SUPPORT OF THE
APPROPRIATION OF THE GOVERNOR'S
BUDGET FOR THE NETWORK OF
CALIFORNIA FAIR. MARCH OF LAST
YEAR THAT ABOUT A COUNTY
FAIRGROUNDS HAS BEEN LARGELY
CLOSE WITHIN HAVING AMPLE ARE
ANNUAL AFFAIRS THE DRAFT HORSE
CLASSIC IN THE COUNTRY
CHRISTMAS FAIR. NEVER MIND
HUNDRED. GIVEN STANFORD WILL
CONTINUE TO SERVE OUR COMMUNITY
INCLUDING OF THE CAL FIRE
COMMAND CENTER AND ANIMAL
EVACUATION CENTER DURING DON'T
FIRE. LOCATION FOR TRAVEL
TRAILERS SERVING THOSE WITH
COBRA PUMA QUARANTINE OF THE
VOTING ELECTION CENTER AND THE
HOME TO UNIQUE PARTNERSHIP
BETWEEN THE VATICAN COUNTY
LOCAL SCHOOLS IN THE NONPROFIT
THE SERVER THE DISTANCE
LEARNING HUB FOR STUDENTS.
WITHOUT INTERNET ACCESS AT HOME.
AND THEN I GONNA PUSH AGREES.
OF FINANCE HAVE A- FOR PROGRAM.
A COMPUTER IS YEAH FOR DISTRICT
BACK. ASSOCIATION URGING THAT
THE FUNDING BE MADE AVAILABLE
TO THE ENTIRE. NETWORK THE AS
COUNTY A NONPROFIT THERE'S THE
TRUTH THERE'S A MISTAKE FARE.
IRRESPECTIVE OF THEIR SIZE OUR
GOVERNANCE STRUCTURE BEARS ARE
IMPORTANT TO THEIR COMMUNITIES
THE STATE DEPARTMENT
RESPONSIBLE FROM OPERATORS
NEED. TO SURVIVE THANK YOU.
THANK YOU NEXT. WE'LL GO TO
LINE SIX NINE SIXTY NINE. GOOD
MORNING CHAIRMAN MY COUNTY AND
SUBCOMMITTEE MEMBERS I AM
SPEAKING ON ITEM EIGHT FIVE
SEVEN ZERO CALIFORNIA
DEPARTMENT OF FOOD AND
AGRICULTURE ISSUE NUMBER ELEVEN
MY NAME IS REBECCA DESMOND I AM
A FORMER FAIRGROUNDS MANAGER
FORMER DIRECTOR OF THE DIVISION
OF FAIRS AND EXPOSITIONS THAT
CDFA AND I'M CURRENTLY THE
EXECUTIVE DIRECTOR OF THE
CALIFORNIA FAIR SERVICES
MCCARTY. I AM SUPPORT IN
SUPPORT OF THE APPROPRIATION
FOR THE FAIRGROUNDS IN THE
GOVERNOR'S BUDGET AS PREVIOUSLY
MENTIONED IT IS VERY IMPORTANT
THAT THE FUNDS BE ALLOCATED TO
ALL CALIFORNIA FAIRGROUNDS AND
NOT JUST STATE AFFILIATED
FAIRGROUND. ALL FAIR GROUNDS
THE DAMAGE FINANCIALLY. DUE TO
THE CORONA VIRUS ENDEMIC.
GROUNDS ARE THE ABILITY CALLED
IN OF FROM. EVACUEE TO
ASSISTING THE STATE IN THE
BATTLE AGAINST KOBE NINETEEN.
AND IT'S SANDERS MCGUIRE AND
DOLLY RECOGNIZED EARLIER THE
GOVERNOR. OF THE FAIRGROUNDS IS
NOT AN ISSUE WHEN IT IS CALLED
INTO SERVICE. ENTIRE NETWORK OF
CALIFORNIA AFFAIRS IS IN NEED
OF ASSISTANCE IT DIVIDE. AND
CONTINUE TO BE THE CRITICAL.
COMMUNITY AFTER THAT THEY ARE
THANK YOU. THANK YOU MAX. WILL
CLIMB NUMBER FIFTY TWO FIVE TWO
YOUR LINE IS OPEN. AFTERNOON
MISTER CHAIRMAN BIRTH TAYLOR
OCEAN OF THE CALGARY BERNERO
REGARDING ISSUE NUMBER CAN YOU
GREEN WITH AN ACQUIRED COMMENT
THAT WITHOUT A REVENUE
GENERATOR. ON ITS- YOU ARE
MANAGEMENT. ARE SMALL SIDE
BERRY AND LYFT OPERATIONS BONTA
BURKE AND FELL WITH ONE. THAT
WE ASK THAT THE COMMITTEE
CONSIDER STANDALONE FUNDING FOR
METHANE EMISSION REDUCTION
PROJECT. I'M ON ISSUE WELL WE
ALSO AGREE WITH SECRETARY RAFI
SECRETARY DOLLARS THAT
REGULATORY COMPLIANCE LOOK AT
THE TOP OF THE LARGEST. THAT
ARE NEW TO GET ON MADE FARMERS.
SO AND WE BELIEVE THAT THAT
DIDN'T WORK REFLECT AN ACROSS
AGENCIES WITH THAT CONFLICT IS
ENCOURAGING OUR STAFF. FOR ALL
WHO'S THE ON GOING AND GOING
AND PUTTING UP OPPOSING ISSUE
THIRTEEN FOR THE STATE WATER IN
ENHANCEMENT PROGRAM FINALLY IN
THE INTEREST OF TIME WE ECHO
THE COMMENTS AND CONCERNS OF
OUR COLLEAGUES. IN OPPOSITION
ISSUE FIFTEENTH IT'S HARD FOR
THE. DISCUSSION THANK YOU.
THANK YOU NET. LINE THIRTY ONE
THREE YOUR LINE IS A. YOUR
MOORLACH HOUSE HE MEMBERS OF
THE COMMITTEE MY NAME IS STACY
RHIANNA AND I AND THE DEPUTY
MANAGER AT THE TWENTY FIRST
DISTRICT AGRICULTURAL
ASSOCIATION BIG FRESNO FAIR.
I'M CALLING IN SUPPORT OF THE
GOVERNOR'S BUDGET FOR THE
NETWORK OF CALIFORNIA FAIR.
CALIFORNIA FAIRS ARE TRULY A
NETWORK AND WE STAND TOGETHER
READY TO SERVE OUR STATE AND
OUR COMMUNITY AT A MOMENT'S
NOTICE. ALL OF THAT. AT THE BIG
FRESNO FAIR IN TWENTY TWENTY WE
OPENED OUR DOORS TO WILDFIRE
EVACUATION TO DISTRIBUTION OF
THE TESTING AND NOW CODE BACK
THE NATION AS THE MAJORITY OF
THE OTHER FAIR TAP. WE HAVE ALL
EXPERIENCED EXTREME LOSS IN
REVENUE AND STAFFING DUE TO THE
PANDEMIC AND THE INABILITY TO
CONDUCT MUCH IF ANY BUSINESS AT
ALL. TO THAT END WE ALL NEED
ASSISTANCE IF WE HAVE ANY
CHANCE TO SURVIVE. I AM IN FULL
SUPPORT OF MAKING THE MONEY
AVAILABLE TO THE ENTIRE NETWORK
OF CALIFORNIA AFFAIRS
REGARDLESS OF THEIR GOVERNMENT
STRUCTURE PLEASE HELP STATE
CALIFORNIA FAIR BY INCLUDING
FUNDING FOR ALL WHEN YOU VOTE
ON THIS MEASURE THANK. YOU
THANK YOU AN EX. NEXT DEADLINE
SEVENTY NINE. SEVEN NINE PLEASE
GO AHEAD. GOOD MORNING JAMIE
MINOR ON BEHALF OF HIV ANIMAL
HEALTH INSTITUTE ARE WE MUCH
RESPECT WE OPPOSE THE MEL
PACKED IF YOU SEE AN EXTRA
FIFTEEN PER THAT A REASONABLE
DOUBT I THINK CA AND CHEMICAL
INDUSTRY COUNCIL. ALSO ON
BEHALF OF THE CALIFORNIA
VERSION BEING THE MAN OF
MANAGEMENT COUNCIL RELATED TO
AN AGENDA PART B. ITEM THREE ON
AB EIGHT FORTY ONE
IMPLEMENTATION I WE DO HAVE
SIGNIFICANT CONCERNS OVER
FUTURE ENERGY EFFICIENCY BUDGET
DECLINING WHICH MAY AFFECT BOTH
COR I OWE YOU ENERGY EFFICIENCY
PROGRAMS AS WELL AS EASY EIGHTY
FOUR EIGHT FOUR ONE PROGRAM
FUNDING- A RECENT ADVICE LETTER
FILING SHOWS WHAT LOOKS LIKE
THE TICKET CUTS TO ENERGY
EFFICIENCY FUNDS IN TWENTY
TWENTY TO TWENTY THREE FROM
THAT INVESTOR OWNED UTILITIES.
SO WHILE WE FULLY WITH THE
GOALS OF EIGHTY EIGHT FORTY ONE
THE DECREASE IN ENERGY
EFFICIENCY. FUNDING FOR PROJECT
YOU CAN. THANK YOU SO MUCH.
THANK YOU. LINE FORTY TWO OR
TWO YOUR LINE IS OPEN. THANK
YOU KAREN NUMBER I'M ALISON
JOHNSON AN ATTORNEY WITH THE
NATURAL RESOURCES DEFENSE
COUNCIL ALSO COMMENTING ON
BEHALF OF CENTER FOR FIFTY
EIGHTY AND ENVIRONMENT
CALIFORNIA ON ISSUE FIFTEEN THE
TRANSITION TO SAFER WITH THE
LOW COST MANAGEMENT. THE
PROPOSAL IS LONG OVERDUE A
STRONGLY SUPPORT A FEEDING AND
HEARING THE PESTICIDE HEALTHY
AND WE REQUEST LANGUAGE IN THE
BUDGET TO DIRECT FUNDS TO FOUR
TOP PRIORITIES AT THE FEDERALLY
FUNDED FOR COMMUNITIES AND
FARMWORKERS. UPDATED HERE
MONITORING PROGRAMS TO HELP
FARMERS AND FARMWORKERS MANAGED
BY FAITHFULLY AND ECOSYSTEM
MONITORING PROGRAM TO ASSESS
AND PROTECT BIODIVERSITY. I'D
ALSO LIKE TO EMPHASIZE THIS
ENOUGH THE PROPOSAL AND THE
SPECIFICS YOU WOULD LIKE TO SEE
ADDRESSED COUNTY APPROVED BY A
MAJORITY VOTE THIS IS A SIMPLE
REGULATORY FEE INCREASE THAT
FUND THE COMPREHENSIVE PROGRAMS
AND MANAGE THE MANY AND COSTLY
BURDENS ON THE FATE. ALL OF
THEM TESTIFIED YOU BOTH THE
PLAIN LANGUAGE OF OCT TWENTY
SIX AND THE CASE LAW
INTERPRETING IT ALLOWED TO TYPE
OF LEGISLATION FOR FORWARD
WITHOUT A TWO THIRDS VOTE.
THANK YOU. THANK YOU. NECKS
THANK WE HAVE LONG EIGHTY EIGHT
ONE LINE IS OPEN. I HATE THE
TEACHER MEMBERS BILL AND JACK
ON BEHALF OF CALPERS. WE WILL
EXPRESS OUR STRONG SUPPORT FOR
THE GOVERNOR'S PROPOSED BUDGET
WITH WHICH INVEST ONE POINT
FIVE BILLION IMMEDIATE FUNDING
FOR CLEAN TRANSPORTATION SECTOR
INCLUDING THE TWO HUNDRED FORTY
MILLION AND EARLY ACTION. WE
ARE PECIALLY CONCERNED WITH
THE LEGISLATOR ACTING ON THE
EARLY ACTION BUDGET APPROPRIATE
GDR AFTER THE CURRENT FISCAL
YEAR BECAUSE THIS WASN'T DONE
LAST YEAR. ALSO MOST CLEAN
VEHICLE PROGRAMS HAVE BEEN
WITHOUT FUNDING FOR OVER
EIGHTEEN MONTHS OTHERS HAVE RUN
THROUGH ONE TIME FUNDING AND
NEED APPROPRIATIONS TO CONTINUE.
WHILE WE ARE SUPPORTIVE OF THE
PROPOSED BUDGET WE URGE THAT
THAT C. B. R. P. BE RESTORED IN
THE BUDGET. IT'S A CRITICAL
PROGRAM THAT INCREASES MEDIUM
AND LOW INCOME FAMILIES AND WE
EXPECT THE BILITY DID THAT.
ADDITIONALLY ON BEHALF OF THE
ELECTRIC VEHICLE CHARGING
ASSOCIATION. SIMILAR TO CAL
STAR WHEN IT'S SUPPORT THAT.
THE GOVERNOR'S PROPOSED BUDGET.
ON IT WE SUPPORT AND WE
STRONGLY SUPPORT THE
ADMINISTRATION'S PROPOSAL TO RE
AUTHORIZE EXTENDED SECURITIZED
THE CLEAN TRANSPORTATION
PROGRAM. UNTIL TWENTY FORTY
SIX. THIS PROPOSAL BY THE
CRITIC CRITICAL ROLE IN JUMP
STARTING THE ELECTRIC VEHICLE
CHARGING MARKET WILL REMAIN
CRITICAL TO HELPING INDUSTRY
CHIEF ECONOMIST AT YALE NEEDED
TO CHANGE INFRASTRUCTURE MORE
AFFORDABLE AND ACCESSIBLE TO
CALIFORNIANS AND IT'S- KEEPING
STATEWIDE DEPLOYMENT GOALS. WE
LOOK FORWARD TO WORKING WITH
THE ADMINISTRATION. LEGISLATOR
ON THE PROPOSAL THANK YOU.
THANK YOU. BY EIGHTY TWO EIGHTY
TWO THE PROVIDERS OF. HELLO
SENATE THEY'LL BE ON THE
CALIFORNIA ADVOCATES THE OTHER
DOUBLE FOR I'M GONNA GO THROUGH
A DIFFERENT. LIST OF. ALL
DIFFERENT- ISSUE THAT WE FOR.
OR AFTER ABOUT. WHAT TO THIS ON
BEHALF OF THE BIGGEST. DOES
YOUR COMPANY FARMERS AND HELP
PREVENT THE WE- TURLOCK ANIMAL.
LABORATORY THAT THE- TO PROVIDE.
THE NOW BE SPREAD IN THE-
AREN'T YOU HAVE OF THE SAME AS
WELL BE ON THE INDUSTRY WE
SUPPORT THE NEEDLE STATION.
THAT PORT WE FOR BRAND WELL I
THINK IT SOMETHING THAT'S NOT
LIKE A THEY HELP BROAD FOR THE
BY BILL- AND THAT THEREFORE ON
BEHALF OF THE EIGHT COKE AND-
YEAH WE SUPPORT OUT OF- REPORT
OF. WHICH ALIGNED WITH YOUR
EGGMAN HOME. YES THEY HAVE DONE
WE CAN DO THAT IT IN ADDITION
WE APPRECIATE THE CALL ARE MADE
BY COMMITTEE THAT ABOUT- I. G.
BUDIG. THAT IS SOMETHING WE
NEED TO MOVE FORWARD. YOUR BILL
ON BEHALF OF PEARS THURSDAY THE
THREE FUNDING A MAN I WOULD
LIKE TO OUR CAR. MUGGER
CULTURAL GOVERNMENT AND ALL
BEAR. ON THE- WITH- COVER SUCH
A- THE WEEK OF. WIDER GROWERS
WATER BURDEN THE NCAA. I'M A D.
W. R. THE PASSED BY THE. THIS
TIME THE PROPOSAL- NEED
ADDITIONAL WORK OR RAISING
CONCERNS. WITH THAT- I
APPRECIATE YOUR TIME. THANK YOU
NEXT. WE'LL GO TO LINE EIGHT
THREE EIGHTY THREE PLEASE GO
AHEAD. GOOD MORNING THANK YOU
TERRA COFFEE IN MEMBERS OF THE
COMMITTEE STEVEN MYERS ON
BEHALF OF CALTRANS COMMENTING
ON PART BE ISSUE TO THE- LOCAL.
GOVERNMENTS PROVIDES RIDE SHARE
VANS INDIVIDUALS. INCLUDING
OVER TWO HUNDRED BANDS FOR
FARMWORKERS HOW MAY I HELP SOME
OF OUR HARDEST HIT WORKERS GET
THE STATE. WORK EQUALLY AND
CLEANLY WITH SIGNIFICANT
SAVINGS A MONTH. ALL IN ORDER
TO CONTINUE OUR SERVICES ACROSS
THE STATE IT IS CRITICAL THAT
OUR PROGRAM RECEIVED FUNDING
FOR IN U. D. EVEY ADOPTION
THROUGH THE EARLY ACTION ITEM.
THANK YOU SO MUCH. THANK YOU
NEXT. WELL I AM SEVENTY SEVEN
YOUR LINE IS OPEN SEVEN SEVEN
THANK YOU MISTER CHAIR OF
MINING STEVEN JIMENEZ ON A
MANAGER CLEANER ADVOCACY WITH
AMERICAN LUNG ASSOCIATION
CALLING IN REGARDS TO PARTY
ISSUE TO. SUPPORT THE
GOVERNOR'S PROPOSAL TO
ALLOCATED EUROPE FUNDING TO.
THE MISSION PROGRAM. INCLUDING
TWO HUNDRED FIFTEEN MILLION
REFUGEES THERE MUST TRUST
BUTTON FOR THE GOVERNMENT AND A.
HUNDRED OKAY WE'LL TAKE THAT AS
A SUPPORT FOR ISSUE NUMBER TWO
PART BEAT NEXT MODERATOR. WILL
LINE NINE ONE YOUR LINE IS OPEN
NINETY ONE. THANK YOU MR
CHAIRMAN MEMBERS OF THE
SUBCOMMITTEE MY NAME IS KARLEY
MORE AND ON THE INTERMEDIATE
THE TWENTY SECOND DISTRICT
AGRICULTURAL ASSOCIATION DELMAR
FAIRGROUNDS HOME OF THE SAN
DIEGO COUNTY FAIR AND I'M
COMMENTING ON PART A ITEM EIGHT
FIVE SEVEN ZERO ISSUE ELEVEN
FAIRGROUNDS OPERATIONAL SUPPORT
AND DEFERRED MAINTENANCE. ON
BEHALF OF MY BOARD OF DIRECTORS
WERE IN SUPPORT OF THE
PREPARATION THE GOVERNOR'S
pWITH CAVIAR. NEXT YEAR'S MONEY
SHOULD BE MADE AVAILABLE TO THE
ENTIRE NETWORK OF CALIFORNIA
FAIRGROUNDS AND THAT THE
BALANCE OF THE CURRENT FISCAL
YEAR FUNDS MADE AVAILABLE NOW
TO SUPPORT OPERATIONAL EXPENSES
TO THOSE THAT CONTINUE TO
STRUGGLE FINANCIALLY FOLLOWING
LAYOFFS. AND MAY NOT BE ABLE TO
MAKE IT THROUGH TO THE NEXT
BUDGET CYCLE. ALL FARES IN THE
NETWORK HAVE BEEN HIT HARD BY
COBIT. NEITHER SIDES NOR
GOVERNANCE MODEL DETERMINE DOES
IMPACT. AS RECENT HISTORY HAS
SHOWN US CALIFORNIA'S ENTIRE
NETWORK OF PROGRAMS ARE VITAL
TO THE STATE'S EMERGENCY
RESPONSE PLANS AND THE CURRENT
PANDEMIC IS NO EXCEPTION. HERE
IN SAN DIEGO COUNTY OUR
FAIRGROUNDS IS THE MULTIPLE
WILDFIRE EVACUATIONS. COVERED
NINETEEN HAD. DISTRIBUTION AND
CURRENTLY OF VACCINATIONS. HM
WE'D LIKE ALL FAIRGROUNDS ARE
INDISPENSABLE COMMUNITY
RESOURCE THE- REVIVAL OF ALL
FAIR GROUNDS IS AFFECT. THE
RECOVERY PLAN. VERY MEDIA AND
PROPER POSTED NEEDS AT THE
NETWORK HAS ANY CHANCE
PROVIDING. THE PLEASE MAKE
CERTAIN ALL FAIRGROUNDS THAT
CHANCE WOULD YOU VOTE ON THE
MEASURE INCLUDING SURVIVAL
THANK. THANK YOU NEXT. GO TO
LINE EIGHTY EIGHT EIGHT EIGHT
PLEASE GO AHEAD. GOOD MORNING
MR KERRIGAN MANY MEMBERS.
SECOND ONE AT REPRESENTING THE
BLUEGREEN ALLIANCE OF
CALIFORNIANS SPEAK NOT TOO LATE
FOR THE DAY. VEHICLE BUILDING A
LINE TO THE NETWORK ORGANIZED
LABOR ENVIRONMENTAL AND
COMMUNITY ORGANIZATIONS
WORKING. A JOB. BAYERN
MOVIELINE SUPPORTS THE
GOVERNOR'S PROPOSAL THAT
ARGUMENT BUT WE NEVER EQUITY
PROGRAMS AND CLEAN HEAVY AND
MEDIUM DUTY TRUCK INVESTMENTS
HOWEVER WE FEEL IT IS IMPORTANT
THE LEGISLATURE WITH THEIR
COMMITMENT TO ENSURE THE JOBS
FUNDED BY THESE PROGRAMS. WILL
JOBS FOR BOTH THE COMPANY. THE
LEGISLATURE CAN AND SHOULD
ENCOURAGE IMPROVEMENTS AND JOB
QUALITY TO INDUSTRIES THAT THE
COMPANY WIDE WAGE AND BENEFITS
UNDER. THE CHEST PREVAILING
LIVING AND MINIMUM WAGES. HILLS
REQUIREMENTS ENFORCEMENT OF ALL
LABOR AND EMPLOYMENT. BUT
IMPROPER CLASSIFICATION OF
EMPLOYEES AND COLLECTIVE
BARGAINING RIGHTS. IT JUST
BENEFITS WORKING CONDITIONS AND
CAREER LADDERS. FIRST WHICH IN
TURN LEAD TO BETTER DESIGN
INSTALLATION OPERATION. THANK
THANK YOU NEXT. MY. NINETY
SEVEN NINE SEVEN ONE. THANK YOU
THANK YOU- WHY CALCIUM MEMBERS
OF THE BUDGET DIFFICULT REVIEW
COMMITTEE I AM SPEAKING TODAY
ON THE FAIRGROUNDS OPERATIONAL
SUPPORT BIRDS MAKE NESTS ARE A
ITEM EIGHTY FIVE SEVENTY EIGHT
YOU SHOW LOVE IT. MY NAME IS
BECKY BARTLING AND I AM THE CEO
OF THE CINEMA COUNTY
FAIRGROUNDS AT THE COUNTY FAIR
WHO IS SELF SUPPORTING SOLELY
THROUGH THE ANNUAL FAIR AND
INTERNET THEN. AT A FAIRLY THAT
HAS. FOR FIRE. ONE WHAT EXACTLY
LICENSE IN JUST THE PAST FIVE
YEARS. AND HAVE BEEN HOUSING CO
THE TESTING COVERED
VACCINATIONS AND HOUSING FOR
HOMELESS. OR AT RISK OF COVERT.
I ENCOURAGE YOUR SUPPORT IN
MAKING THE FUNDING AVAILABLE TO
ALL THE NETWORK OF CALIFORNIA.
AS WE HAVE ALL BEEN SEVERELY
IMPACTED FINANCIALLY BY THE
CANCELLATION OF OUR FARES AN
INSTRUMENT THAT YOU DID IT AND
THERE MIGHT. CALIFORNIA ANSWER
THE CALL TO OPEN AND HOUSE
PEOPLE ANIMALS AND THOUSANDS OF
STATE CAL FIRE TEAMS DURING
WILDFIRES. AND OTHER EMERGENCY
EVACUATION. THIS FUNDING WILL
GO A LONG WAY BOARDING THE
EFFORT AS WELL AS PROVIDE
NEEDED FUNDING FOR OPERATIONAL
SUPPORT AND IMPROVEMENTS THAT
WILL SUPPORT EMERGING EMERGENCY
EVACUATIONS. AND HELP ALL
CALIFORNIA BEARS. A VIABLE AS
COUNTY AND. ASSETS THANK YOU.
THANK YOU ZACKS. MY NINETY
EIGHT NINE EIGHT PLEASE GO
AHEAD. MR CHAIRMAN MEMBERS OF
THE COMMITTEE THANK YOU FOR
TAKING THE TIME TODAY TO
ADDRESS THE GOVERNOR'S PROPOSAL
FOR FUNDING FOR THE CALIFORNIA
FAIRGROUNDS NETWORK ANY TOM
MITCHELL MY AND THE CEO THE
MADERA DISTRICT FAIR GROUNDS IS
ALSO KNOWN AS THE TWENTY ONE
EIGHT DISTRICT AGRICULTURAL
ASSOCIATION. I WOULD LIKE TO
EXPRESS MY SUPPORT OF THIS
APPROPRIATION THE GOVERNOR'S
BUDGET. OF THESE FUNDS SHOULD
BE MADE AVAILABLE TO ALL
CALIFORNIA FAIRS NOT JUST THE
DISTRICT I GUESS SOLUTIONS AND
STATE FAIR I UNDERSTAND THAT
THERE IS CONCERN FOR THE
LIABILITY THE DA'S CREATE IN
THAT WE ARE STATE AGENCIES
HOWEVER. AND DISCUSS BY
COMMITTEE MEMBERS IMPORTANCE OF
CALIFORNIA AFFAIRS INTERSTATE
EXTENDS FAR BEYOND GOVERNMENT
STRUCTURE AS ALL CALIFORNIA
FAIR SHARE OF THE UNITIES HAVE
BEEN DEEPLY AFFECTED BY THE
PANDEMIC. I WOULD LIKE TO SHARE
THE MEASURE FOR GROUND HAS
SERVING OUR COMMUNITY
THROUGHOUT THE PANDEMIC BY
WRITING SPACE LEGISLATURE
PERSPECTIVE IT IS BEING CO
PROTESTING THE DISTRIBUTIONS
SCHOOL SUPPLY DISTRIBUTION P.
P. E. DISTRIBUTION AND YOUR
RECENT NOTIFIED THAT MADERA
COUNTY WILL BE. OPENING A
VACCINATION SITE HERE ON. YOUR
MOBILE AS THE SITE FOR CO THAT
AFFECTED HOME HOUSING EARLY IN
THE YEAR. REQUEST FOR ANSWER
ALONGSIDE. FRESNO FOR AND THE
STRUCTURE AFFAIR IN WE MADE OUR
READY IN A BILL TO US WITH THE
BACK. BUT BOTH ANIMALS AND WILL
AFFECTED BY THE CREEK FIRE.
WHICH DISPLACED REYES BOTH
FRESNO AND MADERA. THE GOVERNOR
AND COMMITTEE HAVE RECOGNIZED
IMPORTANCE CALIFORNIA. AND LOOK
FOR TO SEEING THE SPONSORED TO
ALL FAIRGROUNDS REGARDLESS OF
DIFFERENT STRUCTURE THANK YOU
AGAIN FOR YOUR BIRTHDAY. THANK
YOU NEXT. BUT A LINE NINETY
NINE. REBECCA MARKETS SPEAKING
ON BEHALF OF AMERICAN FARMLAND
TRUST AND THE CALIFORNIA
AGRICULTURE NETWORK IN SUPPORT
OF SEVERAL OF THE GOVERNOR'S
PROPOSAL ISSUE NUMBER THIRTEEN
FORTY MILLION FOR THE SWEET
PROGRAM ISSUE NUMBER FOURTEEN
SIX POINT SEVEN MILLION FOR
TECHNICAL ASSISTANCE FOR
UNDERSERVED BORROWERS. AND
ISSUE NUMBER FIFTEEN THE
PROPOSAL THAT STATE AND HERE
THE PATH FREE THE REQUESTED
CIVIC LANGUAGE IN THE BUDGET TO
DIRECT FUNDS TO PROGRAMS TO
HELP FARMERS MANAGE PATH
BASICALLY. ADDITIONALLY AFTER
REQUEST. TWO POINT FOUR MILLION
TO GO TO THE FAA TO ADMINISTER
GRANT PROGRAM FUNDING TECHNICAL
ADVISERS TO ASSIST LANDOWNERS
IN DEVELOPING MANAGEMENT PLANS
SPECIFICALLY ADDRESSING. THE
IMPACTS TO THEIR AGRICULTURAL
PROPERTY YOU TO THE
IMPLEMENTATION OF CIGNA AND
LASTLY ON BEHALFOF THE
INTERCHANGE THIS ANIMAL FOOD
COLLABORATIVE. INNOVATIVE
HEALTH SOLUTIONS WE REQUEST
FIVE POINT FOUR MILLION FOR
EXPANSION OF THE SENIOR FARMERS
MARKET NUTRITION PROGRAM
ADMINISTERED AT THE FAA THE
FUNDS REQUESTED COULD FEED AN
ADDITIONAL ONE HUNDRED AND TEN
THOUSAND INR. EN FIVE MILLION
TO LAUNCH A FARM FRESH IN YEARS
PROGRAM AT CSA'S FARM TO FORK
OFFICE TO WORK IN COLLABORATION
WITH THE DEPARTMENT OF AGING TO
PROVIDE LOCAL HEALTHY FOOD THE
OLDER ADULTS IN CONGREGATE CARE
SETTING. MODELED AFTER THE FARM
TO SCHOOL PROGRAM. THANK YOU.
THANK YOU NEXT. NEXT IN LINE
FORTY THREE OR THREE PLEASE GO
AHEAD. THE MORNING CARE LIKE
HEALTHY AND MEMBERS OF THE
COMMITTEE MINDING THE PHILLY
AMERICA WITH THE CENTER FOR
ANIMAL ENERGY I'M CALLING ABOUT
HEARTBEAT ISSUE TO THE
GOVERNOR'S YOUR AMBITION
VEHICLE WELL. THEN WILL ENERGY
TO BAR OVERCOME THEIR MISSION
IN THE GOVERNOR. IN EVERYBODY
WITH THE COURT AGREED A EIGHTY
EIGHT AND SECURE. OF THE
BILLION DOLLARS. PER MEDIA
COMPLAINING ALLEGED VEHICLE
CHARGING UNDER THAT
INTERPRETATION PROGRAM. I'M
THEY CAN DEFINITELY CRUCIAL
CANADIAN. EDUCATION HAS VISUAL.
SO OFTEN LIKE THE ECONOMY AND
TIME WHEN THE. ADDITIONAL IN A
COMPATIBLE ENERGY RECOMMEND
RESTORE FUNDING FOR THE VEHICLE
PROJECT OR ARE. I WAS BACK HERE
P. IS ALWAYS OVER. ON THE MAN
THE PROGRAM WILL RUN OUT OF
FUNDS WITHIN THE YEAR. YOU ARE
HE GOT A LOT OF MODERN INCOME
HOW WOULD BE ANGRY THREE DAY
I'M NOT GOING TO SMALL AND THE
EQUITY PATRICK PROGRAM WILL
HURT. GARRISON THE STATE THANK
YOU ON. THANK YOU NEXT. NINE
THIRTY SEVEN RESET. GOOD
MORNING MY NAME IS ARGHA HER
FOR THE CALIFORNIA LIKE TO TRY
BECAUSE SENATE CALLIE TO. BY
COM ARE ON PAR B. IS TO THEM
THANK FOR TWENTY THAT COUNTY BE
A THE GOVERNOR OF THE ONE
BILLION SB TO THE EXTRA- WE
LOOK FOR TO BE ABLE DETAIL IT
IS CLEAR THE PUBLIC FOR A
LEVERAGES BILLIONS IN A THE
PRIVATE. YOU TELL AND
SETTLEMENT DOLLARS LACK OF
INFRASTRUCTURE REMAINS A HUGE
BARRIER PRESENT ON THE ROAD
TODAY AT A COMBINED WITH
GROWING LIGHT MEDIUM AND HEAVY
DUTY MARKET UNLESS THE STATE
DEMONSTRATES A WILLINGNESS TO
INVEST FOR LIABILITY. STRUCTURE
BUILD OUT. I SECOND I'LL BE
LIKE TO SEE FUN RESTORE FROM
DUTY. THAT MR THE CLEAN. REBATE
PRO. WE ARE THAT IF WE THE ALL
COME. VEHICLE OTHER STATES ARE
LIKELY TO FOLLOW. AND THE
FEDERAL OF BOTH LIKELY THE END
OF THE OF THE CAP INCENTIVE
WHICH WILL THE MARKET PROCESS
AND HELP AFTER. I WOULD LIKE TO
POINT OUT. BUT THE CLEAN FUEL.
PROGRAM HOW. IN ITEM TO SUMMARY
IS INTENDED TO BE AT THE- TO
THE LIMITED CBO FUND TOOK.
BROADER KIND OF. THAT AND FINE.
HOW EIGHTY THEORY THE COMMITTEE
APPROVED THE GOVERNOR'S
PROPOSAL WITH THE RESTORATION
OF THE C. B. R. P. FUNDING.
THANK YOU. THANK YOU AN EX.
LINE ONE OH TWO ONE HUNDRED TWO
YOUR LINE IS OPEN. THANK YOU
MISTER CHAIR AND COMMITTEE
MEMBERS MY NAME IS JUSTIN ROWS
ARE CALLING ON BEHALF OF
CALIFORNIANS FOR PESTICIDE
REFORM AND PESTICIDE ACTION
NETWORK. CALIFORNIANS FOR
PESTICIDE REFORM OF THE
STATEWIDE OKAY INTEREST
COALITION OF MORE THAN A
HUNDRED NINETY ORGANIZATIONS.
TO FUNDAMENTALLY SHIFT THE WAY
TESTIFIED ARE YOU THINK
CALIFORNIA NINETEEN NINETY SIX.
WE ARE SUPPORTIVE OF PART A
ISSUE FIFTEEN BE CHEERED MELFI
PROPOSAL AND HAVE SIGNED ON TO
A KOSHER COALITION LETTER.
REGARDING THIS ISSUE THAT HAS
BEEN CIRCULATED WITH THEIR
STAFF. HE WOULD ALSO ADVOCATE
FOR ADDITIONAL LANGUAGE THAT
ALLOCATE PORTIONS OF THE MELFI
REVENUE TO COMMUNITY PROTECTION.
THANK AIR MONITOR. STRENGTHENED
BY. PROTECTION AND SUPPORT FOR
FARMERS TO TRANSITION TO
SUSTAINABLE ALTERNATIVES. WE
LOOK FORWARD TO CONTINUED
ENGAGEMENT ON THIS ISSUE WITH
YOU AS WELL AS THE
ADMINISTRATION THANK YOU. THE
EX. NINE ONE SIX ONE HUNDRED
SIX. THANK YOU I'M DANIEL
BUILDING CAMPUS WITH THE
CALIFORNIANS FOR BIODIVERSITY
A. I. B. SUPPORT PART EIGHT
ISSUE FIFTEEN THE TRANSITION TO
SAY FIRST PATCH MANAGEMENT WE
HEAR THE LONG OVERDUE UPDATE TO
THE MILITARY. AND IN PARTICULAR
IT RESPECT THE PRINCIPLES OF
THE P. AND NOT ATTACK AND
IMPROVE THE SYSTEM WITH THAT
HERE THEY WILL NOW ADDRESS THE
DIFFERENTIAL BURDENS IMPOSED BY
THE WORKING MICHAEL THOSE
LABELED WARNING DANGER AND
POINT. AT THE MOVE FORMALLY FOR
THE REQUEST CONSIDER SPECIFIC
LANGUAGE MAKE SURE THAT BUDGET
DIRECTED TO INTENDED
CONSEQUENCES INCLUDING
PESTICIDE RELIEF FUND AIR
MONITORING HELP FARMERS IN
ORDER TO MANAGE PASS AND IT'S
ACTUALLY PRETTY GOOD SYSTEM AND
BIODIVERSITY MONITORING. TODAY
WE KNOW WE'RE SEEING ACROSS THE
BOARD AND IN FACT APOCALYPSE
BUT IN THE END OF THE DAY THAT
WE CAN ONLY DETECT THE BIGGEST
PROBLEMS THINGS LIKE
CATASTROPHIC POLLINATOR LOSSES
IN THE DISAPPEARANCE OF MONARCH
BUTTERFLIES. EVEN AS WE ALSO
ASK THAT YOU CONSIDER YOUR
BLOOD IN YOUR QUEUE FUNDING TO
COMPLETE A BASELINE
BIODIVERSITY SURVEY BUT WE CAN
DETECT INFECTED CLIENTS FIGURE
OUT WHAT'S RESPONSIBLE FIND
PRAGMATIC SOLUTIONS. THANK YOU
VERY MUCH THANK YOU THE NEXT.
WE'RE GONNA LINE WE TEN ONE
HUNDRED. AND KAREN WHITE NEEDS
AND COMMITTEE MEMBERS MY NAME
IS GRAY AND THE OF THE L.
DORADO COUNTY FAIR FOSTER WE'RE
NOT I'M PROP I'M CALLING IT THE
FOR APPROACH AND GOVERNOR
BUDGET FOR THE KERR NETWORK AND
BUT ONE AT THIS MONEY WOULD BE
AVAILABLE FOR THE ENTIRE
NETWORK QUALIFY FAIR ESTARá A
APPROPRIATE FROM THE- OR UP
WILL NEED A BEEN PART ALL.
REGARDLESS OF BUT NOT FOR ALL
THE NOT HAVE BEEN HIT BY IN ALL
NEED TO BOB NEED IF THEY HAVE
ANY OF SURVIVAL. IN COUNTY
WE'VE BEEN OVER THE- ONE OF
BACKING RIGHT AND SITE WERE
FIRED CAN'T FOUR PP
DISTRIBUTION. YEAH YES I
HEATING AND COOLING CENTERS AS
WELL AS THE HELP OF OUR
COMMUNITY. I THANK YOU FOR YOUR
TIME AND I DO HOPE THAT YOU.
HER THAT WHEN YOU VOTE ON THIS.
YOUR ALLOW ALL. HAVEN'T CAN'T
PROVIDE THANK YOU MUCH. THANK
YOU THE EX. LINE NINETY SIX
NINE SIX YOUR LINE IS OPEN.
GOOD MORNING MR CARE- COMMITTEE
MEMBERS MY NAME IS DAN JACOBS
AND I AM THE CEO OF THE
ANTELOPE VALLEY FAIR I AM ALSO
THE CURRENT YEAR THE
CALIFORNIA. I AM. I AM SPEAKING
ON BEHALF OF ITEM NUMBER EIGHTY
FIVE SEVEN. ISSUE NUMBER
ELEVEN. I WOULD LIKE TO EXPRESS
MY SUPPORT. FOR ALL SEVENTY
SEVEN PLAYERS IN CALIFORNIA.
THE PROPOSED BUDGET REGARDING
FAIRGROUNDS OPERATIONAL
SUPPORT. BUT I WOULD ALSO LIKE
TO ADD THAT WE ARE. ALL SEVENTY
SEVEN PAIRS IN THE NETWORK AND
NOT JUST STATE AFFILIATED. BE
INCLUDED. ALL FARES IN
CALIFORNIA HAVE NEGATIVELY
AFFECTED BY THE CURRENT
PANDEMIC. BEARS REGARDLESS OF
THEIR GOVERNANCE STRUCTURE OR
OWNERS. HAVE PARTICIPATED IN
EMERGENCY OP. THEREFORE WE
BELIEVE THAT THE STATE SHOULD
STAND BEHIND ALL OF. THE
ATTEMPTS TO RECOVER FROM THIS
UNPRECEDENTED PANDEMIC IN
CLOSURE OF FAIRGROUNDS
CHAIR AND CENTER. THANK YOU
NEXT MODERATE. THANK YOU LINE
EIGHTY NINE EIGHT NINE PLEASE
GO AHEAD. HI GOOD MORNING
MISTER KAREN MEMBERS TRICIA
GERINGER WITH AGRICULTURAL
COUNCIL OF CALIFORNIA UNDER
PART EIGHT ISSUE FIFTEEN WE
STRONGLY OPPOSE THE DEPARTMENT
OF PESTICIDE REGULATION. AND
THE PROPOSAL. OVERREACH AND IS
QUITE OVERWHELMING AND INSTEAD
WE WOULD APPRECIATE
COLLABORATING WITH PPR IN THE
LEGISLATURE TO ADDRESS THE
STRUCTURAL DEFICIT THE
DEPARTMENT ASIAN ON ISSUED PINE
WE APPRECIATE AND ECO CENTER
MCGUIRE AND ONE ZERO COMMENTS
INSHORE ON SPECIFICALLY MADE OF
FOR GARY AS YOUR ACCOUNT AND I
DO ARE. GIVEN BURIED IN
CALIFORNIA MEANING AND MISSION
OR IN THE- ON SUPPORT ITEMS HI.
WITH REGARD ISSUE TWELVE YOUR
LINE OF REGULATE REPORT WILL. I
SUPPORT THE PROPOSAL CAN BE BY.
SECRETARY RON FOR A ONE TIME
APPLICATION OF MY AND JACK FUND.
ON THIRTEEN WE ARE SUPPORT
MILLION FOR THE PRO FOR YOUR
ISSUE. IT SHOULDN'T BE A
PREVENT. ON THE EARLY ACTION OF
THE TWO MILLION AFTER. BEFORE
THE COMMITTEE TODAY REDUCE
WATER KEEP TORNADOES QUESTION.
AND ON PART BE ISSUE TO AFTER
SUPPORT MOYER DOLLAR ADD
ACCUMULATED BY THE DEXTER
PROJECT FOR HEAVY DUTY. THANK
YOU. THANK YOU A NECK PLEASE.
IN A OUR FINAL LINE IN Q. IT IS
A LIE. ONE THIRTEEN ONE ONE
THREE. I EVEN IMAGINE AMERICA
LONG ONCE AGAIN MY PARTY BUT
TECHNICAL A- REALLY TO WANT TO
SAY IT. BOB THIS EXISTENCE ON
FOR A EIGHT- AND TO THE BEST OF
THE KNOWLEDGE YOU AND
INFRASTRUCTURE- THE ONE SUCH AS
MEDICAL FREE EIGHT AND THE FOR
THIS PROPOSAL AUTHORIZATION
SPENT- AND YOU'RE OKAY HALF.
FOR AS A PART FARMS TO PROTECT
ON HOW. WE MUST ENSURE THAT
THEY CAN TO PLAY GERM TECHNO
AFTER STRUCTURE IS COMPLETED
IT'S PUBLIC HEALTH CLIMATE AND
AIR QUALITY STAND AS A STYLE
THAT SUCH TRANSITION DEAL WE DO
BELIEVE DOLLARS PUBLIC AND
ALLOW. THANK YOU FOR TAX. OKAY
MODERATE CHáVEZ THE END OF THE-
PEOPLE OF ACT OUR TESTIFIED
TELL. THREE TELECOM SERVICE. NO
THE PEOPLE THE CORRECT OKAY
LET'S CLOSE THE PUBLIC HEARING
AND BRING THE MATTER BACK TO
THE- THE COMMITTEE ANY FURTHER
COMMENTS ANY MEMBERS OF MOVIES
FOR GERMAN ISSUES. THREE FOUR
FIVE SIX SEVEN EIGHT. OKAY
THERE IS A MOTION BY SENATOR
DOLLY ON ISSUES THREE FOUR FIVE
SIX SEVEN AND EIGHT. MR PARKER-
PLEASE CALL THE ROLL. BY KELSEY
HI DOLLY REQUIRE STERN ALL
RIGHT. IS THERE A MOTION SENSOR
STERN ON ISSUES NUMBER ONE AND
TO START THERE'S AN ISSUE ON
THIS IS. ISSUES ONE AND TWO
PLEASE CALL THE ROLL MR HACKER.
MY CASTING BY DOLLY NOPE
MCGUIRE STERN FIVE. OKAY N.
MISTER STERN IS OUR MTION AND
ISSUE NUMBER NINE ON PART A SO
IS IT MOTION MR HACKER PLEASE
CALL THE ROLL. MY CASTING FIVE
DOLLY TODAY REQUIRE STERN ALL
RIGHT I WILL KEEP THE- ALL
THOSE MATTERS OPEN OUR FIRMEST
REQUIRE WHO'S ON HIS WAY BACK
LET'S GO TAKE PART B. THIS IS
ISSUE NUMBER ONE OF THE PUBLIC
UTILITIES AB PAPER ONE. MISTER
DALI. THERE MOTIONS. WAKE UP.
HE THE ISSUE IS THE LAST ISSUE
THAT WE COULD GO. OKAY OKAY
THEN THERE'S MUCH. MOTION BY
SENATOR STERN THE CHECKER
PLEASE CALL THE ROLL MY CASTING
HI DOLLY MCGUIRE. STERN RIGHT
OKAY WE'LL CALL KEEPER THIS IS
A PROGRESS MR STERN MISTER
KHALID THANK YOU FOR JOINING US
THIS MORNING WE'LL SEE. WE'LL
SEE YOU IN MARCH AT EIGHT
O'CLOCK IN THE MORNING OF MARCH.
AND I WILL- WILL KEEP THE ROLE
OPEN FOR A WHILE THANK
EVERYBODY FROM THE PUBLIC WHOSE
WHOSE COMMENTED- IF YOU WERE
ABLE TO- TESTIFIED OF WE ARE
HOLDING MOST MANY OF THESE
ITEMS OPEN ARE YOU CAN SEND US
AN EMAIL OR LETTER- AS- TO.
YOUR COMMENTS. WILL BE INCLUDED
IN THE RECORD OKAY MISTER
HACKER WOULD YOU PLEASE. OPEN
THE ROLE ON- VOTE NUMBER ONE
WHICH IS ISSUES THREE FOUR FIVE
SIX SEVEN AND EIGHT CALL THE F.
ABSENT MEMBERS MCGUIRE RIGHT.
THE CHECKER CLOSER ROLE TELL
YOU TO VOTE. FOUR ZERO FOUR
ZERO THOSE MATTERS ARE APPROVED
FIJI MOTION NUMBER TWO THIS IS
ISSUES ONE INTO ONE PART A
PLEASE OPEN THE WORLD. MCGUIRE
ALL RIGHT CLOSER ROLE TALLY THE
VOTE. THREE ONE THREE ONE OF
MOTIONS ARE OF MATTERS ARE
PROVED AND FINALLY I'M PART A-
ISSUE NUMBER NINE CALL THE
ABSENT MEMBERS. REQUIRE MR
HACKER PLEASE CLOSE ROLE TELL
YOU VOTE. THREE ZERO THREE ZERO
THANKS MATT MOTIONS ARE PROOF
LET'S MOVE TO PART B. PLEASE
CALL THE S. ABSENT MEMBERS AND-
THE VOTE. MCGUIRE ALL RIGHT
DISTRACTOR POSE A ROLL TELL YOU
TO VOTE. THREE ZERO THREE THREE
ONE THREE ONE ONE ARE THOSE
MOST OF THOSE MATTERS ARE PROOF
THANK YOU EVERYBODY FOR YOUR
PATIENCE AND INDULGENCE
INCORPORATION TODAY WE'VE
CONCLUDED GENDER FOR TODAY'S
HEARING- THE SENATE BUDGET
FISCAL REVIEW SUBCOMMITTEE TO
IS THAT WHAT YOU'RE.